leo is the founder of the youtube
channel actualized.org and describes
himself as a psychonaut and a mystic leo
is a proponent of idealism that is that
consciousness is fundamental rather than
material and also a proponent that you
listening to this you watching this you
are god you've simply forgotten that you
are in a similar vein to rupert spyra
though there are differences between
rupert spyro and leo click on the
timestamp in the description if you'd
like to skip this intro for those new to
this channel my name is kurt jaimongal
i'm a filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics interested in
explicating what are called theories of
everything predominantly from a
mathematical physics perspective as well
as delineating the possible connection
consciousness has to the fundamental
laws provided these laws exist at all
and are knowable to us this is an
episode that you'll benefit greatly from
watching twice perhaps the second time
at a much higher speed mainly because
many may be turned off by the certainty
at which leo expresses some of his views
however around the four hour mark leo
expresses the doubt that he has the
skepticism he has which not only
humanizes him but makes his propositions
more palatable often people reject
propositions thinking that they're
dispassionately assessing the arguments
when in fact they dislike the person
professing those statements or they
dislike the manner in which they're
professed or they dislike what they
perceive to be what their perceptions
are of the types of people that would
glom onto those ideas rather than the
ideas themselves disentangling these is
a non-trivial act but an exigent one
given our tendencies for dismissal yet
simultaneous longing for acceptance leo
and i had so much to talk about that
around the six hour mark we realized i
hadn't even gone through half of my
notes at that point so in about a week
or two weeks we'll be uploading a part
two mainly focused on him whereas this
episode is focused on his ideas if you
enjoy engaging with others in real time
perhaps just witnessing perhaps not
engaging on consciousness physics and
psychology then check the description
for the theories of everything discord
in the description is also a link to the
patreon if you'd like to support so
that's patreon.com
kurt jaimongal
a
c-u-r-t
m u n g a l
the sponsors and the patrons are the
only reason i'm able to do this full
time it would be near impossible for me
to have conversations with fidelity on
consciousness non-dualism loop quantum
gravity even geometric unity if not for
your support thank you and that link
again is patreon.com kurt jaimungle with
regard to sponsors there are three for
this episode algo is an end-to-end
supply chain optimization software
company with software that helps
business users optimize sales and
operations planning to avoid stockouts
reduce returns and inventory write downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai that drives smart roi
headed by a bright individual named
amjad hussein who's been a huge
supporter of this podcast since near its
inception the second sponsor is
brilliant brilliant illuminates the soul
of mathematics science and engineering
through bite-sized interactive learning
experiences brilliance courses explore
the laws that shape our world elevating
math and science from something to be
feared to a delightful experience of
guided discovery you can even learn
group theory which is what's being
referenced when people say that the
standard model is u1 cross su-2 cross
su-3 those are lead groups technically
visit brilliant.org toe t-o-e to get 20
off the annual subscription i recommend
that you don't stop before four lessons
and i think you'll be greatly surprised
at the ease at which you now comprehend
subjects that were previously
incomprehensible the third sponsor is
joining us for the first time it's
project transcend project transcend
makes its debut here as a method of
transmitting and storing the most
meaningful not only moments but aspects
of your life such as your values the
founder of transcend matthew phillips
had such an inspiring story about why he
created the app and how the goals
espoused by leo gura are aligned
directly with this app and with matthew
phillips goals for his life that i
appended an interview with matthew
toward the end of this podcast more on
transcend later finally i'd like to
thank jess palmer for turning me on to
leo's content thank you and now enjoy
the podcast with leo gura
i watched a few of the ufo ones which
are amusing
um but i i mostly focused on the uh sort
of theories of everything ones like
chris langan
and uh
what else was there
um
bernardo castro rupert spira
um
oh oh yeah i watched the the wolfram one
that's the last one i watched great
great great
okay why don't you briefly outline to
the audience your world view as well as
the disclaimers that you'd like to say
and how it contrasts your worldview
contrast with non-dualism
and physicalism
right
so the first disclaimer is that
the topics we're talking about today
most people don't appreciate the depth
of these topics these are very serious
and challenging topics in fact these are
the most challenging questions and
topics
that the human mind can try to answer
it's like what is existence that's what
we're basically asking when we're
talking about toes and these sorts of
things
and so um what people don't appreciate
is that this these ant these these
questions can be answered conceptually
or they can be answered in deeper ways
that actually start to involve your
psyche and your personal life and so
some disclaimers are warranted here in
that
you have to be careful if if you have a
history of mental illnesses if you have
a bipolar disorder if you have
schizophrenic tendencies if you
are depressed or suicidal or you're
prone to panic attacks and you're
generally
struggling with mental stability in your
life
then
probing these kinds of questions in the
way that i like to do
not just in a theoretical way but like
really trying to get at the the nature
of consciousness this is going to
involve your own mind and your own
psyche and it could lead to a
destabilization of your mind it could
lead to derealization it could lead to
depression it could lead to spiritual
emergencies
what stan groff calls spiritual
emergencies it can lead to
a psychotic breakdown
you know in the worst case scenarios
so you have to be careful
and
it can lead even to suicide so just
watch out if you have those kinds of
tendencies
the other important disclaimer here is
that
the things i'll be saying
will strike many people as very radical
crazy or impossible and you have to
understand that i'm not coming from a
place of ideology and i'm not asking you
to believe me or to take on beliefs
this is not what it's about and even
though we're gonna be talking about
religious topics
a lot of people consider any kind of
spiritual religious topics or new ag
topics as just
wishful beliefs that people take on
but that's not the issue here what we're
going to be doing is we're going to be
probing into our direct experience
so for me direct experience is king
and if anything that i say
you cannot validate within your own
direct experience
if it's not true for you
then it's not true at all
this is what prevents
these ideas from getting turned into a
toxic ideology or a cult
which there is a tendency for the mind
to want to do even if you like the ideas
it's still dangerous all these ideas are
very dangerous which is why they're not
talked about very often in mainstream
media or even in universities in
academia
or in religious
mainstream religious circles is because
they are psychologically threatening and
they're very easily corrupted and turned
into all sorts of ideologies the ego
will want to co-opt these ideas and use
them for its own selfish purposes and so
it's very important that
any ideas that i share with you today
that these are not used to harm yourself
anybody else and that they are not used
to start any kind of cult
like organization or to turn into any
kind of ideology
and
and in general uh just
for you kurt as you're
communing with me over the next few
hours
i know i look human to you
but
treat me as though
you're speaking to an alien intelligence
like you're not speaking to a human it's
like my world view is so radically
different from an ordinary human's
worldview i'm not claiming to be an
alien or anything
i'm just like you there's nothing really
different between me and you
but
my world view is so different from yours
and from the other people you've
interviewed
that
um
we have a communication gap here right
and so we're going to be working past
this communication gap with our language
and so just try to imagine i mean you've
you've had guests on who talk about ufos
try to imagine that you're you met
someone from a ufo like they beamed you
up into a spaceship and there you are
face to face with one of these aliens
and you have to communicate with them
somehow and they are a total they have a
totally different world view than humans
have so how do you communicate with them
how do you bridge that gap
and if anybody can do it it's you
because of how open-minded you are in
fact uh you really deserve praise for
that because what you're doing for your
audience is you're modeling what i have
taught for a long time which is called
radical open-mindedness the idea of if
you want to explore truth and reality
and you really want to get to a deep
understanding of what's going on in life
you have to
be way more open-minded than most people
are willing to be
and i don't see that as being a problem
with you
but for your audience they also need to
keep that in mind and and you guys
should be very grateful
to kurt because he's modeling for you
exactly the kind of attitude you need in
order to get answers to these big
questions that i know you guys have
the toe question
i'll put an asterisk there because you i
think you give me a bit too much credit
i
in some ways i wish i was what you
suggested but i'm not
on an unadulterated sauntering search
for the truth because the truth can be
mercilessly eviscerating and i'm too
selfish to accept it in any form that
it's willing to take
that's um
that's exactly right is most people
underestimate
how serious truth is most people try to
treat truth or even the idea of what you
call developing a veltang
a world view you know the ultimate
understanding of reality
people treat this as just like an
academic armchair pursuit it's like oh
we can just sit around a coffee table
and just kind of shoot the [ __ ]
and
and get some answers and you know just
kind of speculate about stuff
that's one pursuit
and then the things that i'm going to be
talking about you have to understand
these are not going to be speculations
these are not things that i've
speculated about these are not theories
that i have
these are things you can become directly
conscious of and that is a very
significant difference a lot of what you
see from very intelligent people people
with really high iqs
at academia and in universities
they tell themselves that they're
pursuing truth but they're really not
they're theorizing they're lost in
conceptual terrain
going deeper and deeper down conceptual
rabbit holes without really getting to
the bottom of what reality is and it
becomes an avoidance mechanism and
people who tend to be very intellectual
have a serious problem here is they
assume that oh well reality can just be
figured out using my rational intellect
and that is an assumption you have to
realize that needs to be questioned
maybe that's not true maybe there's
something deeper than just your
rationality that is required for you to
really get to the bottom of what reality
is
i agree
i also would say that with regard to the
open mindedness of this channel it's
more like i'm not in curious i wouldn't
even call myself curious because
i'm curious only about a certain subset
of subjects
reality physics
so i'm exceedingly inquisitive about
those and i use my intuitions and my
judgments which they are judgments like
kurt is
if you're not curious and you're not
open-minded i don't know who is
so i basically i'm treating this like a
professor during office hours i'm going
to voice my concerns in real time as
much as i can but i'm i'm pretty much
here to learn
and perpend in the here and now
like an immediate mentation which is why
i'm often
going to be serious i often am serious
because i'm thinking
sure yeah we need to have a dialogue
because because see also um
as much as i would like to give you all
the answers i i literally could
so the shocking thing about
what you'll if you ultimately crack the
final nut of what existence is the
shocking thing is that you will have
virtually every answer to all of the big
questions you know why does reality
exist what is it doing here where did it
come from who created it um how does it
work what is life about what is the
purpose of all this why is there
something rather than nothing like all
these questions
the the crazy thing is you can answer
them definitively
but
the problem is will you be able to
communicate them to others and that's
the thing that's going to kill you the
most is that you will have all these
profound answers but
it's not it's not as simple as just
telling them to somebody i can't just
write them in a book
it's a it's a very deeply personal
process that you must go through
to awaken yourself to these answers and
a lot of these answers are emotionally
difficult
uh
to accept
and so
my job is to guide you in that not to
give you the answers
okay we've just got through the
disclaimers and almost like about your
worldview rather than the worldview
itself but before we get to the world
view i'm curious it sounds like what
you're mentioning is one needs to embody
one's philosophy which i'm a proponent
of but i'm unclear as to what exactly
that means so can you give me
three examples of what or two examples
of what that means what does it mean to
embody a philosophy
well i don't know if i would even
i think that even that is too shallow a
way to put it to embody one's philosophy
is to
is to to take these things as philosophy
or still as a as some sort of
theoretical framework that one adopts a
set of beliefs or set of principles one
adopts and that one lives by now by all
means that's important to do in order to
develop yourself
at a practical level in the world you
know for example uh truth is an
important principle and so
in general you should try to be as
truthful as possible try to be
intellectually honest
uh try to be honest with yourself try to
be honest with others try to have high
integrity uh try not to cheat not to
steal you know these sorts of things
this would be in alignment with truth
um
other other aspects of philosophy that
one might want to um actually embody
well okay forget about that forget about
what people should embody what i mean is
what's the difference between
intellectually knowing something and
then living it so
peterson often says that you may say
that you're an atheist but you live as
if god exists so that's an example i get
you okay
um
so
it's very easy for the mind to adopt any
kind of belief system it wants like
literally people around the world have
all sorts of crazy belief systems
religious ones and secular ones
and so
um
it's easy to tell yourself that you
believe in god or you believe this or
you're an atheist or whatever you're a
materialist you're a you can even call
yourself a scientist and fancy yourself
a great scientist
these are ideas and the mind is so
self-deceptive that it loves to concoct
fantasies about itself
that's how it builds its identity that's
how it
gets a sense of who it is and what it is
so
you know oftentimes we we portray
ourselves in our mind as these really
good people who are very truthful and
very selfless and very honest but in in
reality we're not that we're very
selfish
and so um
it's a constant process of of holding
your own feet to the fire and really
being honest with yourself like am i
living up to my own ideals whatever they
are
like if you believe in god and you're a
religious person
um and and and maybe you tell yourself
that
you know it
jesus you know cared for the poor and
the sick you might have these sorts of
beliefs and you might say jesus is the
highest savior like if you're a
christian
okay that's fine but then in your own
life do you actually behave like jesus
do you actually care about the poor and
the sick or are you voting for example
for politicians who are giving tax
breaks to giant corporations and cutting
welfare programs
right you see so there's going to be a
disconnect there and a lot of people
they live their life in one way and then
in another way they have all sorts of
lofty ideas about how spiritual or how
good they are and even scientific people
do this for example in science there's a
lot of ideals about what the ideal
scientist is the ideal scientist is
open-minded and mentally flexible and
willing to entertain all sorts of ideas
but then you sit down with the scientist
and you try to talk to him about
something a little bit woo-woo and all
of a sudden his mind just shuts down and
no longer is he that kind of open-minded
scientist that he
is supposed to be or she she of course
yeah okay let's get to your world view
and how it contrasts with non-dualism
and physicalism as well
which means you may need to give an
an explanation at least a brief one of
nondualism and physicalism as well
before giving your worldview okay right
so i would contend that i don't even
that that what i'm going to be talking
about is not a worldview
there exists such a thing as absolute
truth and you can become directly
conscious of it the absolute truth is
that there is only one thing that exists
and that is infinite consciousness what
you are is infinite consciousness
and that's the only thing that exists or
could ever exist and you can become
infinitely and absolutely conscious of
this fact
and
what this means is that you are god
what this means is that literally you
have
imagined the entire universe and you're
imagining it right now so this very
physical experience that you believe
that you're having right now this is
actually a hallucination within your own
mind you are dreaming an infinite dream
which involves infinite other beings
and this is all your own creation it's a
complete illusion and if you ever stop
dreaming it it will all disappear just
like the dream you have when you sleep
at night and in fact there is no
distinction whatsoever between the
dreams you have at night and this very
experience you're having right now or
any other experience that you could ever
possibly have
and so ultimately what i teach is i
try to guide people towards the
realization or the awakening
to the fact that they are god and then
there are questions of what is god and
how did god come about and many many
nuances that come with that and we can
elaborate upon those but fundamentally
that would be my world view it's it's
actually a very simple world view if you
put it like that the only thing that
there exists is infinite consciousness
infinite imagination and this very
conversation and you sitting there
listening to me
uh are hallucinating this very
experience right now
you use that word hallucination and you
don't mind using it whereas most people
would shy away from it so why don't you
define it
well it's i actually mean it in a very
technical sense so if you go to a
dictionary and look up hallucination or
you look up the definition of what a
hallucination is
uh in a psychological textbook what
they'll tell you is something along the
lines of like this i'm paraphrasing now
it's going to be like
a
an appearance without an input so it's
sort of like
you're getting a perception but there's
nothing behind
the perceptions there's nothing sourcing
the perceptions so that's the technical
definition of what hallucination is
and that is literally
what your physical body is your physical
body is an appearance
and there is nothing behind the
appearance other than the appearance
itself
so in my worldview you might say there
is no distinction between a
hallucination and physical reality
uh the only difference there though is
that usually
colloquially when we say hallucination
we use it in a derogatory sense it comes
with a negative connotation the
connotation is that oh it's just an
illusion it's not real it's not material
it's not
physical hard stuff
this is a sort of a conventional
distinction that we've made and we use
it to smear others like oh that's just
hallucination something like that right
um
and so the way we made that distinction
is that we told ourselves
that
those hallucinations which are
consistent and persist for a long period
of time
those we call reality
and then those which are temporary or
fleeting those we call dreams or
illusions or hallucinations you see so
we've we've actually taken the entire
absolute domain of hallucinations and
we've carved it up and we've called one
half the hallucinations reality because
that's what we
live in it's consistent and then all the
inconsistent ones we've relegated those
sort of to the dustbin and we um
denigrate those so for example if you
have a vision of an angel you'll say oh
that's just hallucination
but when you see a coffee table in front
of you like i'm looking at back there
you would say well that coffee table is
real
it's not a hallucination but the only
reason we say it's not a hallucination
is simply because it's just more it's
just a more
steady form of hallucination
you watch the ctm you watch chris
langan's video and in the ctmu he
defines reality as the intersection
between different
observers so what's wrong with that
definition of reality
uh well
my view and chris lennon's you actually
have a lot in common we have some
important disagreements but we have a
lot in common i would say maybe 80
percent of our worldview is
fundamentally in con for example he says
that
uh everything is mind
everything is the the mind of god i
completely agree with that
um he has a notion called distributed
solipsism which sounds much like yours
and bernardo's point of view which is
that we're all
part of the same observer but we're also
all different at the same time it's
distributed solipsism it gets extremely
tricky the issue of solipsism will want
to leave this to ask me again about
solipsism later in this conversation
because we have to build up to it
because the solipsism question is like
the most popular and the most
controversial and the most confusing
question for people and that's because
they don't have enough the foundation we
have to build a bit of foundation over
the next few hours to get to it but but
hold on i wanna i don't wanna
i wanna address the the issue yeah
distributed solipsism you could call it
that it really much depends it's very
relativistic so it really depends on
what what level of consciousness you're
looking at it from so if you're looking
at reality from a low level of
consciousness like from that of a human
then it does seem like uh you have real
conscious agents in the world out there
who are separate from you you have other
humans animals and so forth
but as you increase your consciousness
you become more conscious and as you
approach infinite consciousness what
happens is that the boundaries between
all those observers collapse until
literally they all merge and physically
fuse into you and then at the highest
level of consciousness
at god consciousness you literally
realize that there's only one
conscious entity in the entire universe
and that is you and nothing else
and then there's many gradations in
between that so it depends upon you know
how conscious you are and you can you
can erase and play with all of these
different uh boundaries that the the
the mind imagines so one other
additional point that's important to my
world you we might say about your
previous question is that
in my world view
every single
thing
is
just a distinction within
an infinite mind
so
for example um
the difference between a um
uh between a human and an animal
uh most people most materialists would
take that as a like a a physical
objective difference a physical
objective distinction there's humans and
there's animals and that's just how
reality is
in my world view
all of those boundaries all of those
dualities can be dissolved
and so
for example
the the distinction between
reality and a dream that can get
dissolved the distinction between a man
and a woman that can get dissolved the
distinction between um
my body and this room can get dissolved
the distinction between
love and hate that can get dissolved so
literally any physical distinction or
any conceptual distinction that you can
make
they are all imaginary and they can
either be imagined or they can be
unimagined
so there is no
distinction that exists objectively as
an absolute which means that reality by
itself is infinitely infinitely free to
imagine whatever it wants and as long as
it's imagining it that distinction holds
and as soon as it stops imagining it
that distinction disappears
so for example the distinction between
you and me leo and kurt
that distinction can either be imagined
or it can be unimagined if it's
unimagined then literally there will be
no difference between leo and kurt but
as long as i'm imagining it and you're
imagining it then we can create
that
distinction and then it will appear as
though it is real and remember
reality in my model is
imagination so if you imagine it
it is indistinguishable from reality so
even the distinction between real and
unreal or reality and fantasy in my
world view
that's an imaginary distinction
it only exists if you believe it exists
and if you don't then it disappears
what are the constraints on reality
and none i'm not that i'm
that's a that's a that's a very good
question professor of chris langan's
point of view even though i'm bringing
it up again but chris langan would say
that
for people who say physics is illusory
physics is actually an integral part of
reality and that there are certain
constraints on reality and that in fact
consciousness depends on physical
matter sorry right consciousness depends
on physics in the same way that physics
depends on consciousness
right there's some partial truth to that
in that everything sort of is a two-way
street um
so i kind of hear him on that but fun my
fundamental criticism of chris langan
would be and i mean he's a he's a
brilliant guy and i would consider him
um
uh
he probably has one of the best models
of consciousness and reality that i've
ever seen of all the sort of other
mainstream academics and scientists it's
the most rigorous of all that are
similar to non-dualism
yeah so there's a lot of similarity
there but fundamentally what i would
still say is that even though he's like
maybe 80 90 right
uh in the end it's just a model it's
just conceptual so what he's done is
he's he's had a remarkable conceptual
achievement
but it's just still in the realm of
concept and i don't consider him to be
awake or to be god realized so there is
a difference between having a a really
good model of god and then actually
realizing that you are god or being
infinitely conscious these are two
radically different things and so um
i mean i think he's done about as good
as you could probably do in the
conceptual domain if you're gonna stick
to like the sort of he's playing the
academic game his writing is very
academic you know he's writing almost
like a physicist would write so as far
as that goes i mean it's fine
um but there are
way way way higher states of
consciousness that you can reach and
there is much deeper understanding that
you can have than what you would get
through chris langan's models
so what was your question again about
his model
his model doesn't say that physics is
illusory or that physics could be
whatever it likes there are actually
bounds on physics there are bounds on
consciousness
what are called mutually defining
parameters i believe so right one
definition depends on the other
um so um so all of physics is purely
imaginary um and the way you can verify
that for yourself is when you're
dreaming when you're dreaming none of
the laws of physics apply right isn't
that right
okay now chris langan would say
no there's a certain syntax that's still
there even though there are
even though a rock may float
or uh
or fire may be water
there's certain
it's more more than logic it's more like
metal logic there's certain radiological
principles
and i hear that i understand why someone
would say that
and um and
and
you could you could say that in a
certain sense
um it depends on like you it's we start
to get into very kind of like niggly
territory we're splitting hairs
but i would just say that
what humans what ordinary humans
consider logical
and logically necessary
uh
you can experience states of
consciousness where all of that flies
out the window and i would actually even
suggest that most of you have in your
dreams a lot of illogical stuff happens
in your dreams now you can still say
that well you know in your dreams if
you're dreaming
that
let's say let's say you're dreaming that
there's a chair in front of you well you
can't also if there's a chair in front
of you in your dream you might say well
it's there that means you can't also say
that it's not there at the same time
that would be like a logical
contradiction right so maybe that's what
you're saying with chris lang's word no
no no no because i believe that he has
interesting views on logical paradox and
that imagine there's a physical realm
within a non-physical realm i believe he
would call it the terminal of the
non-terminal
that
in the non-terminal so more the
non-physical realm
this is an extreme
dilution of his ideas but in the
non-physical realm you can have
paradoxes and there are what are called
self-resolving paradox but to perceive
an object
in his model would imply a syntax even
to perceive so even if you're perceiving
what's illogical that's fine that's fine
that's illogical in the terminal realm
in the sense that it's not what we
ordinarily perceive but the fact of
perceiving implies what's called a
cognitive syntax and there's something
with regard to this syntax that's
universal
yeah i mean
i mean i'm not
i'm not aware of all the technical
details of that model but um i've read
his work a bit but
but the bottom line is i would probably
agree with with much of that
it's just that you have to understand
that um
there are still deeper there are deeper
layers beyond that
so ultimately if we're going to talk
about the ultimate absolute highest
level what i can tell you absolutely
that you can personally become conscious
of is that reality is up absolutely
unlimited in that it has no constraints
on it whatsoever
this leads to paradoxes that will
completely shatter your mind like we're
talking about paradoxes that
that chris langan can't even fathom so
like
um it's kind of it's an arrogant way to
say it but i mean okay let's talk about
the dream analogy i think i brought this
up to rupert spyra i'm not sure in the
dream analogy many people who are
enlightened or use the word even
enlightenment or
that they're awake now awakening even it
implies
that
this reality somewhat of a dream state
they've gotten some higher realization
and now they're awake or at least
they're closer to being awake however if
it's analogized to a dream in a dream
when you wake up you're now in a
different place completely and in the
dream once you wake up
the people in the dream disappear
however you're still here i see you and
let's cl let's imagine that you're
awakened it's not as if
i
as a dream character who is not awakened
have seen you collapse like you've just
fallen or my entire world has
disappeared because you've been awakened
right so the analogy doesn't hold
precisely and i'm curious
because you're dreaming that's why
okay see why is it
you're awake the analogy is perfect and
in fact it's not an analogy it's
literally identical so
right now you are dreaming that you are
interviewing somebody named leo
and as long as you keep dreaming that
it's going to feel real to you and in
fact you're you're dreaming the fact
that i dream and you're dreaming that i
have a conscious experience of my own
and so when you realize that that is all
something you're dreaming
you can pop out of that dream and then
leah will disappear
for you from your point of view and
there is nothing but your own point of
view
because your god
and your point is that we have a shared
dream
who said
okay why is it it seems like we have a
shared dream
you imagine that we do
right now you're imagining that we have
a shared dream that's what you're
telling yourself
isn't that what's happening
have you ever experienced anything but
this dream of yours
let me ask another way
the problem here is that it's so radical
that your mind is unwilling to accept it
okay let me ask another question
how does one falsify this view
the reason is that it sounds like it's
exactly right the reason is it sounds
like well look anyone who's listening
you have experiences and i can say what
your experiences are even me speaking
right now is being
willed
either consciously or unconsciously we
can dissolve that divide at some point
either way it's willed by you and then
they say well no because look we can
verify and someone but i say yeah but
even these verifications are within the
realm of your experience there so in
other words there's nothing outside your
experience that seems to be the core
claim
yeah of course
yeah
look
the bottom line here is that you have to
ask yourself what is ultimately true
and so um it might seem like to some
people who are
just listening to me for the first time
it might seem like
this guy just sat down one day and came
up with some crazy ideas but that's not
how i got started the way i got started
is very much the way that you guys are
you guys i've looked at your whole
community you know the theories of
everything community um you guys are
very academically oriented
intellectually oriented scientifically
oriented rationally oriented but you're
also open-minded you know you're open
minded to ufos and things like this
which is good um
but uh
but but the and i was like that too you
know in my education was
academic philosophy my education was
engineering so uh i was very academic um
you know straight a student
all this sorts of stuff but for me the
thing was and i was extremely skeptical
i was skeptical about everything i was
an atheist from from birth base
basically i was very rational i wanted
uh rational answers for everything and
uh in my youth i would actually debate
with religious
you know kids in my school
i had a i had a friend who was a like a
devout evangelical christian and we
would argue about god and to me it made
no sense how could this guy believe
there's a god like it's just stories in
a book like what are you doing these are
just beliefs you don't actually know if
there's a god and in fact your direct
experience tells you there is no god
there is no god in your direct
experience right now for you atheists
so um
so i was like that
but then i started questioning and i
started to really like ask myself
how do i know that science is true
how do i know that materialism is true
and i started questioning and
questioning and questioning i started
questioning so deeply that um
i even started to question my own
skepticism at one point i started to ask
wait a minute how do i even know that
all this questioning i'm doing even that
is valid like how do i really know
anything
eventually what you realize if you
question deeply enough and you have to
question really deeply
um
is you will realize that the only thing
you have of reality is this bubble of
experience right now that you're
experiencing you have nothing else
everything else
is an idea
or a belief that is also happening
within the present moment and that
includes all of science so if you think
science has proven that material objects
exist that external physical reality
exists that atoms exist that you're made
of atoms science has never proven any
such thing
science is something that is happening
within your experience and if you die
tomorrow all of science will disappear
just like before you were born science
did not exist
okay there's so much man that i want to
pick apart and you know because when you
say that you're right right okay but
let's get back to this falsifiability
notion and the dream notion i'm i'm
curious in the same way that one
can't falsify that they're in a dream
can you
falsify that you're not in a dream
so can i not make the counter claim i'm
saying you're leo you're not in a dream
you think you're in a dream so falsify
to me that you're not in a dream
right well
this is this is a common um point of
attack that many uh materialists and
rationalists make it i'm not saying
you're attacking me i'm just i'm just
saying that
please don't take the fingerprints no no
by no means
attacked
yeah yeah go attack as much as you want
uh i welcome it but uh uh it's a common
point of of criticism um
but what you need to understand is that
absolute truth can't be falsified
so there's actually a deep fundamental
error within science about the notion of
falsifiability okay well hey man
right you okay your claim is that right
there you're in a dream and i'm in a
dream all there exists is simply dream
right you can't you can't false you
can't falsify that that's can't that's
not falsifiable now i'm making i'm
potentially i'm just hypothetically
making a counter claim you're not in a
dream falsify that and i can say well
that is what is true reality and that is
unfalsifiable because it's within true
absolute reality oh except it is fault
what you're saying so basically you're
saying materialism is true is that what
you're saying
i'm saying the claim is something like
look you're in a dream this is all being
dreamed up now i'm imagining another
world that's something similar to the
matrix where you're just being fed input
okay so you remember this leo
fetus somewhere just a fetus form of leo
right and all of these are just being
you're just being inputted in the same
way that you would in the matrix falsify
as your fetus that you're having input
in you from some other objective world
let's imagine that other or some other
ones yes let's just call it other yes
yeah so you can easily falsify that by
becoming more conscious
um see there's no way around
consciousness because consciousness is
everything okay
come on let's have some fun here so yeah
what do you say look i can falsify that
by becoming more conscious can i not
make the counter claim that your dream
like state or sorry your dream like
theory whatever it is i know i don't try
not to demean it by calling it a theory
but your dream like proposition is
is
is seen to be true
because you're at a higher level of
consciousness well can i not say that
there exists leo an even higher
consciousness yeah which you would see
that that dream analogy is false right
so you're basically
from your level right so you'd be you'd
be claiming in this case that i'm
self-deceived
so
basically your objection so you're
taking the skeptic position you're
basically saying
no matter how conscious you become there
can be an even higher consciousness in
which one could realize that the
previous level was just a self-deception
which would undermine the entire thing
great
right great summation so so it's very
easy to
counter that
from my position
because what i'm talking about is
infinity
and so i'm talking about absolute
infinity i'm talking about a level of
consciousness beyond which there is no
other level of consciousness so what i'm
talking about is a level of
consciousness which is infinitely
expanding forever in all directions in
all dimensions that is imagining all
possibilities occupying the entire
possibility space of everything that
could ever possibly exist including all
simulations all physics all dreams all
fantasies absolutely everything and that
is what i'm claiming
is absolute truth and it's from that
position that i'm speaking
and making claims about truth so
how do you disprove that
at the level of conscious just so you
realize how radical this is
at the level of consciousness that i'm
talking about absolute infinity
you are so conscious
that in that every
idea of falsifiability that arises even
the notion of self-deception even the
notion of being wrong
is already part of your consciousness
and therefore since you incorporate it
it can't apply to you and it can't
debunk the very thing that you are which
is infinite consciousness infinite
consciousness includes infinite
self-deception it includes infinite
number of people being wrong it includes
infinite fantasy infinite dreams in one
dream you're dreaming that you're in a
material reality and that's true for you
in that dream in another dream you're
dreaming that you weren't in material
reality but then you awoke from that
reality and now you're in some new
reality and that too is part of infinite
consciousness and this goes on forever
so you can never act so
it's infinitely meta like i mentioned
before we started talking i'm not
treating you at all skeptically in my
hand in my head i'm treating you like
you're uh
or i'm treating myself as if i'm an
imbecile and i'm just i just need to
listen to you and learn but i'm going to
voice skeptical
is good there's no problem with
skepticism sometimes people think that
i'm anti-skeptical no no i'm the most
skeptical person in the world my only
suggestion for you is be
truly skeptical if you claim to be a
skeptic so if you're going to be
skeptical be skeptical about your own
skepticism also be skeptical about
science be skeptical about logic be
skeptical about mathematics be skeptical
about your own ego mind be skeptical
about every thought that comes into your
mind because like you said you know you
can imagine that you are this uh you're
in a matrix sort of simulation and
you're being fed from the outside right
you can imagine that well
but notice you're imagining that
see so this skeptic line of reasoning
that you were giving me as sort of a an
attack against my points
notice that that's actually something
you're imagining which is exactly what
i'm saying you're imagining that that's
imagination
okay well see to me it all it's all
simply comes down to a tautology which
says you're experiencing experience at
the root of all of what you're saying
and
there's
like almost by definition you're
experiencing experience or you're
imagining imagination well sorry what
you're imagining is imaginative
well as chris langan says and i would
agree is that reality has to be an
absolute tautology so when you get to
the highest level of what reality is it
has to be a tautology it just literally
is what it is it has to be that in the
same way that you know one has to equal
one one is one
and it in that sense it's profoundly
simple but also it's very easy to
overlook because you you see as like
well one equals one that doesn't tell me
anything new that doesn't help me
understand anything right and maybe we
should get back to the point of of your
idea of you know
trying to develop a belt on song and uh
and developing a toe
because there are a lot of
methodological questions about what a
toe is and how do you develop one
for those people who are wondering like
what the heck did you just say a word
that i reference frequently on this
podcast is veltan xiaomi which is a
german word it it it literally
translates to world vantage point
something like that which sounds like
world point of view but the way that i
use it is more of an all-encompassing
world view
rather than simply because almost all of
us have world well it seems like to live
you have to have a worldview you have to
have a model but not all of us have a
consistent model that is based in
ontology and that's what i mean by
veltan xiaohu and i make an analogy
between that and theories of everything
because most physicists think of
theories of everything as a grand
unified theory that takes into account
gravity
and i take it a bit further to
incorporate some philosophy and even
psychology so just that's just an
asterisk see some materialists
would say that non-dualism is so far out
there that
it either can't be true it's
unfalsifiable or whatever they may say
but for me i view non-dualism as not
outrageous enough
because it takes into account
consciousness which is so direct to our
experience takes that as fundamental and
i'm not even sure if consciousness is
fundamental there may be something epi
conscious something that's even outside
consciousness that's not material
no there can't be because consciousness
is infinite so
uh so this is this is a very common trap
that materialists fall into and people
who start to study consciousness is that
they start to imagine things beyond
consciousness but while they're doing
that they're not conscious of the fact
that they're imagining and that it's
that itself is conscious that doesn't
matter to me because in the same way you
had a great video which i i don't i
don't believe i've watched in quite some
time on girls in completeness theorem in
the same way that a formal system can't
see outside well this is false what i'm
saying is diluting it but in the same
way that a formal system in some sense
can't see outside its own formal system
like first order logic can't see second
order logic in that same manner
it doesn't matter that consciousness
can't see outside consciousness
therefore nothing outside consciousness
exists also it doesn't matter that
consciousness is infinite because to say
that there's nothing outside
consciousness because consciousness is
infinite what is the r2 plane but two
copies of infinity you have r one that's
infinite doesn't mean anything
no
uh here's the mistake
uh the mistake is that
in terms of google's the completeness
theorem that actually that actually
buttresses my point because
google is talking about
finite formal systems
consciousness is not a finite formal
system
and therefore of course
what google's a completeness theorem
basically says is that if you have any
kind of sufficiently complex finite
formal system that can
that is capable of self-reflection
pointing back at itself it will always
lead to a contradiction and it will
always be incomplete
if you don't take certain precautions to
modify the system to prevent
self-reflection from happening because
truth is always a larger concept than
provability which is part of the reason
why provability and falsifiability is
not a good way of going about developing
your ultimate understanding of reality
um because what you're really after is
truth not proof and there are many
things that are true that you cannot
prove and will never be able to prove
and that is in fact what google proved
uh which is so brilliant about his proof
is that he was able to use proof and
turn it in on itself to to basically
prove that
proof is not the end of reality there's
always more to reality than anything you
can prove i'd more like take the penrose
point of view and say that what girdle
showed is that our mind is not a formal
system rather than that proof lies
outside of provability the space of all
that is true
lies outside a formal system provable
notion of truth that's what i would say
yeah okay yeah we agree
so but uh but back to the more important
point
so so basically
you're assuming the problem is that when
i tell you infinite consciousness you
have a picture in your mind of what
infinite consciousness is and that
picture you must realize is finite
so all your ideas of infinite
consciousness are not infinite
consciousness they're finite
consciousness
but i'm talking about actual infinite
consciousness now that what that is you
actually don't have access to it at this
point
when you get access
when you get access to it right so
when you become infinitely conscious you
realize that literally nothing can exist
outside of consciousness because imagine
that you can see the entire universe
everything imagine everything that could
ever possibly exist imagine you're
conscious of it all at the same time now
ask yourself
could there be anything beyond that that
i'm missing and if you say yes there
could that means you weren't conscious
of that thing
and that you weren't really infinitely
conscious
and when you realize that then you
realize aha
consciousness is absolutely all that
there is and there is nothing ever
outside of consciousness
and then you realize
that
there cannot be any kind of simulation
there cannot be any kind of
self-deception there cannot be any kind
of wrongness about the fact that
consciousness is infinite and absolute
because it in fact is and in fact you
are
absolutely conscious
my objection was not to
consciousness imagining something
outside itself and that still existing
within consciousness it was more about
the use of the word infinity look i'm a
stickler i'm a persnickety structure for
words and so usually when people mean
infinity when someone says
see i see this as a linguistic trick
look it's infinite therefore there's
nothing outside it that's not what
infinite means if you're using the word
infinite and i gave the example of the
r2 plane and the reason why so here's
here's the twist yeah
i know exactly what you're saying but
yeah go ahead
for the audience there's an r2 plane you
understand what you understand what r3
plane is
oh that's the real line is infinite but
that doesn't mean there doesn't exist
something outside that real line because
you can have the r2 plane and it's a
forgetful functor technically speaking
to go from the r2 plane to the r plane
you've forgotten some information so the
r1 plane is the r1 is embedded in the r2
plane and so you can have something
that's infinite but still not all
encompassing so maybe the word that is
trying to the word that people would
like to use instead of infinite is all
encompassing so that's different than
the word infinite
so yeah there's definitely a problem
here with language um
and the the problem here is that people
don't have a proper understanding of
what infinite is because nobody
virtually nobody you know none of your
professors none of your teachers none of
the books you've read none of the people
who wrote them were actually infinitely
conscious therefore they have no idea
what they're talking about everything
they're talking about is actually finite
so
let's uh for those of you who are math
nerds and logic nerds
hopefully you've heard of george cantor
and k or uh gary cantor was the
developer of set theory
um what
what has become modern set theory
basically
and um he was one of the first
in the in the last century in the in the
late 1800s he basically came up with the
idea of multiple orders of infinity so
you have the natural numbers or just
like the integers that's the integers
you know one two three four five six
seven though that's one order of
infinity
but then you can take every integer and
you can you can find an infinite number
of decimal point
numbers in between the numbers zero and
one and so
cantor basically proved that that
infinity is actually larger than the
infinity of all the integer numbers and
so
he made some ingenious proofs that
basically showed that you can have
higher and higher orders of infinity
uh and that's all right and what you're
talking about with your r1 r2 planes and
all that that's just
infinity order one infinity order two
three four five and that's all within
the mathematical symbolic conceptual
domain you have to understand that's a
conceptual infinity
then
uh gary cantor if you studied his work
ultimately you know what's the natural
conclusion if you say well
there's one size of infinity then
there's a second size of infinity
there's a third size fourth size even a
bigger size and a bigger one than that
what is the natural conclusion
you say well surely there must be an
absolute infinity in infinity of all the
possible infinities so it's an endless
list of all infinities which keeps
growing forever and gay or cantor
called that
absolute infinity and he gave it the
symbol omega and by the way by the way
he was a deeply religious man
and he if you read his biography and
stories about his life
um he called
omega he called it god
and and and a lot of people at the time
his his colleagues mathematicians
scientists logicians and so forth they
thought he was crazy they did not accept
the idea that there were even multiple
orders of infinity he thought they were
do he was doing pseudoscience
until eventually you know finally he won
over after his death i mean he died in
ill repute he did not die happy that
everyone accepted his his set theories
and all this most of his colleagues
didn't accept it he died and then it
took
some decades and centuries uh and then
people came around to it and opened
their minds but look even what gay or
cantor called omega absolute infinity
that was still all within the within the
domain of concept concepts and numbers
so that is not what i mean by absolute
infinity that's that's peanuts compared
to what i mean what i mean is the
following when i say infinity so imagine
all of mathematics
imagine all of current mathematics and
all the mathematics that will ever be
done ever in a trillion years of human
existence so imagine that the our
universe goes to its heat death right
like in
i don't know 80 billion years there's a
heat death everything dies in this
universe all the math that humans do up
until that point
that will be an infinitesimally small
chunk of absolute infinity but that's
just mathematics now i want you to
imagine
all of physics that humans will do in
that entire span of the universe
that will just be a grain of sand within
absolute infinity now i want you to
imagine all the movies that every human
can possibly invent so i want you to
imagine the entire possibility space of
every movie
that means star wars
the godfather jurassic park
blah blah blah blah all the movies but
i mean even more than that imagine for
example every possible way that jurassic
park could have been filmed but wasn't
because jurassic park is just one way to
film a movie right you could have had a
million different jurassic parks with
different actors different dinosaurs
different settings different colors
different framing different shots
different words different dialogue
different story different length like
imagine
a million different jurassic parks that
are just different from each other by
one second like each movie is just one
second longer one second longer one
second a million of those i understand
right so so if you look at it just the
domain of what jurassic park is can you
see how that itself is its own sub
infinity
because you can literally have an
infinite number of different jurassic
parks
that's just jurassic park so that is a
sub and that's sub infinity within the
infinite
of the entire um film space right so
imagine every possible film that could
ever be made that could be displayed on
us on a screen
i mean we're talking about
crazy numbers of complexity here right
that's the infinity of film now imagine
the infinity of music every sub-genre of
music jazz is infinity of jazz
rock is infinity of rock
rap is an infinity of rap hip-hop is
infinity of hip-hop now imagine every
possible genre of music that could ever
be imagined
so that would be the infinity of all
possible genres of music and so
basically now this is going it's going
larger and larger and larger and now
imagine the possibility of every single
possibility that is
ever possible to exist
that is absolute infinity
okay and now ask yourself the question
what exists outside of that
right and the answer will be nothing why
because you what would exist
what what would there be outside of
everything
everything that you have given me right
now were examples of imagination
for example like imagine so-and-so
imagine stone so now let me play i'm
putting on the hat of someone who's a
beyond a spiritual guru let's say
i can't even i don't have a word for it
an alien let's say the tellurians which
are the regular people the highlights
and then we have the spiritual gurus and
then i'm let's i'm putting on the hat of
a mountaineer i don't know why i'm
calling it a mountaineer whatever
i'm thinking of a mountain that has a
hat okay
let's imagine that
this
person
says
there exists something outside what you
could perceive what you can imagine
what's consciousness
wrong
right now your proofs have proven me
wrong lie within the realm of
consciousness
no no but but no you you
that's what girl told you is that you
can't prove that you can't prove
truth truth literally cannot be proven
because truth is larger than proof so
when you come up with that objection
that oh prove to me for example that god
exists
you're being stupid excuse me but you're
being stupid because you haven't grasped
the profound metaphysical and epistemic
implications of google's the
completeness theorem you can't do that
you can't even do that within
mathematics let alone within the larger
system
okay
sorry leo i don't mean to become bad of
at all no you're good okay go and
don't hold back sure i'm not trying to
say that god doesn't exist i'm saying
that the arguments that you've given
about consciousness being infinite and
therefore all that there is
i'm saying there exists something
outside consciousness prove that
incorrect so i'm saying there's
something epi consciousness that
consciousness is not aware of because
consciousness can only be aware of
awareness or experience i'm saying no
well no i'm like i'm sorry i'm putting
on my mountain hat so i'm saying as the
mountain hat as the mountain guru
prove that wrong here's the problem i'll
tell you i'll tell you what the problem
is
the problem is that when you say
consciousness and the way people use the
word consciousness they don't really
know what they're talking about when you
say consciousness you're assuming a
finite thing for example your
your your notion of consciousness comes
with metaphysical and epistemic
assumptions and baggage it's extremely
loaded so for example you
assume that consciousness is something
that arises from living beings
at least when i say you i just mean in
general people us as a culture we assume
that we assume that animals have
consciousness maybe plants have
conscious although some people would
even deny that but then like we say like
a rock doesn't have consciousness and so
therefore when you have this sort of
picture in your mind then it seems like
well yeah of course you can be conscious
of everything but then you know a rock
is conscious of nothing and iraq still
exists outside your
consciousness but the problem is is that
that's an assumption you're bringing
that metaphysical baggage in with your
idea of consciousness that is not what
consciousness is consciousness is not
something that arises from neurons it is
not something that comes from the brain
it is not something that living beings
have it is
it is absolutely transcendental which
means that
consciousness is not limited by any
physical
constraint or any logical constraint of
any kind and literally anything that
exists must exist within consciousness
as a form within consciousness so the
problem is that you're not conscious
enough to realize that and so
really what our what our conversation
yeah where a conversation breaks down
it's sort of like this
imagine that you have a donkey
and then
we come to the donkey and we bring him a
mirror
and we show the donkey the mirror and we
try to get the donkey to we like we
point the donkey's face at the mirror
and we say this look this is you
do you see that this is you in the
mirror and and then like we hit the
donkey and we keep hitting the donkey
donkey's looking at the mirror but he
doesn't understand what we want because
he doesn't literally have the enough
consciousness to recognize what we're
trying to show him to be able to
recognize his own reflection in the
mirror right and so
trying to explain consciousness to
somebody who's in a low state of
consciousness not an infinite state of
consciousness is literally impossible in
the same way as trying to get a donkey
to recognize himself in the mirror the
donkey cannot recognize himself in the
mirror because he's locked into a state
of consciousness that is not high enough
to allow for that degree of
self-awareness
so likewise right now you are locked
into a state of consciousness that is
not high enough to allow you to have
enough consciousness of what i'm saying
which is that literally
nothing can exist outside of
consciousness you are imagining things
that you think could exist outside of
consciousness as a possibility
and then you're using that to be
skeptical
but you're not conscious of the fact
that that is within the realm of
consciousness see all skepticism is a
function of consciousness
are you getting that yeah yeah yeah i'm
i hope that you don't think i'm being
unnecessarily captious but when i say
that look let's take this analogy the
donkey can't see a level above it and
because of that you can't explain some
it has no way of understanding or
comprehending that
there's all-encompassing
consciousness well in that same way can
i not make an analogy and say i'm not
claiming to be a god enlightened at all
or above gun light obviously imagine i
put on my plato hat i should have said
plato instead of mountain for some
reason because platonic sounds
interesting so imagine i put on my
platonic hat and i say there exists
something even above consciousness
leo that right you within your
consciousness you're only looking at
your own mirror in the same way that you
gave me an argument about the donkey i'm
saying the same is happening to you
there's something epi conscious you
cannot be aware of it right yeah you're
you're you're saying that but i'm saying
that to you
you see you see how this game is played
so it really is a game of trickery so
there can be an infinite number of
arguments that we can build back and
forth to try to
jump over each other and that's exactly
what happens within the conceptual
domain because we're in the conceptual
domain so yeah you can make an argument
that i'm self-deceived and then i can
make the counter argument that no you're
self-deceived you're self-deceived that
i'm self-deceived and then you could say
ah but i'm gonna go meta and i'm gonna
say that
leo is self-deceived that i'm
self-deceiving myself about leo's
self-deception and so we can we can go
up for infinity that's what infinity
means we can keep going right okay so
who is right in this circumstance
platonic the guy with the play-doh hat
or the girl with the play-doh hat or the
or the god-realized person of the god
consciousness god realized person
well you have to you have to understand
what god realized is god realizes not
sort of a static state that you reach
and that you're there
um god realizes infinitely meta so what
god realized means is that you're
conscious of the fact that this is an
infinite regress of self-deception that
we can keep going down forever until
we're both dead right that's what god
realized means so it's a meta function
so god can't be locked into a single
form so one of the problems here is that
you're trying to lock god into a form
like well god is what leo says it is
it's like no god is that plus more
god is is
always infinitely meta it's infinite
means it's endless that means you can't
ever encapsulate it into any kind of
model so everything that leo is saying
is just a finite portion of what god is
any description of god that i give you
is always going to be a partial
aspect of god i guess what i'm saying is
it's actually extreme it's more simple
than that it's more like
someone is claiming something that's
true but unfalsifiably so and you're
also you're saying i agree kurt i agree
with that and then i'm saying
right within this realm of us arguing
over here over zoom over words even you
can't convince anyone you've said this
too which is like i'm agreeing with that
you can't convince anyone with
justification but in some sense we're
trying to and so in any way that you're
convincing me i can put up a counter
argument that you can't prove and then
you could say well i can't prove but you
can't prove slightly above so it's like
any time you give me a number a i can
give you a plus one and then you could
do the same
right
just that alone is evidence of infinity
because you can see that it goes on
forever that's just a minor infinity
within absolute infinity but uh look um
do you agree that one equals one is that
true
yeah well that equals it by definition
by definition of what equals means and
by definition of what one means however
however the reason like look i'm so i'm
such a a carp but but prove it prove to
me that one equals one
how would you do it
is it falsifiable falsify to me that one
equals one the way that i can falsify
that
is if you take some other claim that you
claim to be true
okay so let's say you take the there uh
there's another claim that you claim to
be it could be any claim so let's say
that there exists a paper here
okay actually let's make it a more
numerical claim so you claim that 329
doesn't equal 300. let's say you claim
that that's a claim so then i can prove
to you that one equals one in the sense
that if one were not to equal one i can
prove to you what you claimed was not
true
so a proof by contradiction are you
saying like a reductio ad absurdum the
reductio ad absurdums they have a
phyllis they have a connotation that's
more
they i don't like the word
i'd absurdum because it implies that you
already have an idea as to what's absurd
of course yeah absurd the notion of
absurd is completely relative
the notion of absurd is absurd yeah yeah
yeah it's more about if you were to
write there's so much loaded in what
i've just said which is classical logic
so you have to have the law of excluded
middle you have to accept that you can
have proofs by contradiction which is
actually contested in
in mathematics heavily so what i'm
saying is so many years to prove to me
that reality isn't
contradictory prove to me that there's
no not a single contradiction within
existence
i mean see there's there are so many
things that uh that are absolutely
impossible to prove or to falsify
um
uh and and you know the most difficult
things to falsify are the ones that are
true
you see it's not an accident that truth
can't be falsified so
while we're on the topic of
consciousness it seems like social media
is antithetical clearly to the common
refrains of what it means to live a
meaningful life that is to not be
distracted to pay attention especially
to the present moment to love to not
judge
to show clemency social media as it
stands breeds disconnection unhealthy
competition feelings of merciless guilt
hours of time wasted if not days i don't
know how to transform it i don't know
how to revolutionize it but recently i
met with the founder of project
transcend and he's building in that
direction it focuses on helping you
capture and articulate aspects of who
you are that you would like to pass on
to your children to your unborn children
to your unborn grandchildren such as
what you believe what you'd like to
share such that they can experience it
in the same way that i don't know what
my parents were like when they were
around my age all i have are photographs
i don't know what their values were i
don't know how they think i don't know
how what their body language was like
what their intonation was like i know
what their stories are now about then
but that's decidedly not the same sign
up for early access at
projecttranscend.com
to reserve your spot space is extremely
limited it may end up doing for social
media what openai did for language
processing at least it's certainly a
step in the right direction for more on
them keep watching till the very end and
i'm appending an interview with the
founder matthew phillips of transcend
see the beauty with truth is that it's
completely unshakable once you are
conscious of the truth nothing will
shake you now you could say well that's
just you're deluded
and that's right you can be deluded so
don't get me wrong the idea and the
problem you have here is basically
you're saying to me leo self-deception
is a really big
problem within epistemology
how do we know anything at all uh
shouldn't we be more humble you know
you're here saying that god is this and
you've reached the end of infinity on
all that like but shouldn't you be more
humble i mean what if you're what if
you're in a simulation what if you're
deceiving yourself what if you're
fooling yourself what if you're just
hallucinating whatever right so um
i totally get you
i am the biggest proponent of
studying the mechanics of self-deception
so when you are saying that maybe leo
all the stuff you're saying is
self-deception my counter to that is to
say that
from your point of view it can certainly
seem that way and you should take that
possibility seriously so
your audience members they don't know me
they have not experienced what i've
experienced they don't know what i've
become conscious of so from your point
of view i could be self-deceived i could
be a grifter i could be a cult leader i
could just be
mentally ill
or i could even think that i'm saving
the world but just be fooling myself
from your point of view that all could
be true
which is why you need to investigate for
yourself what is true and ultimately get
to reach your own conclusion that's the
difficulty about absolute truth is that
you can't give it to anybody it has to
be reached by you which can take 10 20
years of deep investigation and
and the most important aspect of that
investigation is studying self-deception
but you have to be very careful with
self-deception because within
self-deception there are deeper
self-deceptions and one of the
chief
self-deceptions that tricks people up is
the self-deception of skepticism i don't
know why it also has to be
self-deception why can't this simply be
nashians and i prefer nations to
ignorance because ignorant nations what
do you mean what do you mean by that so
ignorance is like you
almost like you willfully choose not to
know but nesting simply means you just
don't know it's like almost like
obliviousness but obliviousness has a
connotation too
so i would say so you're saying it's
ignorance or what or or nations
no i'm saying it's nations because
nations is more like you just simply
don't know
no
no no no
no but but it's way it's way worse than
you simply don't know in fact the
problem is not that you don't know the
problem is that you know
you it's the problem is that what you
know is wrong
so see
we let's let's talk about the
epistemology here because we kind of
jumped right into the deep end of the
pool about infinity and all this and we
basically jumped into metaphysics but
before you can do metaphysics first you
have to do epistemology because if you
get your epistemology wrong none of your
metaphysics is going to be right and
epistemology is just the how do you know
anything at all question
like literally how do you know anything
and so if you're not taking that
question seriously you cannot develop a
toe of any kind and you cannot have a
metaphysics of any kind because how
would you know your metaphysics is true
right yeah
are there hierarchies and nature true
like i know there seems to be
hierarchies at our level but then at
this god-realized level let's say the
most true level are there hierarchies
what what do you mean by hierarchies
well give an example good versus bad up
versus down
okay that gets us into metaphysics but i
can quickly answer that um
so
hierarchies are imaginary so they exist
as imaginations um
but at the at the absolute level what
happens is that
consciousness
realizes its own oneness so deeply that
it realizes that all distinctions are
uh imaginary and all those distinctions
dissolve and then all you're left with
is just a pure unity it's a pure
formless unity of pure consciousness
in which every distinction is basically
blended together into uh into
a unity
uh and so
by the way you know for those of you who
are trying to figure out your toe and
all that
uh one question you should be asking is
what is the substance of reality
what is the substance of what everything
is made out of
is it energy is it quarks is it atoms is
it molecules is it
information
is it
whatever else you know
um
maybe it's a
charge maybe it's uh
strings yeah no maybe numbers a lot of
mathematicians believe it's all formulas
and numbers at the bottom right or maybe
you believe it's a computer or maybe you
believe it's a
something like that
um
so see it can't be any of those that's
what you have to realize so this is this
is something i can help you guys with
because this will solve this will save
you 10 20 years of your life right here
if you realize this one point
is that the actual substance of reality
you can become directly conscious of
what it is
and what it is is it's nothing
the substance of reality is literally
nothing and the reason it has to be that
way is because everything you call a
substance is actually a distinction
within
consciousness so for example when you
say
reality is mad of matter you're you're
creating a distinction between matter
and non-matter
and you're creating both of these and
you're saying reality is this thing but
not that thing
conscious is doing that when you say
reality is
information you say well it's
information but then it's not the
opposite of information whatever that is
in your mind and so you make that
distinction or you say it's strings well
if it's strings then it's also not
not strings it's not the opposite of
strings and so you're always thinking in
these opposites and this is the
fundamental problem with science and
with academia is that it's always
thinking in these in these opposites and
these do i call these dualities
literally every single scientific notion
is a duality
and because of this you're never able to
access the actual substance of anything
because all you have are distinctions
and you're not realizing that what
reality is is it's not one particular
distinction that grounds all of their
distinctions but rather what reality is
is nothing other than the sum infinite
total of all possible distinctions
reality is not made up of atoms your
body's not made of atoms strings energy
quarks none of that
reality is made out of distinctions
which is
in other words to say differences
literally literally
the literally the difference between any
two things
is what makes that thing a thing yeah i
agree
so
um
so why does that mean that the substance
of reality is no thing nothing
by sorry by the way when you say nothing
do you literally mean no thing or do you
mean something else well it literally
can't be spoken so what does match can't
be used can't be spoken right because
because eva you see even nothing is a
distinction because nothing is relative
to something that's the distinction and
that is not what i mean when i say
nothing when i say nothing i'm talking
about the thing that actually can't be
spoken
so let me explain your question of um
why does it mean that that the substance
has to be nothing the reason the
substance has to be nothing
is because
so if everything is a distinction
ask yourself what is the distinct what
are the distinctions made out of
other distinctions
no
because even the idea of a distinction
is already
involved in this problem it creates a
circularity problem a self-reference
problem and a paradox because
a distinction
cannot be made out of a distinction
because distinction itself is a
distinction let me say where i agree and
then where i find it muddling
when you say that this can't be spoken
about i'm in such agreement with you
that if what you're saying is to be
believed and spira as well then rupert
spire that is then
all of what we're doing right here is so
fruitless because look one of the ways
we say the individual doesn't exist
that you the person who's listening is
because well let's take the materialist
point of view and that
your collection of atoms while those
atoms are blurred okay so where do you
begin in the universe
where does the universe end and you
begin and then you say well okay well i
can't put a distinction and then because
you can't place a border
then you can say that essentially that
the that the words themselves are
meaningless and i can't convince you
all all words are relative so one of the
problems here is that we're entangled in
language and language is a is an
absolutely relative and distinct uh and
and dualistic rather not to say but
dualistic um scheme so every word in the
english language including every
word in the
english language
is a distinction
see see you can't get around this
problem with language because language
itself is constructed from distinctions
everything is constructed from
distinctions so we can't use language to
understand what a distinction is you
have to go underneath language the
problem is so profound you guys when
you're trying to figure out your toe
what you don't understand is that the
problem is so [ __ ] profound it's way
more profound than you realize
because even the language you're using
and the thoughts you're thinking to
construct your toe are all distinctions
you're creating so literally you're
imagining your toe into existence
imagination is nothing other than the
imagination of distinctions that's what
imagination is that's the technical
definition of imagination
so that means that for example
the difference between a chicken and a
coffee table
that difference is something you're
imagining that's what i'm saying
i'm not just saying this in the mind i'm
saying that if you take a physical
chicken and you take a physical coffee
table and you put them next to each
other see you as a human have been
trained to believe that these are two
separate and distinct
things that exist independent of your
mind and what i'm telling you is that
your mind is constructing the physical
difference between a table and a chicken
and that's why they look different to
you
and if the chicken and the table were
not different they would literally be
one thing
and that thing would be nothing
it would and and that nothing would be
infinity because infinity is nothing
because the distinction between
something or rather everything and
nothing is itself going to collapse into
a unity which is prior to our word
nothing and something
i agree that if your worldview is to be
taken seriously inspire whether or not
you want to call it a worldview or a
valtton song or whatever it may be
because even to give it a name implies
that if there's a delineation which
implies there's something it's not and
so on and so on we have objections there
but let's say you're to be taken
extremely seriously what if the heck is
the point of speaking at all
like what is the point of argumentation
it gets to nowhere well well first of
all speaking
speaking
speaking was not designed for philosophy
speaking was designed for simple things
like i want to eat chicken that's why
you speak
you want to eat a chicken you know you
want to buy a coffee table that's why
you speak and in that sense it's
practical and it's useful just like you
know classical newtonian mechanics
what's the point of it if it's false i
mean we know it's false we know there's
no such thing as absolute velocities and
absolute distances
it's all relative right these are gross
over these are gross oversimplifications
though i would have objection there
would you yeah object to the notion that
there exist
how how how how tall how tall are you
if you don't mind saying oh yeah no i
don't mind i'm five eight five nine or
so
i'm five i'm five eleven on tinder so
okay
so you believe
so you believe that that's your that's
objectively true no no what i mean is i
imagine that the way that you would go
about dispelling the notion of length
would be using special relativity
however there's a contradiction between
special relativity and the plank length
because look if you have a shortest
possible length in which we know that
physics breaks down
then what are you going to do when you
accelerate at a velocity higher than
that can you have smaller than the plank
length so they're so they're that's
false by the way there is no there is no
bottom to reality there's no mod there's
no minimum length
the reason we can talk about that
but the reason i'm objecting is only
because
i'm being uh
most people would say well relativity
and einstein and so but actually if you
examine that you'll see that special
relativity contradicts
well not contradicts but it's unclear
no okay but forget forget relativity uh
in the gi einstein sense but just let's
let's really think about this
existentially
do you understand that there is no such
thing as length
unless you have
two objects
which are relative to each other
without which length does not exist as a
thing i don't know i don't know i don't
know about that
look what you're saying is look the word
length has units attached like you are
five meters
well what is a meter a meter is uh
somewhere in france and then we go with
that and we take that and we place it
five times next to something okay so you
have this conformal scaling and you
can't have well actually
length length is more fundamental than
units so i'm just talking about the the
abstract notion of length regardless of
units so even to have a notion of what
length is you have to understand that
this is a relative notion you need to
have a start point and an end point to
have length
right you agree yeah
okay so
so
so length depends on how you choose your
start points and end points
yep
without which there is no such thing as
length yep
so length is a distinction that we
imagine or create
wow
and then and then
but but then but in einstein's model
your length differs depending on how
fast you're moving right right right
right i mean like right right right
right so length so your height is
literally not five eight your height is
five eight assuming relative to
us me and you being in the same
reference frame of moving at the same
velocity relative to each other
there's something so there is and there
are invariants not all that exists is
relative in einstein's point of view
there are invariants there's rest mass
there's even
it's not quite true to say rest length
but you can come up with something
called einstein wasn't einstein wasn't
infinitely conscious
[Laughter]
so take einstein general relativity and
now expand it out to make into what i
would call absolute relativity which
means that everything is absolutely
relative so everything is relative to
every other thing
without which you have nothing
so what i'm talking about look i'm
actually talking about a profound notion
here called ontological relativity this
is actually a notion from willard quine
a famous philosopher from analytic
philosophy says this is not some wubu
guy he has a paper called two dogmas of
empiricism really good paper i recommend
you guys read it if you're serious about
toes especially the last two pages of
that paper where he talks about
his conclusions on ontological
relativity so basically what ontological
relativity means is what i just told you
so if you have a if you have a chicken
and you have a coffee table
and this is now my interpretation this
is not quite saying it but this is how
i'm framing it if you have a chicken and
a coffee table ordinarily we assume that
there is such an object as a chicken and
a coffee table
these are just like
objective things that exist independent
of our minds independent of how we look
at the world independent of who we are
independent of consciousness
there is something there and what i'm
saying is that there's nothing there at
all
outside of how your mind perceives that
thing
and that difference that you imagine
there is between a chicken and a coffee
table is literally what a chicken and a
coffee table are and if you ever realize
that there is no difference between a
chicken and a coffee table that's
something you're imagining that
difference will disappear and literally
you will not be able to see a chicken
and a coffee table they will merge into
a single thing at the physical level i
don't even think you need to go that
that advanced i think even a scientist
well maybe not the traditional scientist
but a true scientist one who doesn't
take off
a stance on philosophy would say that
the distinction between an electron and
a proton is merely one of predictivity
that we haven't a formula for this and
we can predict so and so but in reality
it's not as if there exists something
separate between a proton and an
electron other than ours placing
a certain framework on it so that we can
predict and have formulas
but i'm saying something more profound
than that scientist so while we might
agree that science is all instrumental
that idea is called sort of basically
instrumentalism this idea that it's sort
of a pragmatic notion of of science
which is like what science all that
science really is if you want to be
technical about it is just measurements
you're making measurements between
different things and then you're
comparing them and then as long as your
measurements are being used consistently
then you've got something like a science
and you can make certain predictions
that's essentially and then and then on
top of that you add a bunch of
conceptual baggage too so there's plenty
of that going on in science it's not
just measurements but
it you can boil it down to measurements
if you want to be extremely rigorous
about it but what i'm saying is
something much more profound than that
what i'm saying is that
even though at a conceptual level you
can understand this idea of distinctions
and you might even agree with me and you
might say yeah leo it's all distinctions
but what i'm saying is that you're not
conscious
that this is the case
you're thinking it's true but you're not
conscious of what a distinction is so
the
you can actually have an awakening into
what a distinction is and when you do
you will actually be directly conscious
of the uh of the the one true substance
of existence which is
nothing this is where language is so
tricky leo because if i'm i like i said
i believe or i agree with much of what
you're saying but is we can't use
language because so much of what you're
saying there are caveats to it and then
and contradictions within it but then
you would say well of course like the
word the realm of language is the
improper domain for this it's experience
or perhaps psychedelic experience
whatever it may be because even there
you can one can say that
sorry but but that that's exactly how it
should be i mean you would you would you
should you should intuit that this must
be the case because after all language
is not
fundamental to reality now this is also
where i would disagree with language
right says that it is
um
language is a language is a distinction
within reality
to have language you need to have
non-language so you can't say that
reality is language because you also
need to have non-language without which
the notion of language doesn't even
exist
um
to have non-dualism do you have to have
dualism
uh yeah you do actually
as a um
non non doulas
when you say nondualism what you're
saying is absolute infinity and absolute
infinity entails every possible finite
thing
which includes
every possible delusion and fantasy and
non-dua and including all dualities so
the reason we have duality is because we
have non-duality which encompasses it so
this is the yin yang symbol right the
yin yang symbol is
the white half and the black half with
little dots in each half
showing that there's a little bit of
white in the black and black and the
white right and then the you can also
what people don't see about the yin yang
is that it's it's a unity it's not just
white and black together
there's an over there's you can imagine
a circle that combines the two together
and that would be non-duality combining
the duality
so yeah non-duality and
necessitates duality
does
god necessitate non-god or does
existence necessitate non-existence
it's a little tricky because your
concept of existence is a relative
notion of existence so there's existence
that's absolute existence and there's
existence which is relative existence
at the absolute level there's no such
thing as non-existence there's only
existence existence is an absolute
existence is infinity existence is
consciousness
there's no difference between
consciousness and existence
so literally the only thing that can
happen is existence does consciousness
necessitate
non-consciousness it does if you have a
relative notion of consciousness so this
is also a problem is that most
materialists and scientists and
academics when they talk about
consciousness they're talking about in a
relative sense in a dualistic sense
consciousness and non-consciousness so
like they talk about anesthesia or
losing consciousness when you get hit in
the head or stuff like that
this is a relative notion of
consciousness then there's an absolute
consciousness which cannot have an
opposite so the definition of what an
absolute is an absolute is something
that has no opposite
so god has no opposite
consciousness has no opposite at the
absolute level
can you explain your two levels of love
at least briefly to the audience
and also why because i've heard you
i've heard you articulate that love
level one love is what's rudimental but
then at the same time you just said
nothing is rudimental so there must be
an equivalence between love and
nothingness but either way explain the
two levels of life yeah
love is nothingness
so love is a very profound concept most
people think of love as some hippie new
age idea or a human feeling see again
love is one of those concepts that we
bring a lot of metaphysical baggage into
for example when we say love we assume
here's what the materialist assumes is
that love is an emotion
that is created by neurons in the brain
that is
a property of higher order mammals and
living beings
and there there would even be doubt in
this in this model there would even be
doubt whether like a cricket has love
does it do you think a cricket has love
can experience love
i don't know i i would imagine it's an
extremely low form of love if it does
right and then would a rock experience
love you would say no
i'd imagine it's like one percent of a
percentage right i mean
and and that would already require you
to to be in the woo-woo territory
because because if because if you if you
tell a serious scientist that a rock
experience is love they'll kick you out
of their university you know it's so
strange because
these ideas that you and i are talking
about they seem to be
gaining more and more acceptance in a
stranger that is
that is true at least with itt
integrated
no iit integrated information theory of
well because we're talking about it
that's why that's almost like pan
psychism so in some sense every single
part of the universe's conscious is just
at different degrees and that's a more
scientifically accepted theory of
consciousness so it's so strange that
much of what you and i say to the
traditionally skeptical debunking
materialist mindset it seems like
all of it is so false that it's
ridiculous we're even talking about it
but that's even that's
that's not true from a scientific
perspective i just want to it's good
it science is always evolving so of
course the ideas we're talking about if
they are true if what we're doing here
actually has any kind of validity or
merit we should expect that science
every decade will become more open to
these ideas because they're inevitably
true
yeah let's get to these two levels of
love
right um so what was i saying about love
yeah so so
usually we think of love as an emotion
love is not actually an emotion
love has a
is a metaphysical property of existence
so what we really mean by metaphysical
love of which the emotion is just a
little offshoot it's just like a little
bit of like um almost like think of a
volcano you know
where does the lava come from in a
volcano it comes from the core of the
earth it's a very deep
thing the lava it literally the insides
of the earth are pouring out but if
you're standing on the surface you only
see a little a little bit of lava
popping out and you can't fathom how
deep it goes
so likewise with love us humans you know
when you love an object let's say you
love what do you love you love bacon i
don't know what's your favorite bacon
man you know just between you and i
my goal for one of my goals for life is
to make
enough money that i can buy what's
called ready-made bacon and not feel bad
about it because i don't i love bacon
but i don't like to cook it because of
the mess and i would love it if i could
micro i don't think i've bought
microwavable bacon once in my life
because it's eight dollars when regular
bacon is four dollars and i would like
to get to the point where i can buy
ready-made bacon and not feel bad about
it at least not at the level of spending
money i feel bad that there's extreme
suffering that goes on behind the scenes
to produce that bacon but let's put that
aside
yeah i i wouldn't buy that because it's
like in plastic isn't it wrapped in
plastic or something yeah they're
writing in the ready-made bacon what's
the distinction between plastic and
non-plastic
but yeah
well
well your body
your body your body will ask you that
later
um your body knows the difference but
anyways um but yeah so see you love
bacon what does it really mean to say
you love bacon we we say it but we don't
think about it think about it very
metaphysically like when you love bacon
what's actually happening is that you're
you're tasting it and it's salty and
it's crispy and it's crunchy and it's
it's got the you're it's a
phenomenological experience right eating
bacon just like imagine it you're having
an orgasm in your mouth and it feels
amazing relative to other experiences
you normally have right and and so you
fall you were literally in love with
that experience while it lasts it's so
good you can your your mind
your mind is biased like for example if
we put uh
if we if
if if i tell you to eat a cricket you're
not going to have the same experience
because your mind is biased it likes
bacon but it doesn't like crickets
um
agreed so
so what you're doing is you're comparing
your mind is comparing these two
experiences consciousnesses and it's
it's being biased towards one rather
than the other and when it's doing that
it's recognizing the innate beauty of
that experience
in a biased way
because you could actually train
yourself to eat a cricket and to fall in
love with the taste of a cricket as much
as bacon you could do that and certain
animals
experience it that way like maybe you
know a snake or a frog it will prefer
the the cricket over your bacon
okay because i understand because it's
its neurology is built such that it
loves that thing it has a bias yeah
right so
how this connects to love is uh is that
that's how we experience as humans but
at the level of god consciousness at the
level of like
being as conscious as possible there are
no distinctions between things
therefore there are no biases towards
one experience over another experience
therefore what you have is you have a
love of all experiences which is
equally suffused throughout the entire
universe so to speak throughout the
entire field of consciousness
consciousness imagine it like an
infinite field
anything that arises in that
consciousness
consciousness can either embrace it and
accept it as itself
or it can reject it it can say no i
don't like that experience i want to get
rid of that experience and so we as
living beings as humans we have
preferences for certain experiences over
others the ones we prefer we love and
the ones we hate we call those evil and
bad
and and we call that pain and suffering
um
but
from the absolute point of view because
there literally is no difference between
anything
why would you love one thing over
another thing why would a cricket be
worse than bacon
so when you're infinitely conscious
you are so conscious that all
distinctions collapse into a unity and
that actual collapse
is what love is so the technical def my
technical definition of of metaphysical
love is the realization that there is no
difference between anything when you're
that conscious and you realize that
there is no difference between anything
and you realize that everything is you
you actually fall in love with yourself
infinitely and you love all parts of
reality infinitely at that level of
consciousness
you can love being tortured as much as
you can love eating bacon and it makes
no difference because
in actual truth there is no difference
between eating eating bacon and being
tortured but your mind thinks there is
and as long as you believe that then
that's what you're going to experience
and you're going to have a limited form
of love so the two levels of love is the
absolute love which is completely
unbiased and then the biased form of
love which you need to have in order to
survive as a human being remember
everything you think and do and feel is
conditioned by your need to survive as a
finite form that you are that you're
attached to you're attached to being
human
that means that you can't love being
tortured you can't love eating
poison
because it'll kill you
but god doesn't have that problem
because at the level of god
consciousness it has no body it has no
form it can't be harmed by anything and
it's completely selfless it has no self
it has no identity its identity is
everything when your identity is
everything do you care
what happens to you no because you're
equally happy being in any way that you
could be
what's the difference here between okay
firstly this is presuming some absolute
relativism is that correct
um well i want to know what you mean by
that exactly but i would i'm inclined to
say yes yeah yeah what i mean is that it
it's almost like
a blank sheet of paper that's of
infinite extent privileges no point
exactly
exactly well here's the here's the deep
intuition i'm actually releasing an
episode about this in the next week or
two the deep intuition here is this
why wouldn't the universe be perfectly
symmetrical
in every possible way why would it have
any kind of biases for example do you
think that the universe cares
whether you
like have sex with a goat
do you think it cares
part of the universe that encompasses my
wife would care but
right i'm not sure exactly the universe
exactly part of the unit but i mean like
the universe as a whole right well no
man like this see there's so much about
what's being said that people who are
listening are like kurt why are you not
objecting well firstly i'm my my
job here isn't to simply object for the
sake of objecting but the number two
it's that there's so much here that
belong in the realm of or that yes they
belong in the realm of linguistic
tricks though i'm not saying you're
using them as tricks it's just that it's
so difficult to speak about because as
soon as soon as you speak about it you
degrade it i think of course
wittgenstein i'm sure you're aware had
such
huge injunctions about speaking firstly
about what you can't be precise about
and second even though people thought
wittgenstein was a
hard-nosed atheist he actually
profoundly loved the more mystic sides
of reality and would say that
consciousness is not it's it's not a
something but it's not a nothing either
it's a famous quote i love that quote
but it's not a nothing either because to
say it's a nothing implies a
implies the delineation that we were
enjoying because he was talking about
the two yeah because that's a relative
duality so he intuited that yeah that's
that's smart of him to do he all you
know what else he said my favorite quote
of wickenstein's is this
uh
the aim of philosophy is to show the fly
out of the bottle
and that is what we're doing here my job
is to show you how to because you are
literally lost inside an infinite
labyrinth of your own mind
concepts and ideas and science and toes
and theories you've studied so many of
them
um and i can totally empathize because
i've been there myself and so the trick
here is how do you
go through all of that and come out to
truth in the end because there are so
many ways you can get lost there are so
many dead ends and cul-de-sacs you can
explore your mind forever you can
explore the mind for a for a billion
years and not get to the bottom of it
because it's infinite have you heard of
wittgenstein's ladder
yeah
okay well it seems like
possible what about it possibly what i'm
doing is is going up the wickensteinian
ladder and for the people who are
unaware uh
i believe his tractatus or whichever he
had only pretty much two publications
whichever one yeah it's at the end of
tractatus he says it's like the last
lines of the tractatus
yeah
once you climb up the ladder of
philosophy you throw it away mm-hmm the
whole point was to just throw this away
to get you to the point where you could
realize this right and
and by the way
right and by the way when you awaken if
you ever awaken if you ever reaches god
realization what you'll realize is that
absolutely every single step in your
life was necessary to get you there
including this conversation but not just
this conversation your conversations
with your wife the fact that you married
your wife
the fact you went to school the fact
that you were even deluded all the evil
[ __ ] you did you will realize in
retrospect that all of that was
necessary for you to
bust through all of the resistance you
had towards realizing that you were god
would you say that it was necessary or
would you say that it helped
like what is the difference well
obviously there's a difference between
those two but why are you saying it's
necessary so let me give you an example
is it necessary that
well everything is necessary because
everything is absolute of absolute
tautology this will take us into the
free will question that i know you want
to answer
well we can get there
are we done are we done with love yet or
no no no i'm i'm just
see
i'm not a fan of explanations that use
the same word in a polysemic matter
manner because it's like
i think that different words should be
given instead of saying level one love
and then level two love i think that you
should give a different word to it so
say level two love is called love
because we traditionally understand it
to mean a certain to have a certain
connotate and denotation and then you
give the level one love a different
word rather than calling it level
rather than calling these
underrived elemental blocks level one
love you call it something else and the
reason is that when you're explaining
you or anyone else whenever they use
like i mentioned the same word in an
equivocal manner
it gets confused yeah yeah and then you
can take someone through these logical
sequential
reasoning steps and at each point
someone can agree because the reader the
listener or the watcher has a certain
meaning in their head
but it's different than what you have
and then at some point you arrive at a
different place so i
i guess in some sense it's at the
essence of this channel
i'm going to give a brief math analogy
and then i'll give a peterson analogy
which more people would get but for you
you would probably get the math analogy
if i was in mat in group theory there's
something called the
well there's the op the group operation
so it's denoted with a circle but you
call it circ but you can also call it
plus and if i was to use the generic
group operation plus to mean the plus of
the integers which is commutative but
the generic group operation is not then
i can prove fantastic theorems i can
prove go back's conjecture like this
and that's because i'm using the word
plus
equivalently not specifically
indistinctly
so that's why i think one should outline
relationships separately okay now for
those who aren't mathematically oriented
i'll give you a different analogy
people accuse peterson of jesus
smuggling and part of the reason is that
he'll bring up the word
right he'll bring up the word logos
which has a religious connotation but it
also has a secular one
and
he'll give
or at least in some people's minds he'll
give the impression of speaking about
the unsacred phenomenon which is logos
and then all of a sudden you arrive in
jerusalem and you're like how the heck
did i get here and it's because one is
using the same word in different manners
and at
and you can agree at each point at each
point and then arrive at a completely
far-off place and i'm a proponent of
being as precise as one can possibly be
especially when talking about
fundamental reality not to be unduly
persnickety or to deride or to pick
apart but somewhat precisely the
opposite because i think that
one should build one or like i don't
know how one can build a top shaky
foundation
and this scrutiny breeds solidity
that yeah
that's the two points about that so
of course we're in we're entangled in
language and this presents enormous uh
epistemic challenges for us and even
metaphysical ones because the
metaphysics is tied with epistemology so
the problem is that all language is
relative
and even your notion of what
of what jesus is is not the same notion
as my notion of what jesus is literally
every human mind on the planet has a
different idea of what every word means
so even if we take like the word chicken
your idea of chicken is not the same as
my idea of chicken if we sit down we
make a list of all our ideas about what
a chicken is our like ultimate
definitions of chickens there's gonna be
differences and we can disagree about
the not only in the list but in the
perception like if you were to take
psychedelics and somehow transport
bodies
you may realize man
i thought i knew what a chicken was but
i had no idea that you thought a chicken
was this
yeah exactly so this is just language is
extremely tricky in this way it's very
relativistic in this way um and you can
even change your own ideas of what a
chicken is like and that in fact you do
that as you're doing science and as
you're doing this philosophical work is
that part of the problem here is that
when you start off you adopt all these
labels where do they come from you
didn't invent them you got them from
indoctrination from your schooling you
never questioned what a chicken is they
just told you it was a chicken and you
just accepted it likewise uh they never
told you really what an atom or an
electron is or or energy is you just
accepted these just intuitively had some
intuitive vague sense and then as you do
the work you it gets refined and then
you you change your idea like oh i
thought energy was this and now it's
this and then like oh no i was wrong
about that too and now it's this and you
keep expanding and refining your idea of
energy
um
and um
and the problem is that it's endless you
can do this forever basically um
and you're playing these games
and uh and yeah people use different
definitions for different things and so
that's you have to take all that into
account as you're listening to me and
also as you're thinking about your own
definitions and you have to also realize
that maybe my definition of what love is
isn't right and by me i don't mean me i
mean you
so like
maybe leo is wrong about his ideas of
love but maybe the way you define love
maybe there's a lot of fuzziness there
and maybe it's not being defined very
well
or maybe there's a misunderstanding
there i actually have a really good uh
analogy that i invented
i'm writing a book it's about the lego
blocks
no it's a different one okay
we'll talk about the lego blocks let's
see here the yeah okay
so the so this relates to the love
question all right so here imagine this
the following thought experiment we take
a small child and baby um
we we we build a special facility in
which we're going to raise this child uh
the child will only live on this campus
let's say it's a university campus the
child can only live there as a baby and
we will teach that child
everything that you know it's like it's
like a lab experiment we're going to
teach him only the words we want him to
know and only the concept we want him to
know or her
and so anyways
we have a little backyard area there
where we have ducks
and we take the child out there every
day and we show him
duck duck duck you know these ducks
uh and when we do that we point to the
duck and we say energy
energy energy and every time he sees a
duck he associates that with energy and
and then we have classrooms that we put
in and then we talk about how energy
works we give him some equations for
energy and we explain energy but all the
time we tell him that
duck is energy
and only duck is energy
that's that's what we teach him then
what we do let's say he's 20 years old
finally we let him out of this compound
into the real world he goes to a real
university and he goes to a physics
classroom and he's sitting there in the
you know
physics 101 class and the professor is
talking about how
everything is energy
the table is energy
the stars are energy
the the light bulbs in the room are
energy food is energy and the kid is
sitting there and he's he's completely
dumbfounded and he's he's furious
at this professor like what kind of
nonsense are you talking about how can
the table be energy how can the stars be
energy how can light be energy only
ducks our energy
now how do you train that person
to have the proper
concept of energy
after 20 years of that brainwashing
so my claim is that this is exactly what
has happened with love
we've been trained
on what love is
with pleasurable experiences that we've
been getting and how adults around us
have told us what is appropriate to love
and what is not appropriate to love like
it's okay to love bacon but it's wrong
to love having sex with goats
we've been trained this is part of our
culture this is baked into us
and now when someone like me comes along
and says
everything is love
when i say the coffee table is love uh
you look at that and you look at me and
you say leo is [ __ ] crazy
now here
is where
i would say that we need a bit more
sophistication with the language
rather so there's like two points we can
take it
one can say one where we need a complete
dissolution of the language like
language is actually holding us back and
i'm inclined to agree and the other
point is that our language is not
articulate or delineated or demarcated
enough and there are some arguments to
be made there now one would be like
let's talk about our friend wittgenstein
he would say that language is simply use
so when you say book the reason i
understand it to be book is because
we've used it in our culture to mean so
and so
and when this person has been told
energy
it works for them in the previous i
believe it was the university in that
example like a low-end university and
then at the second end the higher-end
university or whatever hierarchy we want
to give it the higher-end university the
more true university the scientific
university energy was associated with
atoms and so on
well
the point was that different words
should have been used and that you can
see the conflict because they're now
being used differently
so rather than i would just say rather
than saying you need to untrain people
or disabuse them of their notions of
love i would say perhaps you just need
to come up with a different word like
call it bagabu
instead of no
no that that's precisely what my example
is meant to um disagree with
and demonstrate why that why that's a
bad idea
is because um then there's something
about the traditional word love that
you're trying to retain because if it
was completely independent you wouldn't
have any qualms calling it bagaboo
um
it's hard for me to explain why
it's important i mean i get the same
argument people tell me the same thing
about god they say leo why do you call
it god it's so stupid why don't you just
call it like nothingness
to make it more scientific and
acceptable to atheists you know atheists
atheists will accept that that reality
is made of nothing atheists will accept
that but they won't accept god
um yeah what's your answer to that
there's actually a deep problem the
resistance to the fact
the resistance to the use of the word
god or love is itself the problem that
needs to be tackled and addressed
head-on
because see there's a reason why you're
objecting to the use of the word love or
god it's because you're resisting it
you actually don't want to realize that
everything is god or everything is love
you would want it to be called some
other word that would make it easy
because then you can disconnect
your direct experience with love with
some just silly concept
you see
what needs to happen is that you need to
recognize
that the thing that you actually love in
your life let's say you love your wife
you need to recognize that that is an
arbitrary bias your love for your wife
is as uh
is as selective as it is to call a duck
energy
you n you're missing the connection
between the love for your wife and the
love for
uh some child in africa that you don't
care about
or the love for hitler
like in your mind these are disconnected
things and the point of calling it all
love is because now it interconnects in
the same way that like
why do we why do we call
everything in physics energy in a
certain sense because it tells us that
everything is interrelated and that
everything can be converted into
something else like your body is energy
when it dies it will turn into energy in
the grass that will grow from your
corpse and then that grass will be eaten
by some cow and that will turn into
energy in the cow and then someone will
eat that steak and get energy from the
steak and it's a it's a cycle and it's
all interconnected and this is
profoundly important for physics because
it's the unity of all of physics and
science is basically you know
e equals m c squared it can all be
converted and there's a conservation of
energy that's going on well likewise
when i say everything is love
i'm trying to point you towards a
profound realization of how
love manifests in the universe and i
can't do that if i call it bugaboo or
whatever you wanted me to call it
i hear what you're saying
as being as agreeing to what i just said
because what i was saying before was
that we have some ideas as to what love
is and then you have a refined version
of what love is but it bears some
resemblance and that's why you're trying
to save it's almost like you're trying
to recover the word love if the word
love has been lost and in some sense
literally yeah forgotten that we're god
in spyra's
words same for god same for god by the
way the same for truth all these words
have been corrupted deeply
love truth reality all these words are
very corrupted
so part of our process here is to
rehabilitate these words and take them
back and to purify them
to give people a proper understanding of
these words could someone say that hate
is what
are these primitive components rather
than love can someone use the word hate
like it's all made of hate
yeah i get i get that often it's like
people say well leo if everything is
infinite love why can't be infinite hate
too if god can be all loving can't god
be all hating
mm-hmm and the answer is no
because
the source of hate itself the whole
hate is a finite thing
hate is a hate is a reaction you have to
some aspect of reality
you see some some experience that you
don't like and that that's hate it's a
rejection of some aspect so god can hate
of course that's what human hate is
but it's always going to be finite and
limited it's not going to be infinite
hate can't be infinite
uh let me see if there's a better way to
say it
because look
you have to understand that here it gets
really tricky because the notion of love
see again love is it we have two notions
of love we have a relative notion and an
absolute if you're talking about the
relative notion of love which is what
most humans talk about and what you're
thinking right now probably then that is
a duality between love and hate that's
that's the duality and so in this sense
you can have love and hate and they can
play with each other whatever they can
be in different degrees but what i'm
talking about is i'm talking about
absolute love absolute love is a love so
deep that it incorporates even hate so
what you call hate i would call absolute
love
it's incorporated
like that yin yang
so hate is like the black part of the
yin yang
relative love is like the white part of
the yin yang and then what i call
absolute love is the entire yin yang
man there's such there's so many great
analogies here to math there's something
called item potence
yeah speak speaking of i just speaking
of math you know i'm actually not very
good at math um
um and i don't really enjoy doing it but
um i i watched a movie yesterday
i found this movie by the title called
uh the man who knew infinity
it's actually i'll be posting it on my
blog over the next few weeks but it was
about uh ramanujan you know this guy
this brilliant
indian math prodigy who died when he was
really young but um the story with him
goes is that like he had this divine
connection to his god and god was
delivering these you know amazing
mathematical proofs to him and theorems
and stuff
it's called the man who knew infinity
which is exactly correct yeah
let's move on to
free will
how can it firstly why don't you explain
your ideas to free will do we have free
will or not
it's very tricky
because again you have to notice
that every question so notice this meta
issue every question you have about
existence is going to be um
corrupted with a sort of duality so
already when you say free will what's
that in opposition to determinism or
non-free will right
um and so you should notice that that
itself is already an imagined
distinction
which is already problematic so if you
think it's going to be one or the other
you're
you're probably going to be wrong
right in general this here's a little
simple way for you to avoid a lot of
confusion and problems in this
quest
to understand nature
is that any time you find a duality and
then you side with only one half of that
duality you can be sure you're going to
be ultimately wrong
because nature has to incorporate both
sides
of the duality for example
consider science you have science on the
one hand and then you have uh
pseudoscience on the other hand
everything that's not science you might
say
if you think that science is where all
the truth is and that there's no more
truth to be found in pseudoscience you
can be sure you're wrong on the other
hand if you think all the truth is going
to be found in pseudoscience and none in
science you're also wrong
it's going to have to somehow
incorporate both
because both are aspects of infinite
consciousness consciousness can imagine
both and therefore both have to be part
of it
but anyways so back to the free will
issue
um
perhaps you should define free will
whether or not you're going to say it
exists or not
yeah
um how should i phrase this
it's relative so it depends on what
perspective you're looking at it from so
i can't give you a well i can give you
an absolute answer but
the absolute answer is not going to be
something you like and that itself you
can consider sort of a perspective so
basically let's say that you're at the
level of ordinary human consciousness if
you're at the level of ordinary human
consciousness that's one situation we
can give an answer for that and then
let's say you're at the level of god
consciousness infinitely conscious
that'll be a different totally different
answer so first i'll start with the god
consciousness great if you become if you
become infinitely conscious
what you will realize
is that
what god is god is an infinite mind
it's a mind that is completely free of
any restrictions upon itself and the
reason that is is because it's a
singular mind therefore there is nothing
that could restrict this mind in any way
because every restriction
upon this mind would have to be imagined
in order to exist
you see the reason god is omnipotent or
has infinite power
can literally create anything god can
imagine an entire planet out of thin air
requires no energy has no cost no
physical limitations no logical
limitations there are absolutely no
limitations
and the reason that can be is because
what would limit god
i mean like the question is more like
uh
how would this infinite mind be limited
what would limit it
and and then you have to think about
that and you have to say well something
outside of itself has to limit it
but how can there be something outside
of itself if it's infinite if it's
infinite there literally can't be
anything outside of itself therefore
it has no limits literally any limit it
has is imagined by itself so god can
have limits but those limits have to be
self-imposed through its own imagination
therefore god has to trick itself
in order to limit itself
that's why self-deception is so
important because if god is not
deceiving itself then it's omnipotent
then it's unlimited
i don't understand that part but do you
mind okay i'll make a note on that
because i would like yeah we can come
back there's a lot more to say about
that limitation implies self-deception
or is equivalent to
right
right okay
so think about this way
look
if
imagine imagine you have all imagine you
have
no limitations whatsoever you can
literally spawn things into existence by
thinking them
a couch a chair whatever you want okay
so uh imagine if you let's just assume
you have that power so now ask yourself
this question
do i have the power
to
surrender this power
if god is all-powerful this least so
interesting paradox if god if god is
all-powerful can god create a rock that
he himself cannot lift
is it possible for god to
not be god
something less than god
and the answer turns out to be yes
but only by deceiving himself
not in actuality but through a deception
through an illusion so he has to he has
to fool himself into
thinking that he's not god
then like for example if he imagines
that if god did man so how would god
remove all his powers he would imagine
that he was a human born on a rock
circling around the sun
with logical laws and physical laws
and pain and pleasure and all these
things
and fear and all these things that need
to be avoided all these predators and
animals all these dangers
and then you know when he imagines
himself in this finite body this finite
body is not infinite this finite body
cannot
do many things this finite body can only
lift rocks up to a certain
size you cannot lift a two ton rock with
your body
but if you had if you had a bigger body
you could maybe lift a two ton rock but
then you couldn't lift a 50 ton rock
so see by the fact that you have a
finite body your powers are limited
um
so that's why self-deception
is so crucial so at the highest level
since you're completely unlimited
literally
and god is consciousness it's an
infinite intellect
so this infinite intellect can literally
imagine whatever it wants and it is
using its will to do so so literally god
can will anything it wants into
existence but there's a catch
and the catch is because at that level
god is completely infinite unlimited
it's completely selfless
it has no sense of self
at all
if it has no sense of self that means it
has
no capacity to do anything selfish
this is why god is absolutely good
it's absolutely good because it's
absolutely selfless
if it's absolutely selfless
imagine this imagine if you had all the
power in the universe you could create
anything
and you were completely selfless
what would you create
imagine if you could will anything into
existence literally you will it and you
will get it like if you will to have um
the biggest house in the world you can
have it if you will to have
sex with whoever you want you can have
it if you will to have beautiful
children you can have them instantly
what would you will for
i can't i can't imagine what it would be
like to be completely selfless because
then and and create at the same time
because to create i would have to imply
a bias somewhere and if i'm saying that
i'm unbiased i don't know how i would
choose a point
so let's say let's imagine that's good
that's good that's what well let's
imagine i said i would create a tree
well why would i create a tree and not a
microphone
okay now okay now keep going keep going
yeah that's that see
well you you're about to answer how all
of creation was created
do you want to know why the entire
universe exists sure
the entire physical what we think of as
a physical universe or the entire
universe with a capital u as in all that
yeah
both
both
and okay right right let's hear it or
or even it or even anything
i would like to know how can anything so
i mean isn't that the ultimate question
that you want to know like i mean if
your toe cannot explain why
anything exists
and why it must exist then you really
haven't answered anything your toe is
not a toe
right
i mean i don't know i don't know about
that i mean because it depends on the
definition of theory of everything some
people take it to mean like gravity
unified with gravity unified with it
well but everything you're trying to
explain where everything came from right
you have to explain where everything
came from yeah yeah yeah the reason why
i'm saying i don't know about that is
because it seems like
there will always be parts of reality
that
i will not know
okay that's correct from your point of
view but now notice what happened now a
possibility has been open in your mind
that
you could know
open your mind to the possibility and
take this possibility seriously that you
can actually reach a point where you
will know
everything does that happen upon death
well that's a secondary question let's
let's let's just tackle one thing at a
time the reason why i say that briefly
is because
in some
or many religions as soon as you die
even in a secular
place a secular religion let's say of
pixar in the movie soul i believe it's
called soul okay so even in there it
seems like what death is is unity with
god
well that's
that's basically correct yeah so in some
sense when you die you being the self
when the self dies
with god and god is all that there is
and god is omniscient and so in some
sense
the
the quest for a toe is futile in a
living
being as far as i can conceptualize what
a living
differentiated being is like a self okay
so then you're saying well kurt imagine
you could know everything
right okay so please continue
well but are you open to the possibility
that that they're i'm not even imagining
i'm not asking you to imagine you know
everything i'm just asking you are you
open to the possibility where you could
know everything
yeah is that possible or do you believe
that's not possible because a lot of a
lot of scientists and academics and such
they will literally tell you that's not
possible
well i see it as impossible from certain
perspectives like if you believe
yourself in the materialist sense to be
can can you do it can you do it i'm
asking you very personally do you
believe in your lifetime in this
lifetime you will do it no
right now i'd say i believe no
okay well then notice that if you
believe that then that just becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy how can it ever
happen if you already believe it's
impossible in the same way that for for
example if i said
i believe it's not possible to fast to
build a vehicle that travels faster than
a hundred thousand miles an hour
that's it then it's impos literally even
if it's possible i won't ever build that
vehicle i don't know about that and the
reason is that there are plenty of
surprises that happen
people surprised themselves all the time
they thought oh i never thought i could
run a marathon and then i did
or i never thought i could do so-and-so
and then i did or i never thought
so-and-so was possible but then it was
well they have to change their mind of
course yeah you can change your mind
i mean
um
you you see the problem here is that's
what you're saying while you believe
it's not possible it's
from your point of view it's not
possible because as soon as you believed
it
in the examples that i just gave you
changed your mind so no longer so with a
correct statement that i said sorry to
amend my statement more specifically it
would be that
previously you believed it was not
possible after a certain point
let's say with your eyes you saw
you saw a platypus and you never thought
mammals could be like that you've
changed your beliefs
yeah yeah okay and also and also notice
um usually to verify something like that
or to change your mind requires an
investment a significant investment of
resources so for example let's say we
were talking about a skeptic
who never lived in australia and we were
trying to tell him that a platypus
exists there's such a thing as a
platypus and he says no there isn't
prove it to me and we show him
photographs and videos and he says no
those are just doctors you just
photoshopped those that's like you took
a duck's head and you put it on a beaver
and that this stupid photoshop obviously
it's photoshopped and we show up a video
and he says ah well they have deep fake
videos of anything nowadays he said
that's a 3d generated you know computer
generated thing you know they i've seen
jurassic park they can make dinosaurs i
mean they've made monsters in movies so
of course platypus you could make that
into a video but it doesn't really exist
and we say okay but are you open to a
platypus existing
and he says no it's too ridiculous i'm
not even open to it it's just
preposterous on its face
well
we would say okay but are you open to
actually traveling to australia to
hunting down this this platypus they
live there in the rivers in the ponds
you can find one
and he says um no why should i travel to
australia that would be a waste of my
money
and in a certain sense he's right i mean
like from his point of view if if this
is a preposterous thing why invest
energy into it to chase it down it takes
a lot of time energy to fly to australia
go into the ponds and look for this
platypus
um he has to be motivated he has to be
motivated
yeah you have to be motivated to do it
and all science works this way i mean
look the large hadron collider that they
built cost like 10 billion i don't know
10 billion or something to build all of
that was done to try to prove the
existence of some hypothetical higgs
boson particle that may or may not have
existed that's 10 [ __ ] billion
dollars 10 years of building this thing
hundreds of scientists involved hundreds
of engineers hundreds of laborers that
was very risky and there was no
guarantee that it was going to produce
any kind of truthful result it could
have just been a waste of money
and so
part of what it means to be a truth
seeker is that you're willing to
actually invest energy which is why what
you're doing is so good is because i can
tell you're preparing for these
interviews you're researching you're
reading you're studying videos you're
being open-minded you're actually
putting your own ass on the line you're
losing sleep over this and that's
exactly what it takes you can't reach
the truth you can't reach god and love
and all these things you can't reach the
ultimate toe by just sitting around and
navel gazing and just kind of doing
what's comfortable for you
because the truth may not be comfortable
oh that's definitely true man
if anything it's true that's true
do you think see i don't think i don't i
don't know if i can
to me truth is so not trivial some
people think of it as simply statements
that need to be accepted written
propositions but right
the truth can be so harsh and so we
gotta talk we gotta talk about two
levels of truth too
[Applause]
but
make it make a note of that but before
we get there let me let me finish my my
thoughts man we have so much to talk
about yeah oh yeah we haven't even
touched on self-deception limitation
okay
for a week yeah um yeah by the way we
can leave some of these for sure future
time and people who are watching if you
would like to see a second part please
let us know
and and we have um we have still hours
to talk so we can paste this out
uh anyways but actually let's pause
right here for a second because i want
to restart my camera just so that we're
safe with the file go ahead
oh no i can feel you prepared how
well first of all i can feel your
authenticity so i can trust your words
to a certain degree but also um
just like i mean it's just obvious from
your work like with chris langan you
were asking very technical questions
about
this term and that [ __ ] nerdy term
that he used and so
just even the f even the fact that you
care just even the questions you kind of
ask already show the level of interest
you have all right let's get just
obvious if you can remember where you
were yeah so so yeah i remember exactly
where we were so we were talking about
um
uh
oh yeah remember so the question was
like if you were infinitely selfless and
powerful what would you create
and you and you said i don't really know
like
why would i create maybe why would i be
biased towards creating a tree or
something else right that's what you
said
and then i told you that here now we're
going to answer the origin of all of
existence right right
why anything is this okay so here's why
so look
if you're all powerful
and you're all loving and you're
completely selfless
you can and you can create absolutely
anything
just by willing into existence
what you would create and you're
completely unbiased you're right about
that you're completely unbiased what you
would create is absolutely everything
every possible form every possible being
every possible
thing that could be imagined you imagine
and why and why and look but why do you
do that
so that you can give others
a sense of
the beauty and love that you are
so the entire point of god's creation is
to create finite forms of itself so that
those forms can then reunite back with
itself to realize what it is which is
infinite goodness
so it's an infinite sharing of goodness
why does it create all possibilities
look at what's really going on the
genius of what's going on
god has infinite goodness but because it
is one it has no one to share the
infinite goodness with who would you
share it with there's nobody else but
you so what you do is you deceive
yourself to create an other who you
could give that gift to the gift of
yourself of god the highest gift in the
universe is the realization that you are
god
but you can't share that gift with
anybody i can't share that gift with you
until you realize that you're me
the realization that you're me is the
gift i'm trying to give you
why does god care about sharing
because embedded in that is the valuing
of sharing it's love
right why do you why do you love why do
you give your wife a present on
christmas
you're sh you're
you are literally sharing you literally
have chosen to share your life
with your wife
why
you're asking me a question about
motivations i i don't know i could just
give you a superficial answer like why i
think not it may not be why i do it but
why i think i may do it
i'm not interested in those
the answer is love
it's very simple the answer is love
all your motivations boil down to
variations of degrees of love
that are that are filtered through your
mind let me tell you what occurs to me
so one we said god is not
self-conscious because there is no self
to god in the
right there is no self to god before god
creates a multiplicity it god god is
self god is infinite self
god is all possible selves
so is-ness is is prior to
self-reflection in this case
so god can self-reflect of course god is
not
but but suffer self-reflection is
already a dualistic uh dynamic you see
because there has to be a self and then
a reflection that you're reflecting off
of so god is prior to god is just self
infant itself and then it can also
reflect in infinite ways
is it okay if i tell you
just rapid fire some thoughts that occur
to me
yeah sure so at first it's like god is
selfless because god doesn't have a
conception of self okay so then god
creates infinite
types of selves but then
and in order to share but then i'm
curious number one why is it in order to
share like okay well god is made of love
okay but god is not aware of god it's
it's a
so god is not aware of sharing being a
preeminent factor of himself or itself
uh love is so love is is such a
metaphysically profound notion that it's
prior to i'm a little bit
anthropomorphizing god here so we have
to be a little bit careful so the notion
of like god sharing
it makes sense from a human perspective
from a more from a more like if you want
to be really strict about it um strictly
speaking love just is an endless
flowering of creativity so literally
what god is is creativity it just it
endlessly creates because that's what
love is you see there's there's such a
profound unity between goodness love
omnipotence intelligence consciousness
oneness and creativity that literally
and love is that
what it means to be infinite love is to
just spontaneously create everything
that could possibly exist that's what
love is
it's not just something love does it's
what love is you can't be love unless
you're everything
love is
everything two thoughts that occur to me
right now i've always found i'm probably
you the same as when you were when you
would consider yourself to be someone
who was planning to be a scientist i've
always found the multiverse idea and the
anthropomorph sorry the the universe
that
i forget the type of
ah i'm forgetting the name of it but
there's a
why are the physical laws the way that
they are because they're fine-tuned
because there are multiple universes and
i forget what yeah yeah anthropic is
that is that the anthropic principle or
something always found those to be
lacking
because they they're just they're
non-explanations you're asking well why
is it so so the answer is because it's
everything at the same time
okay
sure i don't know how to i don't know
how to work with that i don't know how
to use that
well that's okay so that's one thought
one thing like it seems to me to be the
easy way out even if it's true it could
be absolutely like everything you say
could be
100 correct
but i i find it to be somewhat of an
easy way out and then number two
i it's interesting that creation is so
tied to love
so love to me is about unifying but
creation to me seems to me to be about
distinction if anything destruction
would be closer to unifying because as
you destruct as you destroy you reduce
down to zero which is the same but as
you create you proliferate
good okay um so now notice the following
what is creation and destruction
duality in fact this is a classic
duality of the yin and the yang
right so god has both aspects um you
actually what you should notice is that
you actually you can't create without
destroying
because like
let's say you have one sheet of paper on
which to draw
you're going to draw some painting like
let's say you have an etch a sketch you
draw on the etch a sketch
and then you got your sand painting
but now you want to paint something else
well you gotta shake the etch a sketch
destroy all this stuff and then you can
paint some more
so the two are intimately tied to it i
mean it's the circle of life if you want
to think about it that way like you
can't have it's sort of like you're
saying well leo isn't life good but
death bad this is a very naive way of
thinking about it because if you go and
actually look at how ecosystems work in
nature
you realize quickly that the only reason
you can have life is because of death
it's because
the the you know the gazelle died that
there could be baby lions and because of
the baby lions uh you know some of them
die and then because of that there can
be worms and because of worms there can
be grass and because of grass there can
be gazelles and because of gazelles
there can be more baby lines and so it
goes around in a circle forever
so it's both i see it as being yeah i i
i i should in the structure give a point
of view to think of death as evil and
then
and then birth as necessarily good but i
also don't see it as i see it as like in
our world everything virtually
everything in fact i can't think of a
counter example everything that we think
of good is predicated on something that
we would think of as evil let's say you
think in those domains already good and
evil in the sense that well what do you
think of is good you think that
to give him an example of buying a gift
for your wife well how was that gift
made like it probably was predicated on
some suffering of some children in some
faraway land and even if it wasn't there
well you produce some emissions that
weren't good for so-and-so creatures and
in some sense that's evil
in some sense it's all it's like
every act every single act me talking is
destroying some cellular creatures
exactly
of course yeah yeah just for you to be
alive you have to be like killing
viruses and bacteria in your body every
day privilege yours
whatever your quote-unquote means right
over theirs okay i i understand that i
don't see a metaphysical necessity in
the same way that you do and the reason
is
the reason is like let's imagine
i keep going back to math but let's
imagine the natural numbers before they
become the natural numbers so you start
with the empty set and you call that
zero and then you apply a successor
function you get one you don't destroy
zero and then you apply a successor
function you get two while retaining
zero one and two you apply a successor
function you get zero one two three so
and that's i would consider to be an act
of creation but i don't see an act of
destruction in that creation right there
yeah so there's some profound things
that could be said about that um
first of all
all of the creation that we know as
humans is all finite creation so you're
really just talking about finitude the
fact that everything you create is going
to be finite
it's not going to be infinite
um and that's right every finite thing
has limits that's what it means to be
finite is to have a limit and the only
unlimited thing is completely indistinct
so every distinction that you imagine is
going to be finite for example in your
mind if you're imagining an elephant
there's an elephant now for you to
imagine a giraffe you have to let go of
the element imagine a giraffe
and so literally for your thoughts to
work you have to destroy and let go of
old thoughts
and so it is with all form
every finite thing interferes with the
existence so for example here's here's
the profound way to think about it
let's say you have a coffee table
for that coffee table to be a coffee
table it has to not be
a i get it dining table
not not be a chair not be a chicken not
be your wife not be whatever it has to
be that and by being finite it excludes
all other possibilities that's literally
what a chair or a coffee table is it's
the exclusion of every possibility other
than itself as it is in its finite form
did you happen to watch the interview
that i had with this guy named anthony
anthony mativier so he's a memory
champion he's a memory champion who says
that memory is intimately tied with
consciousness and to me i don't i don't
okay well to me of course at least
previous to about a few seconds ago
i thought that the memory is almost
irrelevant
to consciousness but then what you said
to me right now it reminds me of working
memory because let's imagine that the
average person has a working memory of
seven
entities
so for you to imagine something new you
have to replace one of those seven with
something else you don't have infinite
working memory in other words but even
if you did it's still a problem
do you see imagine you have infinite
memory
right you have infinite memory
um
even if you ima if you if you and you
let's say every memory is just like a
slot you have a little box you can put
an item in even if you put one item into
that box
that space has been filled by that item
and not by some other item
that's a finite thing you actually um
created a limit when you did that
because like let's say you could have
put a frog in your memory or a giraffe
or an elephant but you only put one not
all of them
otherwise you'd have a superposition you
see
for for
like if you if you're talking about like
a quantum memory imagine a memory slot
where you can stick multiple items into
the same memory slot over top of
themselves and then you get a
superposition and if you put every
possible item into that memory slot you
would literally get infinity or
nothingness in that memory slot because
it would all superimpose into nothing
yeah yeah you understand this is
extremely interesting
you know
okay keep going so you can look look
think about it like this so imagine
let's take the domain of all animals all
possible animals that could exist
ever
um so let's take a giraffe a frog
elephant and so forth
what happens what happens if we
if we literally merge a giraffe and an
elephant and a frog and a dinosaur all
literally into themselves
into a perfect superposition of all
possible animals what would you have
what would that
would that look like
okay but yeah continue she she she'd be
in there somewhere is it yeah where are
you going with this
so what do you think that looks like i'm
just trying to get you to pick i have no
clue i imagine it looks like a blur
well it would it would just be a
variable it'd be like x right
but just x the variable
variable x okay yes
so like what it what is a variable a
variable is just it's like a placeholder
that says that literally anything can go
in that place we haven't defined it's
undefined
but that's literally what nothingness is
or infinity
infinity is literally it can be anything
but we haven't defined what it is yet
it's undefined and then as soon as we
define it or draw a distinction
that becomes whatever we define it to be
whatever we imagine it to be that's what
imagination is are there
like i look i'm gonna ask you a question
about paradoxes and i imagine you'd say
well there are paradoxes because
let's see this is why i call it the easy
way out and not that that makes it
untrue i just see it as the easy way out
and that's maybe the easiest way out is
the truthful path i don't think that's
necessarily true but it may be true
there are paradoxes with thinking of the
universe
as all that could be because you get
into paradoxes of sets of all sets and
so on so for example
yeah
of course
that's that's that's
that's a feature not a bug
i think i heard you say that even if
there are multiverses let's just call it
capital u universe because you just
collect them all okay well
if god can create
everything then i don't see why god
can't create universes that
are built
with properties in them so defined by
property so what if a universe was
defined by the property
so there's a universe it doesn't really
just let me finish this there's the
universe out there it can't we can't
imagine it precisely it doesn't look
like a physical universe but that's fine
god can do whatever you like this
universe is defined by the property that
this universe when placed in collection
with other universes negates those other
universes
okay so now we say okay well let's
collect them all into this big u well
you've negated some of them now so have
you truly collected all your universes
can you truly say that there exists
capital u universe
okay so this this is good this leads us
to a very profound question that i want
to kind of guide you through so
let me ask you this this will indirectly
answer your question um
so don't worry so let me ask you this do
you d are you conscious of why reality
has to be one
no
okay so
so let's let's go you want to go through
an exercise to help you
to grasp this fire ian okay yeah can we
cuz yeah we got to do a little bit of
exercise here because this is all just
mental masturbation
basically up to this point so
why must reality be one and not anything
more than that
think of reality
as more than
one okay
okay try to do it
okay
but the notion of reality it has to be
an elastic notion because everything
real has to be inside the notion of
reality right so my question is so
imagine so let's say you're imagining
two realities right so you have reality
a and reality b
yeah next to each other all right so
is a the real reality or is b the
reality which one choo choose
choose one are you gonna say both of
them are reality
okay so if a and b are both reality
then
what's real is that you've got both
yep and that's reality that's reality
right so now
that's one
so two become one
by the fact that they're both real
or are you saying one of them's not real
right
okay okay so let's say so let's say they
are both real so then you can you see
how that's one reality uh-huh yeah
because is the separation between them
real
what is separating one reality a from b
what is the line between them is that
line real yes
okay so then so then literally
this a is literally fused with this b by
the real line uh-huh it's
right
or are you saying they're separated
let's take the case where they're
separate let's say
let's say we have reality a and then b
is b is not real
well what does it mean to say that b is
not real it means that there is a line
between a and b which is separating real
from under i don't know about that
right
well how can a not be
if there's no line between them then
isn't ba
i don't see that as as necessarily being
the case i i don't know i know this is
said quite frequently but to me these
are again linguistic tricks like look we
can't have what's out look like here's a
couple here's one the universe can't be
spatially expanding because what is it
expanding into well that doesn't have a
notion of intrinsic geometry or we can't
have what's infinite like we talked
about because if you're infinite there's
nothing outside it well obviously you
can you can cross product two infinities
okay so there's that i don't see
that before there to the distinction
between real and then unreal as having
some border
i don't know if the proper
conceptualization is a border but but
but but what distinguishes real from
unreal
i don't know if i i don't
well if
i if you become conscious of it deeply
you'd have to sit there for years maybe
yeah or
you're on meditation until event until
eventually
eventually uh one deep dose will get you
to realize that actually there cannot be
a boundary between the real and the
unreal
and when that happens that's when your
mind literally
becomes infinite because you realize
that
all of these things there needs to be
boundaries but you can't have something
you can't have something
um you can't have something outside of
real i mean chris langan actually gave a
good explanation of this early in in in
your episode with him
is that um
yeah he basically so the note what you
need to realize is that the notion of
reality is an ever elastic notion so
even if you say something is unreal are
you saying that unreality is real
let's say we have a and b let's forget
about the the boundary between them
let's just say we have a and b a is real
b is unreal so is the unreality of b is
that real
right yeah it is
that would be the case yeah
well if it is then it's real then we
have a connection between the two
wow
right and if it's unreal if it's unreal
then it's nothing there's nothing there
if it's unreal it doesn't exist
but by definition exist non-existence
cannot exist words that have these
they have that are laden with
connotations that aren't
exactly precise and so we can get
yeah i understand i understand your
concern there's a connection between the
two i'm not precisely sure it's the same
connection as in you have a box
connected by string to another box
of course it's not the same but um
[Music]
yeah i understand what i'm what i'm
telling the bottom line i'm telling you
is that it's more than just word play
it's some of this stuff might sound like
word games but it's more than that
it's way more than that
um
it's very actually important for you
guys who are trying to build your toes
to actually have direct consciousness of
the fact that reality cannot be anything
but one
if you think it can if you think you can
have two realities something has those
two realities have to be within
something what if they say like i
understand that
my reality can't be anything more than
one in the rupert's
fiery in sense of where what what the
question where is the edge of your
awareness
where the as the where does your
experience end and then and then you say
well my experience i can't see an edge
to it whatever edge means i can't see it
but that doesn't mean that edges don't
exist it just means that as far as i
know edges don't exist as far as i can
even conceptualize right okay now
right but now what i'm telling you is
that you're way beyond concept here
imagine that you can go beyond your
concepts and that you can actually see
infinitely imagine if you could
literally see to the outer edges of the
entire universe you saw everything that
could ever possibly be and you saw it
all at once now if you could see all
that would there be anything that you
couldn't see
well i'll tell you what i can't see is
what is unseen
what's unseen
can't be seen i don't know about that i
i can understand that see we're getting
this is such a great question like what
the heck does it mean to exist and i'm
not going to defend
like you know me i'm not going to defend
a physicalist but i don't even think
that that holds water because like what
the heck does it mean to exist but
and you can't answer that if you
answered that that would be awakening
so so there is so a lot of people think
that well well this is just a
philosophical question no one will ever
know no that's wrong
you can definitively know what existence
is i'm conscious of existence
right now i know exactly what it is
you can become conscious consciousness
part of existence i would say that
now you're saying well kurt hey man
i'm no i i i i'm not talking about the
forms of i'm saying existence itself
what does it mean to exist
not as a particular thing but just
existence
as itself
what is existence
right right
you can become conscious you can you can
become conscious of that
and if you do that's what awakening is
so
when that happens you will realize that
non-existence
isn't a thing at all it's not possible
only existence is existence is an
absolute
see you're thinking that
some things can exist some things can't
exist no
there can only be existence
when you're thinking of non-existence
that's you
imagining
something that
it's a concept see what you're doing is
you're creating a concept of
non-existence and that exists but as a
concept and you're not conscious that
it's a concept rather than existence
so there's a there's a very sneaky
game that your mind is playing in order
to keep constructing these imaginary
concepts like non-existence or something
beyond the infinite and so forth
so these are actually self-deceptions
that you can penetrate through for
example if you do a meditation practice
you'll actually notice these are
thoughts non-existence is a thought
not
anything real it's a thought well i mean
the thought is real but it's a thought
just a thought
and
same thing for something beyond infinity
that's a thought that is not actually
beyond infinity
because look infinity includes thoughts
of things beyond infinity but that's
part of infinity
you're assuming that's not part of
infinity but it is part of infinity
because infinity is infinite and it's
endless and it's see it's an ever
elastic thing whatever you think it's
not it encompasses and includes that so
you can't ever defeat it
i would urge you to change the word
infinity to all encompassing
particularly because of what we talked
about earlier what you truly mean when
you say infinite is all-encompassing
well there's when you when you realize
that you are infinity you will
you'll come back and we'll talk and then
you'll you'll laugh we'll laugh together
at why i said it's infinity
let's let's try this here let's try a
little exercise here so
look
the problems with the mind the mind goes
down all these rabbit intellectual
rabbit holes forever all this philosophy
and stuff you're you're lost in a
labyrinth of thinking so look
ask yourself this
do you realize how profound it is that
anything at all exists
are you conscious of that like right now
try to become like look at your hands
and try to just be conscious for a
second
that it's just it's utterly astounding
that they exist right now
like it's astounding and by the way can
you become conscious at least try that
these are the hands of god
so remove your idea that you're a human
as you're looking at your hands strip
away the idea that you're a human strip
away the idea that there's anything
that these hands are made of atoms so
remove the idea of atoms
remove the idea of mathematics remove
the idea of god and physics as well or
no
yes
yes yes throw away the idea of god
um
and throw away the idea that this is a
lit that these hands are a living being
part of a living being
right and just look at these hands as
though you're seeing them for the first
time
they're not even hands i remove the idea
first time
or no okay yeah
okay yeah of course so almost like raw
sensory experience is what you're trying
to get me okay
yeah yeah
exactly raw sensory experience so now
what i want you to notice is that so
here's a definition of what truth is
this is absolute truth your hands what
you're what you're conscious of right
now first of all
notice that you're conscious of these
hands these hands are literally
consciousness
this is what consciousness is
do not think
just look at these hands this is
consciousness
it seems mysterious that's not a mistake
it's supposed to be mysterious
so let it be mysterious
let let it awe you a little bit like
it's awesome that something here exists
and you're not sure what it is
you don't know what it is but you know
it's here
it exists
so these hands are literally
consciousness
they are literally existence itself
they are literally absolute they
absolutely exist
they cannot not exist they're right here
they are not a function of any kind of
brain or neurons or anything else
they're right here
and these hands are literally
infinity
god
you are literally the universe
being
itself
the universe is these hands
the universe is not some bubble out
there somewhere beyond the stars the
universe is these hands that's what the
universe is
in this particular moment
it can be other things but this is what
it is right now
and there is no time these hands exist
outside of time
there is no time and there's no space in
which these hands exist
this is prior to space you're throwing
away the ideas of space and time
and matter there is no matter these
hands are not made out of matter
also these hands are not an experience
that you are having these hands exist
prior even to experience
because experience assumes some sort of
ego self looking at the hands
these hands are absolute truth
they're absolutely true
and there's no way they cannot be
anything but absolutely true
it's completely inevitable
there's no possibility of doubt or error
when you are this conscious of your
hands
you're so conscious
that you're too conscious to have doubt
because you realize that doubt is just
thought in your hands they are more
fundamental than any thought
notice that your thoughts do not change
the existence of your hands
no matter how much you doubt your hand
your hand will be there prior to all
thought
you can doubt your hand as much as you
want but here it is it's a hand
you can even tell yourself that this
hand is simulated by some kind of
computer or whatever and none of that
matters because
the absolute truth is that this hand is
right here right now
qualia
is absolute truth
and that's all that meditation is
is what you're doing right now
all right
okay tell me
tell me yes
how did that feel
it's interesting
it's
i have to
it's strange because i have to tell
myself
i have to talk to myself but then make
sure that i'm not talking to myself so
for example when you said look at your
hands i imagine at the same time i also
have to dissolve what a hand is because
to it to look at my hands implies that
there's something that's not my hands so
i was just trying to look at sensory
experience at the same all just sensory
experiences raw's can be
yeah that's good yeah it's it you could
you have monkey mind
and
and unconsciously i'm relating what
you're saying to what other people say
and you also say what
spurs
some interesting connections such as the
relationship between qualia and all that
there is or absolute truth or god the
relationship between that because
there's obvious not obviously but
there's
somewhat obviously a relationship
between consciousness and god and time
as well which is something else i'm
exploring i also wonder how much
consciousness depends on time
consciousness does not depend on time
time is imagined by consciousness but
but i don't know i know that that's the
traditional
view but i'm wondering how much
how intricately it is time
tied to consciousness now it seems to be
obviously tied in the sense that people
like eckhart tolle would say there's the
now which is somewhat a temporal aspect
even though it's a temporal no
no the now what what eckhart tolle means
by now is he means absolute now this the
absolute
this is the absolute everything you see
around you is absolute truth
so sometimes people think that when i
talk about absolute truth i'm talking
about some sort of far-off realm behind
the curtain of the universe somewhere
behind the scenes no no no this right
here is absolutely true look at your
hands this is the easiest way to ground
yourself in absolute truth is just look
at your hands
and realize that they absolutely exist
and
same for all of your qualia so what
ecartoli means by now is this absolute
moment here it's not in time it's
actually eternal
so time is time is an overlay or
projection that universal mind is
imagining on top of the now
and it's imagining the past and the
future the past and future don't really
exist there
they exist as
imaginings they're very powerful
imaginings they're so powerful that
right now in your human state of
consciousness you can't uh
easily undo them you can't unthink them
they're they're they're baked into the
state of consciousness you're at so a
further elaboration upon my worldview as
we started off at the very beginning
my world view is that consciousness is
all that there is and that everything is
a state of consciousness so right now
you're in a state of consciousness a
particular state that state is curt the
curt state and also it is the human
state that's what human consciousness is
like the way that it is for you
now this state can change at any time
and it can change through
drinking alcohol
that will produce a state change it can
change through psychedelics it can
change through meditation through yoga
through getting hit in the head with a
hammer all sorts of ways to change your
state and that will
you know change
change
how your reality
flows and behaves and so if that ch if
that state changes radically enough
physical reality will literally start to
melt and collapse which is what happens
on psychedelics and then people who
aren't
who don't have a good foundation they
start to freak out because they don't
understand why reality is collapsing
around them and melting away and the
reason that it's melting away is because
the walls of your house are literally
imaginary
and here i can further add
uh my explanation of what imagination is
so imagination has again two levels
ordinarily what we call imagination is
we call the thoughts in our mind images
in our mind imagination and then when i
say something like that the walls of
your house are imaginary
um a lot of materialists and so forth
and skeptics
they they snicker at this and you know
they they say well if leo if the walls
of your house are imaginary prove it
show me why you walking through a wall
right it's imaginary why can't you do it
well
i'm not saying something so stupid and
naive as like
that your ego mind is believing that
there are walls around your house and
then you can just
drop your beliefs and then walk through
the walls i'm saying that the actual
physicality of a wall is imaginary and
this is not something your ego mind has
control over
in this state that you're in
so
when you
bump your head into a wall and it
doesn't go through like this hand right
now cannot go through this hand
that doesn't prove the hand is real
all it proves is that i'm imagining
physicality
that's what physicality is
and a really great way to illustrate
this is for example in your dreams
in your dreams let's say you're being
chased by a serial killer and you're
running away from the serial killer
and there's you know you're running
through your house and then you lock
yourself in the closet and you lock the
door
why are you doing all this in your dream
isn't it obvious that the walls of your
closet and your door in your dream are
just imaginary why wouldn't the serial
killer just
go through the walls like a ghost
why do you believe you gotta lock that
door
because that's what you're dreaming
you're dreaming a dream and physicality
is part of the thing you're dreaming
so within that entire dream you have the
dream of physicality and there you
believe for example in a dream you
believe that you're not going to fall
through the floor why don't you fall
through the floor in your dreams
it's an imaginary floor
but then again falling through is also
imaginary
you see
just like in a video game why doesn't
super mario fall through the floor in a
video game i mean is the floor real
no
what if we take super mario in a video
game and we cut open his skull
and we see a brain there
and then we take a hammer and we bash
his brain
with the hammer
in the video game
and then from that we have a rule we
program a rule that if that happens
then super mario
is gonna his body his
his body's gonna collapse and he's gonna
die argument
right hoffman is wrong by the way about
important things let's get to that
let's get to how your views compare in
contrast to some of the
important thinkers of our time and even
some of those some of your water time so
sure donald hoffman where do you agree
and disagree
actually let's just point out where you
disagree
i'm trying to remember yeah i kind of
need to remember both in order to see
who again said it's a duality
you can't have agreement without
disagreement and vice versa
so um
he's got the right intuition and in fact
i mean
i applaud him for taking some of the
radical stances that he does i want
scientists taking more radical stances
with their metaphysics so i like the
fact that he's sort of adopting this
idealist and what what not sort of
metaphysics and
and he's exploring you know ideas
outside the material domain and he's
questioning materials this is all really
good
the problem still for him
is that even though he meditates a lot
and so forth he's actually not conscious
of the absolute
he's not conscious that qualia or
experience itself is literally the
absolute so in his model what he likes
to say is that it's like a computer
interface like a gui desktop right this
is the metaphor he uses
and he says that well you know i've done
some we we've ran some mathematical
proofs you know he brings math into this
we ran some mathematical proofs and
because you're surviving you know you
grew through natural selection your body
grew up through natural selection your
brain evolved through natural selection
because of this we did some mathematical
calculations what are the probability
what is the probability
that actually the way that your eyes and
your brain perceives reality is truthful
and he says the probability is near zero
he's got it precisely backwards
he's assuming natural selection and
evolution all this stuff he's not
realizing that this is part of the dream
so anyways um
he thinks that reality that reality
somehow there's a truthful reality
somehow like behind the scenes of the
gui interface he's not realizing that
the gui interface is reality absolutely
so what you're seeing right now the
the possibility that what you're seeing
right now is absolutely true
is 100 percent
literally everything you perceive is one
hundred percent absolutely true
otherwise you couldn't perceive it
also part of this model is that there
are multiple wait what do you mean that
what i see is absolutely true
otherwise i wouldn't be able to receive
a why
do you mean sorry let me let me see if
we'll correct my misunderstanding if
it's a misunderstanding
if i see glasses here on my table
then
i see glasses here on my table that's an
experience experience is reality it's
i'm not supposed to infer something from
the glasses about some independent world
that's giving input into my brain which
is being translated into a percept yes
i'm supposed to see this qualia as is
and take the qualia as evidence of the
qualia which is what reality is because
reality is the qualia
exactly so what needs to so the the
fundamental problem with science and
with thinking is that it's fundamentally
indirect it's always
creating something and then it's looking
for something else behind that thing
that justifies it right so like you find
you find an atom and then you say well
there's something behind the atom to
justify the atom and so you go to a
quark and then you find the quark and
you say well there must be something
behind the cork to justify the quark and
then so you find a string and then you
say well the string there must be
something behind a string it must be a
number and then you just find the number
and then you say well but a number is
something in the brain and so there must
be something in the brain there's a
neuron and then it goes around in
circles like this forever and so science
never actually directly contacts
being itself
what's being missed is being would you
consider yourself to be a reductionist
absolutely not productionism is
impossible
that's the cheat that's a chief delusion
of all
scientific pursuit is the idea that you
can reduce one thing to another thing
you can't everything is what it is and
not something else uh so for example you
know if you ask a scientist what is the
color red he will say it's light it's
photons
uh or it's
neuronal activity it's a structure of
neurons it's a network it's information
no all of that is false
what it actually is is it's red red is
red
you have to bite the bullet see what the
scientist doesn't understand is that
it's a what the scientist is doing is
it's endless game of tale chasing that
never ends because he's always coming up
with some new conceptual construction
for some other thing he's trying to
describe
so pick anything in science and there's
going to be some other thing to describe
it and then some other thing and some
other thing and some other thing and
then you never reach the end and it has
to be that way because science must
necessarily avoid the issue of substance
and being
because you can't grasp it through a
conceptual process and science is all
conceptual process you can't have
science without concept this is crucial
to understand for those of you who are
trying to develop a toe or try to do
good science
science is concept like
grasp this
no concept no
science and being is prior to concept
you can exist without having concepts
but you can't have concepts without
existence
this is crucial to understand so i
imagine that what you're saying is being
is prior to concept however however
if one was to investigate what the heck
concept is i'm like well what is the
concept then you say it's so and so then
they say well what is that you would
eventually get down to being so concept
and being are ultimately the same
because everything is the same as being
and which also means everything is the
same as console yeah so
because if concept is the same as being
and everything is the same as being
it depends on how you frame it you could
say that way but it's it it gets muddled
if you say it that way because the the
think of it like this this brings that
analogy with the with the lego blocks
and the two levels so look
this is really important to understand
this is so fundamental
we have lego blocks right
from these lego blocks we can build a
castle or any other shape that we want
there is no limit to what we can build
with the lego blocks
within the limit of how lego blocks
attach to each other right
so
if we build a castle out of legos
the actual blocks we'll call that order
number one
that's the baseline order of reality is
the blocks
that's the substance and then we have
order number two which is the shape that
is built out of the substance
so in that's order number two so in this
case all
concepts and all of science is second
order it's not first order
and so is a sand is is a castle made
is a cat what is castle made up it's yes
it's made of blocks but it's not the
same thing as a block
you see so this distinction is really
crucial i'm
having trouble understanding that if one
isn't a reductionist what makes the
second order level
less important or less fundamental than
the first level
the it's not it's not any less
fundamental really
um the problem is that by confusing
them
you create self-deception so let me give
you another example to explain this so
for example
santa claus
is real
and exists
as a concept
as a concept that's what santa claus is
now the mistake people make is if they
like a child is when you say santa claus
and they think ah santa claus means that
there's actually a man on a north pole
that i can go see
that is a mistake that's not what santa
claus is santa claus is not a man that
exists somewhere santa claus is a
concept a unicorn is a concept
now a unicorn exists as a concept
but that doesn't mean you'll find it at
the at the material level so to speak
so likewise
something like a you know hoffman's gui
interface that exists as a concept
something behind my hands atoms quarks
strings these all exist as concepts
but the hands are here first
the mistake that scientists make in
materials make is they think ah well
strings and atoms those were there
before the hands but no the hands were
here first the atoms and strings came
second
you look at it look at it like this
humans had hands before quark before
there were quarks
before they invented quarks
it wasn't the other way around
but we ignore this i mean it's so
obvious but we ignore it we invented
cork quarks are not quarks were invented
100 years ago human hands have existed
for thousands of years
you would you don't like the
statement that humans discovered quarks
oh we invented that of course
meaning to say we invented the idea of
quarks or the concept of quarks however
what we're trying to
what is the core present with the quark
did that exist that's the whole problem
is
that's the whole problem there's a deep
here
epistemological problem because of
representation that's the whole problem
is because science uses language and
representation so literally you're stuck
in some what's called symbolic logic
symbols
but you have to break down and
deconstruct what a symbol is so what is
a symbol this is extremely profound
because if you don't understand what a
symbol is you're going to get all of
reality wrong
like most
academics do
what a symbol is is so [ __ ] profound
look at this a symbol
is
precisely
not the thing it represents
yes
so for example
the word duck the sound duck
is not a duck
why is this
something that you think academics don't
understand
because i don't imagine i could find an
academic that would think that the
formula for a quark is the same as a
quark in fact it takes many quarks to
even write the formula
well but the whole notion of a quark is
is not there's no such thing as a quark
quark is a concept
see you're imagining that the concept
quark points to something that's a quark
that we can't point to which is beyond
concepts and what i'm telling you is
that that too is a concept it's a chain
of concepts leading to nothing
you're assuming it leads to something
and i'm telling you what that thing
you're assuming it leads to is another
concept it's a concept pointing to a
concept
yeah i'm saying the royal the royal you
us us man mankind
why can't one also say hey man you're
assuming there's only mental there's
only qualia you're assuming that
i'm not assuming it that's literally
what's the case what what have tell me
one thing you've experienced that isn't
quality please derive that without
assuming it
that's not a derivation that's
absolutely through experience
no if you're going to claim let's be
scientific about this if you're going to
claim that there exists something
outside of qualia prove it or at least
even demonstrate one exam i'm not even
asking you to prove it just demonstrate
one example point to one example
because look if if i was if i was
telling you unicorns existed you would
tell me to point to one or if i told you
that uh
dark energy exists you'd have to you'd
have to say
point me some dark energy or some dark
matter or whatever where is we get back
to what we were talking about near the
beginning so it's almost like the
tautology of saying you're essentially
asking by saying prove to me so-and-so
you're essentially asking give me an
experience that isn't experience
right yeah it's a tautology
you can eat you can you can either
assume that's a mistake or it's not
let's steal man the materialist for a
bit
let's imagine on this wall behind okay
there are some
buttons and one of these buttons one of
these ones says pleasure one of these
buttons says pain one of these buttons
says tickle or actually laugh one of
these buttons says
insight and there's another button that
says real
real and you're like well what the heck
does that do okay so you press pain
and then the person you hear someone
scream like your next door neighbor and
then you're like oh that's interesting
okay so then you press
pleasure into
moan and you get them to come in here
you're like dude i want to see this so
they come in and then you're like let me
press pleasure and pain and then they
get one of those erotic fixtiation
orgasms okay you're like oh that's
interesting and then you press pain and
the button unreal and then they're like
oh well i felt pain but i didn't feel
like that was real
and you're like oh that's actually
interesting well that can happen like i
can see something but you also get a
sense that it's unreal that's what
happens sometimes when you learn
horrible news and you feel like in your
dream state
okay so so you get d-ro d-realization is
another word for that okay so then
you're like oh there's a d realization
button which is the same as the unreal
button but then there's a real button so
let me press pleasure and real you're
like oh that was the most real pleasure
i've ever had okay then then let's
imagine there's a button that says
atheist
you press atheist and and unreal and you
get someone who says i feel like
i have this impression that there is no
god but i also had the impression that
that was a false impression
okay now let's press the button that
says god
and unreal and then you you get this
this is the reverse impression okay now
how about we press the button that says
god pleasure
and
real
and then you get this
sense that all that there is and it's
real it's absolutely real and it's also
associated with some pleasure
okay now let's
now let's imagine so i'm still manning
the materialist case okay please emulate
the materialist
i imagine you're like okay well
i am simply pressing these buttons and
this person is feeling so-and-so now
let's what happens if i give them this
psychedelic
or this meditative experience it's
almost like a pill meditative experience
in this example
it changes their neurons i find that
their neurons correspond that's pleasure
oh that that lights up that particular
pattern
that particular pattern lights up for
real unreal okay now what happens if i
take a psychedelic and i
and i notice that when the
now what i see is instead of me pressing
these buttons i give them a psychedelic
and i see the buttons light up because
i'm not pressing i would just see that
one lit up and it said pleasure after
their experience of psychedelics they
say i had a pleasurable experience
another one pleasure god and real and
then they say oh i had a feeling of
profound oneness unity and it was love
and it was absolutely more real than
this okay
then you given the object okay so now
let's imagine we get to some place in
the future
where we're far more sophisticated
neurochemically and with brain imaging
and we can see
that this analogy is more apt than what
i'm saying
would you say that someone who's had the
experience of god realization has had
that experience
or
would you say that it's simply the
neuromodulators and neurotransmitters
well if i was a materialist i would just
excuse all that away and say that it all
boils down to just chemistry
you just have to basically you have to
basically just assume
you know you basically have to assume
some kind of
static structure to a uni to a to a
static structure to a universe whether
it's atoms quarks strings numbers
computers information
and um and then just everything reduces
down to that
and you just kind of keep reducing and
reducing
and uh yeah the point that i'm getting
at is then how do you trust whether or
not the insights from someone let's say
they get the opposite the atheist and
then real and pain
maybe it could be pleasure right so real
and pain
and that's it but it's secular hate
and then you're like well you know what
yeah i don't know if any of that is real
per se because every single time you
come back with a report of an experience
it just corresponds precisely to these
lights and to these patterns
okay well i yeah i would just i would
just ask you or this person with all
these buttons
uh is the unreal button real
you have a button that says unreal is
that button real i'm gonna pretend i'm
gonna put on my materialistic hat and
say hmm i don't know i wouldn't even use
the words real and unreal all i would
say there are reports
of real and unreal of this phenomena
that people claim to be real right yeah
so so this is so
so there's a possibility that what you
consider unreal
and real
uh
you don't know what you're talking about
when you're using those words
yeah so that's doubt
yeah so
um
but also notice that for your thought
experiment to work you need that unreal
button to actually be real
so you're actually contradicting
yourself in your thought experiment
you're imagining an impossible thought
experiment because you're imagining
something unreal and then you're making
it real so like you're imagining unreal
pain
but in fact pain is real
even if even if you say well you know i
experienced some pain and i it felt like
i was in a de-realized state yeah but
that derealized state is still aren't
you aren't you yourself claiming that
it's real
is there a derealized state or not
because if there isn't then why are you
talking about it and if there is well
then there's you're it's real
it's it's just the problem is the
confusion you see concepts create this
multiple
layers of confusion that's what symbols
do you know like we start talking about
a duck and we confuse even though
logically if you ask a professor like is
the word duck the same thing as a duck
he'll say of course not i'm not a
[ __ ] idiot but then
in practice he's gonna go playing with
his math formulas and start talking
about how reality is mathematical
but your mathematics are not reality in
the sense that yes you can you can
project them onto reality you can do
mathematics you can conceptualize you
can talk about ducks but your words
about ducks are not a [ __ ] duck and
they never will be
so you are not allowed to make a leap
from the fact that like max tegmark for
example
makes all sorts of claims about how
reality is mathematical the only reason
it's mathematical is because he's
sitting there and he's so steeped in
conceptual mathematics that that's how
he sees the whole [ __ ] world
when uh
whatever what all you have is a hammer
everything looks like a nail
right and a christian who's who believes
in christ sees everything as a symbol of
christ you know he looks at his morning
toast and he sees christ christ's face
in the morning toast somebody on my
forum recently some christian person
posted up a picture of him um looking up
at the clouds and he saw the face of
jesus in the cloud
that's how a christian thinks
that's how every mind thinks a physicist
thinks that reality is mad of
information or uh
quarks and a string theorist thinks it's
made of strings and a mathematician
thinks man of numbers and then some some
new age person thinks it's made out of
energy you know woo energy and somebody
else thinks mad at something else and
what i'm telling you is that
it's all of that all of your [ __ ]
buttons are imaginary and god is
imagining all of it and it could imagine
infinitely more you can keep imagining
what reality is forever and in fact i'm
telling you something even deeper
i'm not just saying that
imagination is so relative that if you
imagine it deeply enough it literally
becomes your reality so for example for
an atheist literally there is no god for
an atheist god doesn't exist for an
atheist
his reality is that there is no god
that's what right god is imagining god
is imagining there is no god
likewise for example for a materialist a
materialist literally lives in a
material reality
but the difference is is that he thinks
it will always be that way and what i'm
saying is that that's just a temporary
state that can change at any time
so a materialist assumes that his whole
life will be material and what i'm
saying is that well maybe it is now but
in the future you might change your mind
or you might take a psychedelic or
whatever you might have a divine
mystical experience and then you'll
realize that oh all of that was just
imaginary
and also by the way this explains why
why
why another here's here's an issue with
an epistemology that a lot of people who
are studying toes don't take seriously
enough and that is
why
are there people all around the world
throughout every continent and across
all of human history that believe the
most ridiculous [ __ ] things as though
it was true have you noticed this
like
you've got you've got you you you've got
terrorists you've got uh radicals you've
got cult leaders you've got uh you've
got materialists you've got idealists
you've got philosophers and all of them
believe that their worldview is the way
that reality is
how could and it's not like they're just
it's not like they're stupid
we're talking about some of the most
intelligent people in the world for
example isaac newton
believed in god
so you have to believe that isaac newton
was stupid
how do you explain that how could
someone who was so smart in other ways
was so stupid in terms of god now i'm
not citing this as evidence of god i'm
just saying that as one example because
because most scientifically-minded
people will recognize the intelligence
of isaac newton by the way the majority
of of world scientists
believe in god
right um and there's actually good
reason for that i'm just saying that
that like that's something that claimed
by many but but but anyways right
but but then right but a suicide bomber
believes that when he bombs some
civilians he's going to see allah
right he really believes that he
believes it so much he's willing to blow
himself up like
fathom for a moment the sincerity of
that that that's not that's not just a
belief like that is a that is a
that is a whole reality like talk about
uh valtteri you know this is
uh he's he's living in a different
reality
why do you think that some people
believe
that there is free will if you believe
there is no free will let's just why do
you think that some people believe there
is free will why do you think that some
people believe
in a fairy tale notion of god and so on
well
we haven't really even talked about ego
which is a huge we really should have
started this discussion with ego because
it all rolls around ego but i mean
ego is literally
a state of consciousness which believe
it's a finite state of consciousness
which believes it has control over
reality that's what ego is for ego is
there as a sort of mediating control
mechanism
within your psyche
it it's like an assemblage point around
which you can then manipulate reality
and so that ego of course necessarily
believes it has control
it has to because
it that's what it needs to survive as a
finite self
okay so there's an incentive to believe
in free will
well let me see let me see if i can say
it some other way that
that would help you um
in a sense you i'm not necessarily
saying there isn't any such thing as
will there actually is so
there actually is infinite will god has
infinite will it can will anything it
wants we didn't really finish this
discussion from earlier we jumped topics
but let me let me finish this because
it's actually very profound so god has
infinite will but
god
allocates all of its will because it's
completely selfless towards
the most selfless thing it can do which
is love
so in a very twisted paradoxical sense
god has no choice but to be love god
cannot use its will for anything but
love it has to be selfless because
that's what god is
in its most highest absolute infinite
you're using the word will as different
as distinct from free will is that
correct or are they the same
it's going to be very difficult to
define what will is because you can only
define it by looking at it
you have to be conscious of it
um
see physical manifestation literally is
what will is
will will just like imagination you see
imagination can occur inside the human
mind
as mental images but then imagination is
also the physical walls of your house
that's just a deeper layer of
imagination that your ego has no access
to likewise with will
will is uh what you can have in your
little human mind you have a very little
bit of will in your human mind
you can do a little bit and then
at the absolute level will is literally
the couch that you're sitting on the
physical hands that you're looking at
they are literally will
precipitated it's god's will
precipitated as physical form
so for example
i have become so conscious that i
literally became conscious of how i am
willing my hands into existence
as i'm looking at them also i've become
so conscious there's another aspect of
god we haven't discussed yet there's
many aspects
we haven't discussed yet um that i call
self-design
it's when you become so conscious of
yourself as god that you literally
become conscious that you are using your
will and infinite intelligence to design
every hair on your on your arm
you can look at a single hair and you
will become conscious of how you
designed it using your own intellect
another example is that i i was so
conscious i became conscious of how
i wrote every book
ever written by humans so normally we
think that other humans are writing
these books but when you collapse the
boundary between self and other you will
actually realize that you personally you
wrote every book
on your bookshelf back there
does time exist in this realm
no
this is eternal can you then be
conscious of something in the future
make a prediction and then verify it
future doesn't exist in this realm right
okay can you be conscious
it's imaginary like how you said you
at least for historical books you
were conscious of the fact that you've
written them or why you wrote them or
how you wrote them and i'm wondering if
the same
is true about some future event and thus
you can press edge something write it
down
and verify that this was indeed
some truth because
well
you were in some more truthful state it
gets extremely tricky and i know why
you're asking these questions because
materialists always ask for like proofs
you know like yeah if you're on if
you're in a state of omniscience why
don't you just guess the lottery numbers
and become a millionaire i'm not even
asking for proof i'm saying
some evidence even that this is not
something more than simply you telling
yourself this convincing yourself of
this there's a very deep uh metaphysical
problem here it's it's a bit like the
sort of quantum uncertainty principle
like when you try to pin down where a
particle is you actually lose its
definition of being a particle and so
you kind of can't really pin it down
exactly
there's something like that analogous to
that going on in really high states of
consciousness when you're in a really
high state of consciousness you become
so conscious that material reality
literally collapses and the notion of a
future that you can predict
itself starts to break down and melt
away
okay and there and there is um
and
because what you realize is that you're
imagining the entire future
does the notion of the past also
yeah okay like for example you're
imagining your birth
your human birth yeah well i don't see
why please tell me why and i don't mean
to be poking and prodding where i
shouldn't be but why is it that
what's historical you mention historical
documents and your birth which is in the
past as we ordinarily conceive of time
why is it that
those events come to you fairly readily
but if there is no distinction between
past and futures all illusory why isn't
that you can't have and
a premonition of something that's going
to occur
two days from now or four days from now
and
well first of all many
mystical folk do
claim such
premonitions it's called clairvoyance
um it's actually extremely common in
mystical circles and communities and
amongst spiritual masters and teachers i
personally don't claim any of these
abilities
you have to also understand that i'm not
done with my work in many ways i'm just
a beginner in this work
um
and so what kind of abilities i might
develop in the future i'm still
exploring and experimenting with that so
maybe in the future i will develop
clairvoyance i don't know i love that
you're saying that because so many
people will dismiss you i hope
to
dissuade them of their dismissal of you
because they'll think that
judging by the
conviction in which you say your
statements which are large they can be
seemingly egotistical especially if
you're claiming equivalence with god and
it seems like there's no modicum of of
or there's at least a modicum of
self-pride in you when you say that i'm
i'm perhaps there is because everyone is
an ego everyone and you're not claiming
to have zero ego yeah but either way i
like and even one of your videos which
i've time stamped i like that you said
or expressed some doubt
as to
your entire veltan chaong
i have the timestamp here i i to me that
made you much more human even though
obviously
the claim is that you're not but we are
not as well so it's not as if you're
above us in some manner
i'm certainly uh so a couple of
clarifications i'm certainly not immune
to self-deception
like i'm really big on self-deception
and i even say that even if you become
fully enlightened you will still not be
immune to self-deception because
self-deception still happens at the
relative domain
or what when you say yeah like yeah the
sort of just the earthly domain of
living okay here like like for example
you could still be wrong about covid
whatever your beliefs about the vaccine
are you could still be wrong about that
whether you're enlightened or not
because enlightenment and awakening the
absolute truth there's actually sort of
a trade-off when you go so high in your
consciousness you're actually losing
connection to the fine details of this
dream
sort of like look like let's say you
wanted to see the entire planet earth
the more you the more to see the entire
thing you have to zoom out really really
far the further you the further you
use them out the few details you see so
like when so
um we might phrase it like this like if
i tell you i've seen the entire earth as
a whole and you say oh yeah really prove
it tell me tell me how many uh how many
uh houses are
yeah
exactly it's like well but but you're
not seeing that there's actually a
profound trade-off there i had to zoom
really far out to lose the detail to see
it in its totality
and then you know if you want specific
details now i have to zoom back in but
then i lose the totality so there is a
profound trade-off there
so i am not immune to self-deception
because most self-deception just happens
at the ordinary sort of earthly level
material level
and
i can certainly fool myself and i do i
do fool myself about things and i have
to change my beliefs and i i hold false
beliefs about certain things
but the app but the absolute infinity
that is not a belief
and i and i would say i can't be wrong
about that but everything else i could
be wrong about
what's something you recently
have self-deluded yourself about that
you have come to the realization that
you've been self-deluding
um
something non-trivial
yeah
like not about peanut butter and jelly
like oh i actually thought i liked the
creamy peanut butter but i never tried
the chunky kind so um
for a long time i intuited that
paranormal abilities are possible such
as healing clairvoyance other such
things a lot of what is the woo of the
woo new age stuff right even though i
was never really into it per se but then
a few years ago i had a i started
developing some serious health problems
with my stomach i was having a bacterial
infection and it was really difficult
for me to even figure out what it was it
took me a year just to figure out what
it was
so it caused me a lot of suffering and
misery what are those symptoms just pain
uh
basically i have a very limited number
of foods i can eat without causing me
lots of pain
because it feeds the bacterial infection
i'm sorry so i've been dealing with yeah
so i've been dealing with that
um it's kind of been a thorn in my side
and i i went i exhausted all the
traditional methods you know normal
doctors they couldn't help me i went to
many of them tried normal medicines
antibiotics didn't help me
uh so finally i got frustrated i'm like
well but you know i've accessed some of
these higher dimensions of consciousness
and i intuit that this sort of
paranormal stuff is probably possible
even though i don't have these powers
myself so why don't why don't i go to
yelp and just look at in in town in
vague i live in vegas they just look
look first look for some paranormal
healer type of people
look for some um clairvoyant like i
actually went to some fortune tellers
oh man because i was thinking i was
thinking like if i can go to one of
these fortune tellers and and all i want
from the fortune teller is like i don't
want a lottery number just tell me what
the actual root cause is of this stomach
issue
so i actually went to some of these
fortune tellers and they weren't just
these hokey fortune tellers uh some of
them were like reiki master type people
that do like energy healing work you
could you could find
yeah and so um
so anyways and and then what i decided
to do i'm like well but i don't know can
i trust these [ __ ] fortune teller
people i mean i'm very skeptical
that's too bad
the reason i say it's too bad is uh i
would i would have i want to know what
was that experience like going in
believing them or at least being so
open-minded that you're well i well i'm
gonna get to that because i mean i i was
a bit desperate and this is part of how
people deceive themselves is that you
gotta have some element of desperation
so ordinarily i'm very rational but you
know when you're under when you have a
serious
health condition that's one of the
things that makes you very desperate i
mean you're willing to believe anything
at that point to you know if you've got
cancer or something you'll you'll try
anything once you exhaust all the
traditional stuff and it doesn't work
i mean what do you got to lose you got
nothing to lose because your life is
going to hell so anyways
so i decided ah what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna i'm gonna schedule like five
different of these
healers and fortune teller type folks
and i'm gonna go to all of them in the
same week and i'm not gonna communicate
what each of them told me so i'm gonna
play them off each other like like you
like to do with your guests so i'm going
to play them off each i mean this is a
technique i've used for years with
science and all sorts of stuff so anyway
i'm going to play them off each other
so so that's what i did
and i went to to these different uh folk
and uh
i want to make sure i'm understanding
what do you mean when you say you played
them off one another you're trying to
manipulate them or you're trying to see
if one is telling the truth or what do
you mean
well i i i was basically like for
example i wanted to go to like a fortune
teller and say i have this health
condition uh can you tell me what the
root cause is and she would tell me oh
it's because you you you were you did
something bad in your past life
and so i would say okay maybe it's that
maybe i don't know maybe then i would go
to a different one i would say okay i
got this health condition and i wouldn't
tell her that i went to the previous one
yeah okay
tell me tell me what the root cause is
and then she would say oh well it's
because you uh you masturbate too much
or whatever right and then so so we're
going to compare all these and see i
mean supposedly if it's true they're all
supposed to align i mean that's how
science works right
the answers are supposed to align
so what i found in the end is uh that
the answers didn't align very well
and in fact i actually i got so
desperate and but also see guys said i
was also doing this not just out of
desperation i was also curious i knew
that i could use this to refine my
epistemology
so
um
i was hoping it would work but also um
so one of the ladies basically says um i
have this uh friend who works with dark
energy
he might be able to help you okay so i
called so i call this this [ __ ] guy
he says he says for 200 i can remove
dark entities that are inhabiting your
body
okay like you know evil spirits and
stuff so literally i drive out in the
middle of the desert he lives in the
middle of the desert
this dude
uh so i spent like four hours with him
and he he basically does an exorcism on
me
okay and i'm he's describing all this
wild stuff that he's doing but i'm not
feeling anything
he's like he's he's acting as though
he's like pulling evil spirits out of my
body and so forth
and
and i'm just i'm i'm very open i'm open
to the idea but at the same time i'm not
[ __ ] gullible right i understand that
i can't just accept him on his word
so and he basically tells me look
i've cured you
ninety percent of your problems are gone
don't worry about it go home in a month
give it a month to settle and you'll
feel great no more problems
and and i'm like yeah i don't really buy
that but i'll try it
um anyways so i tried it
and in the first week i even had like
a relief in my symptoms for the first
week and i i almost like
i was kind of stunned i'm like maybe
this is real like i actually had a
relief of my siblings for about a week
um but then beyond that it didn't it
didn't really change my symptoms at all
and i'm here i am a year later and still
dealing with the same [ __ ]
and so um
so what that
what that taught me in terms of
self-deception you were asking
originally is is that um
i became
much more aware of the importance
of of being skeptical of all this kind
of woo stuff
uh i
i still think that some of it could be
real
but i i don't just subscribe to it
as gullibly as maybe i would have in the
past
especially when when you when you're
motivated to want to believe it have you
experimented with self-healing
especially being in one of these altered
states
yes and and i could even admit that
there was some self-deception there as
well because i was also very motivated
to want to heal myself
so after that kind of healing didn't
work i tried to say okay [ __ ] well why
shouldn't i be able to do it if other
people can do it why can't i do it on
myself
so i have i've tried to heal myself from
very high states of consciousness
um
and and sometimes even like
kind of
believing that maybe it worked
uh and
it didn't work
see uh for the people listening i would
like you if you've listened this far i'd
like you to re-listen to this podcast
because
probably as you listen to leo in the
beginning
the
seeming audacity of him and his claims
may have turned you off but it's toward
the three-quarter mark where
leo right here you leo you're expressing
so much humility and skepticism
that it
buttresses your
other claims it at least makes it more
palatable for the people who are
who are likely turned off which i'm sure
you also get in your youtube comments
but if you've listened this far you're
likely extremely open-minded however i
recommend you again listen with fresh
ears
how do you get what is this what is this
barometer of woo that you have and how
does one
calibrate theirs
so so but but and then even to build
further on this so this really started
to get me to wonder like
um how do i make sense of this how do i
make sense of the fact that there are
for example
there are exorcists who genuinely fully
believe that what they're doing is
exercising demons from your body like
they are fully in it like they are not
they are not
just uh you know scammers
looking for 200.00
um
they are like you can tell that these
are genuine like
kind-hearted people in fact this guy who
i paid 200 for the exorcism he told me
that there's only going to be one
you will never need a second exorcism
ever again in your life so you're only
going to pay me 200 and that's it
right because like and that was very
interesting
because i would think that like you know
if he's a scammer yeah why would he set
it up that way he would like i would
have a whole scheme of like ladders like
a almost like an mlm scheme of like oh
you've you've reached tier one and then
you got to reach tier two and this and
keep paying me right 200
is not a lot of money for
for four hours of work right he was with
me for four hours
so um and then and and he's never called
me he's never asked me for money i've
never heard from him since yeah i got
him he never asked he's never asked me
to refer anybody to him or anything he's
a very kind of like reclusive guy lives
in the [ __ ] desert so like how do you
explain that
and um
and the way that i the way that my model
in worldview explains it
is that basically
all of us are living in our own bubble
of reality so to speak
and
we assume generally that we're living in
the same reality and in a sense we're
not
uh we are constructing
our own dreams and these dreams we could
say interpenetrate to some degree
but to a much lesser degree than many
people and materialists especially and
scientists assume there's a lot of
there's a lot of very weird [ __ ]
that you could be dreaming but that
you're not dreaming
that those woo people are dreaming so
it's not that those people are deluded
per se
it's that they are literally inhabiting
a different dream in which like i
believe that that guy to his son to
himself in his own mind he was seeing
demons he was pulling out of my body but
that doesn't mean that it's true for me
because i'm i'm dreaming a different
dream that is not fully aligned with the
dream that he's dreaming
and so
if you actually study deeply these
woo-woo people and you ask them about
their first person experiences this is
where you get the real gold
they will tell you about
visions they have entities they see
ghosts [ __ ] aliens uh
um
you know evil entities and ufos and
whatever else
uh angels and [ __ ]
and
the mistake that the materialists and
the scientists make is he says oh well
this is all it's all nonsense even
rupert spirit told you that's nonsense
it's not nonduality right he told you
that he considers it nonsense
uh even that is not quite correct
it might be nonsense from a
us you know from a sort of a consensus
reality point of view it's nonsense
maybe it's nonsense from the scientific
point of view you can't
prove it
according to materialistic
standards of proof and by the way those
proof standards are all relative and
there's many problems with how we define
proof within science we can talk about
that but anyways
but what you have to understand is the
open your mind of the possibility that
those people who claim that they're
seeing angels and devils and
whatever
they're actually seeing it
and the reason that is in my model it's
very easy to explain that it's because
there's really no difference between a
dream and physical reality and if you
take psychedelics you'll you'll you'll
see
you can take so much lsd that literally
when you look at your hands your hands
can turn into the hands of a devil
try it
yeah
well
be careful when you try that that
particular experiment
if you d
if you dare yeah
i still
don't
see why it's not delusion in your mind
you said they they inhabited a different
world now our worlds intersect and we
can call this objective reality though
objective reality intersects to a much
lesser degree than we think it's more
protean than we think well i'll tell you
why it's like this
for example
you can understand language
you have that capacity
an animal your dog if you have one
cannot understand
words written on a page
so from the point of view of a dog your
ability to understand language is
delusion
when you read a book you think that the
book actually means something from the
dog's point of view the book means
nothing and that you're deluded to claim
that the book means anything the way i'm
imagining this we got to use a different
example than a dog dogs don't even think
in terms of delusion there's like oh is
there food is there not food
so let's let's take a let's take an
example of someone else like another
person from a different culture well
that that's just but we'll get to that
but that's actually a good point a dog
doesn't think about delusion that means
the
consider this that delusion literally
does not exist for a dog that's a human
idea a human notion
right because people just assume that oh
delusion is just like a existential fact
maybe not maybe delusion is actually
something that is particular to humans
or to certain kinds of
beings
but yeah go on what example did you want
to use oh just use a different culture
instead of a dog
another culture that has the idea of
delusion
so they would look at you with your
beliefs of
non-duality all of your beliefs of the
bible
yeah let's take even like a very
skeptical child you might even take a
young child
and show him that there are that there
are words written on a book that let's
say he doesn't know how to read he
hasn't learned language you could show
him
and he
that child if he was raised improperly
or so he might be skeptical he might say
um no
that means nothing
it's not possible to read
how would you teach a child to read if
he's so skeptical he doesn't even
believe that reading is possible let's
say he only has verbal language but no
reading ability
how would you do that
you see
he would really be stuck that's so
that's why skepticism is so dangerous
because you can really get yourself
stuck with with skepticism because
here's the ultimate thing is that if you
want you can be skeptical to an absolute
degree about absolutely anything
you can literally deny
that um
you can you can deny
that the sky is blue can you deny that
you're conscious
isn't that what you isn't that what
you're doing
you can certainly deny that you're
conscious
um but you'd have to be conscious
but you'd have to be conscious to do it
in some sense you're right
about me denying
my own consciousness and i'm not doing
so consciously
at least i don't think so but i do have
a feeling that
there's a strong relationship between
what's evil and what
is
against existence now that's like chris
langan
formulation but there's also and
existence is tied with consciousness
and i imagine that one can be so
wrapped up in one's own
self
that one denies oneself
well yeah that's that's exactly that's
exactly what an atheist does an atheist
is one who is in denial of oneself as
god
well i would just say
forget about god forget about using that
word i would say that an atheist is in
denial
of
that's that's tricky i would say that an
atheist can be in denial of themselves
being conscious because they reject
existence to such a degree or they hate
it at some level
they don't they don't have to hate it
like when i was an atheist i would i
loved existence as an atheist um and if
someone as an atheist told me that i am
you know denying that i'm god i would
just laugh at them i would say they hate
it at some level and the reason is that
if you talk to an atheist
it's so
interesting to me they have a hatred for
god they don't
it's not simply that they don't believe
in god and the reason is i agree with
the reason is this
they hate the concept of it no not just
that they hate they would hate god if
god existed and the reason is they have
an arrogance about them they'll say that
well what about the problem of how the
heck is a problem the problem of
suffering even a problem it's because
you think you know better you think that
you that there should be no suffering
and then some atheists would even say i
don't want to live in a i don't want to
believe in a god that would allow a
child to be tortured and raped i would
hate such a god
yeah well that's just yeah they're just
fooling themselves there
they they're just not conscious enough
to see what evil really is or what
suffering is really about
but i i i mean evil is just selfishness
that's all it is
which is equivalent to lack of
consciousness
so the less conscious you have the more
the more quote-unquote evil you're gonna
be
interesting by which by which we mean
you're gonna you're gonna take more
pleasure in actually uh negativity so
you might say like the lower your
consciousness the more pleasure you're
going to take and actually the suffering
of others so a really easy way to tell
whether somebody is high conscious or
low consciousness or how developed they
are is just take a look do they actually
derive pleasure from the suffering of
others
like us you know psychopathic people
will actually enjoy torturing animals
that's a very that's a telltale sign of
many uh early
signs of a psychopath is that they do
that in their childhood
or even like for example you watch
political news and you can actually see
sometimes something happens to the other
political party and some people are like
well but yeah i mean like that
republican died even though he was a
coveted denier he died and i don't and i
don't take any pleasure in his death he
was being foolish but i don't take any
pleasure in his death some some of the
higher conscious commentators will say
that that's a that's a high conscious
person a low conscious commentator will
say he died and he deserved it and i'm
kind of happy he died right
i see that plenty i recall you saying
that you disagree that the left and the
right are of equal
merit and that and that that's somewhat
of a naive view
and you believe that the conservative
side at least as it currently is
formulated at least within the popular
news pundits are more
likely to lie and be
prone to tribalism and so on compared to
the left i don't agree with that i
i mean and especially not now especially
seeing the hatred toward anything that's
like trump or anything that's like a
trump supporter i see them as
being so unwilling to give trump any
credit for anything positive and if
that's true of course something positive
it was by accident or through his
selfishness he has done nothing for the
good of america by with
with any good intention on his part
and i i don't see that as characterizing
any human there's almost no human that's
completely good nor completely evil
sure of course
i would agree with that
so then this also reminds me of sam
harris
so there's a couple you remind me a
couple couple people so tom thomas can
can we take a quick break here for yeah
sure sure
okay yeah and i'm going to reset the
camera too all right man
there's so many problems that i have
with the moral landscape
in terms of in principle problems let
alone practical problems and one of them
is that it's not even clear to me that a
state of all suffering is possible given
what you just said which is
some people derive the most pleasure
from
committing suffering to others i don't
know if it's physically possible to have
a state where there's the most suffering
for all beings simultaneously and then
even if so it's not like well i have
many
different
critiques about that but either way i'm
curious what you think about sam
harris's moral landscape additionally
you mentioned well it has to be true for
you truth is
strange it's absolute and relative at
the same time which reminds me of thomas
campbell so i'm going to ask you about
sam harris your views
and then thomas campbell so let's go on
sam harris and the moral landscape so
i've not read the moral landscape i'm
more familiar with his like metaphysical
views and his
views on awakening and stuff if you want
to summarize to me um what his views
like like for example uh um i mean i i
do generally consider sam harris sort of
what i would call a moralist in other
words he actually believes there's sort
of like an objective right and wrong or
good and bad yeah so i would disagree
with him on that on that
um
all all good
is relative
so
that's just what you'll discover as you
become more conscious
it's basically you're going to find that
it's impossible to define what is good
or what is bad in any kind of finite way
like for example if we're talking about
what's good for humanity
you can't actually define that
because humanity is a bunch of disparate
agents they all have their own agendas
and selves and finite selves that
they're trying to survive so what we
really mean by good the the normal human
relative sense of good if we're not
talking about absolute good is just like
what is
what is good for the ego for the human
ego and you can have egos at different
levels of development and different
degrees of consciousness and some egos
are more expanded some egos are more
contracted and so and we have
seven or eight billion egos on this
planet and there's going to be a lot
more of them
in the future
and so
there is no possible way that you can
come up with a unified definition of
what is good for all of them there's
always going to be trade-offs and this
is why we have the kind of chaos we see
in our political system
is that when you have a radical
democracy where everyone gets to vote
everyone is voting for their own self
agenda
and so even the most selfless people
unless they're infinitely selfless which
nobody is basically
they're all going to have their own
biases and and
interests and there's always going to be
competition between all that
like even if we were to you know meet
aliens let's say aliens land on the
white house law and tomorrow and they
are very conscious loving aliens
but they are still going to be finite
and their agenda
might be you know a beautiful agenda
relatively speaking but it's not going
to be some absolute agenda and we are
still going to have to negotiate with
their agenda and our agenda and to see
you know how are we going to negotiate
that with the politics of it should be
it's going to be very messy and you
can't say what's really good or bad in
that
it's it's very relativistic as far as
sam's metaphysics
he wrote a book called awake i believe
or something like that waking up is that
what his book his podcast used to be
called that now he changed it um
it's because of that book
actually i got the same just so you know
between podcaster or youtuber to
youtuber to the degree you can call
ourselves youtube that i was given the
advice kurt change your podcast name
from better left unsaid which is what it
used to be about a year ago
to something else because i have a film
coming out called better left instead
and people are going to get confused and
this person who's given me this vice
advice is a close friend of sam harris
and he said sam harris has the same
problem or had the same problem which is
why he calls it making sense now because
he had a book called i believe it's
awakening or what is it called what was
waking up i think waking up right it was
a book called that and then you confuse
it with the podcast and people conflate
the two so keep them separate
for legal reasons and just just for the
public okay continue sorry
yeah well it's also misleading because
he's not fully awake so he doesn't
really he doesn't really understand what
he's talking about when he's talking
about non-duality and god and and and no
self so he's had some degree of
awakening into what i would call the
truth of no self what buddhists call
anata the truth of no self and that's of
course valid it's a valid and important
facet it's an it's usually an early
stage of awakening is when you realize
that the
the biographical
ego self is actually a mental
construction it's not a physical thing
that exists in the universe
so that's what he's realized and that's
what he kind of teaches that
and
no you know
and so that that's valid but the pro but
the problem is that there are much
higher degrees of awakening
uh
and then ultimately god realization and
infinite states of consciousness which
which actually get you to understand the
very fabric of existence itself and he
has obviously not penetrated into that
because he doesn't know he can't speak
about what truth is for example you ask
him what truth is he can't tell you
you ask him where existence came from he
can't tell you
he's just going to say well we don't
know and it's impossible to know you
know it's that's not something i'm
supposed to be able to answer but
the whole point of awakening to truly
awaken means that you you have answered
all existential questions the biggest
ones you know where it came from why it
exists
what love is you know what truth is you
know what's absolute um
um
and you can easily talk about these
things
uh without a bunch of
you know
conceptual or philosophical sort of like
uh
waffling
um and and you're also not gonna be
denying god
so he's not he's not conscious that he's
god fundamentally that's the problem
so if he would humble himself and open
his mind more and continue with the work
rather than doing his podcast
he would eventually reach a stage where
his entire sense of reality and mind
would collapse he would have an
existential crisis it would be very
painful for him because he has deep
attachments to materialism but he would
see past that and eventually he would
become god realized and he would realize
that he is god dreaming up
the entire sam harris persona which he's
still playing and i don't blame him i
mean it's fun to play sam harris
i'm sure you
i'm sure he gets paid well and so forth
why do you think it is because he has
experimented publicly so with
psychedelics right to a large degree why
do you think it is that he hasn't had a
huge encounter a terrifying encounter
with god or with love or with his
atheism coming to dissolution well first
of all i would say he did it to a small
degree to not to a large degree of
course large and smaller relative
notions
but from what i understand he has not
really done a lot of psychedelics
um
at very high doses
and also because he has a very dense
materialistic mind his mind is very much
enmeshed not with just with materialism
but also with philosophy and science and
his moral philosophy and his
intellectual persona as a public
intellectual right and his whole
business model and his whole brand is
that the people who follow sam harris
are spiro dynamic stage orange highly
rational skeptical atheistic people
that's his brand
he he like probably 80 90 of his
audience you know his most rabid fan
base are those people and what he sells
them
is
a philosophy that buttresses and
reinforces
their worldview in the same way that you
know a conservative fox news uh host
like tucker carlson what he's selling is
he's selling
propaganda to reinforce the world view
of those people who he's appealing to
you know the conservatives and that's
what sam harris is doing but at a higher
level
and so um for him to have a god
realization and then to come back and to
tell all those people hey guys you know
i'm sorry i was wrong actually i'm god
for him to do that that would be so
antithetical to his survival agenda like
it would be extremely threatening it
would be very painful and he would lose
half of his audience i mean he could do
that but
it would be very difficult
so i and i empathize i'm not criticizing
him for it i i empathize with how
difficult that would be to do
in the same way that it would be very
difficult for
for a suicide bomber to admit you know
hey guys
my notion of allah was all [ __ ] and
you know what i don't have to kill
people to appease allah or whatever like
that would be very difficult for a
suicide bomber to admit that and to
reform himself because he's so steeped
in that ideology and his entire life is
in business and his career and his
family they're all tied in with that
that's how he survives
is through that ideology so ideology is
the most dangerous thing and ideology is
not just something stupid religious
people have it it's not just for about
topics ideology very much exists
within science
and philosophy as rationalism this very
stubborn
arrogant
attachment to a material
logical
universe and anything that
contradicts that gets demonized as
woo-woo or whatever it just it gets
ignored
and then and then you get stuck in it
i never thought of it like that with
respect to taking a psychedelic and then
it not totally shattering your world
view because your world view is so
entrenched
oh yeah that's
yeah because what what the psychedelic
will do
if you do enough of them is that they
will it the psychedelic is trying to
expand your consciousness but your
consciousness can only expand as much as
you're willing it to expand
so if your mind is not radically open
and you know yours is
unlike most people's so for you might be
difficult to actually empathize with
somebody who's got a very close mind um
it is that way for me to i'm very
open-minded i have to be to do this work
um but there were there were things that
i learned through psychedelics that are
were so radical it would it created
existential crises for me that i would
have to sit and just you know
um curl up into a ball
and just lie there on the floor
integrating this thing you really have
to go through all of your psychological
baggage before the psychedelics will
allow you to expand consciousness into
the deep
metaphysical and existential and
epistemological framework of reality and
that's exactly what most people
encounter on psychedelics because they
take a psychedelic but they don't have
the intellectual framework
and they have so much trauma fear
attachment and psychological baggage
it'll take them years to work through
that
many trip dozens of trips to work
through that until you clear all that
out and then finally you can say okay
i'm no longer afraid i'm no longer
anxious i've gotten rid of all my trauma
now show me what reality
is and then
you'll be shown
but it does takes a lot of work for most
people
okay i'm going to get personal and so
i'll probably bleep my name or just
remove this one part but leave your
answer to this
when i took psychedelics for the first
time i wasn't expecting first of all i
didn't know what to expect and i was
what what one would call a hard-nosed
atheist and i pretty much was even after
that it's not as if it shook my atheism
it shook my ideas to what consciousness
could be but not my atheism
and i took a regular dose one tab and it
and i remember
i'm just telling you this personally leo
because i'm curious to know what you
think so i remember just going to the
mirror and feeling like i couldn't
control my breath
and that was so terrifying i went on the
floor i couldn't speak and then two of
the people that i was with came to me
and looked at me and said like are you
okay okay and i said ask me only
yes or no
questions and i couldn't even because i
couldn't say it with emotions emotions
for me to display an emotion was far too
much effort i could feel it terrifyingly
in the back and i but luckily i had
enough i was cognitive enough for them
to say that okay for me to say that okay
then they were a bit worried about me
and it came in waves and so on okay
that's cons that's traditional
psychedelics comes in waves
and
but i would have thought
that my previous world view would was
extremely
i i would have
like i would imagine it as an extremely
toughly built home
steel girders and so on and
but the psychedelic i took wasn't
hurricanes worth it was pretty much a
wind's worth like but i don't know why
that wind blew my house down however the
other person i'm with
he is also a staunched atheist
materialist
but hasn't thought much about his own
philosophy
that's that's the key and he no no but
he
what i'm saying but he took the same
dose and has taken other doses and has
never had personal insights at all he
takes even larger doses and just views
it as oh i can see the walls changing
that's so interesting because
it's extremely easy to explain because
it's obvious that your mind actually
wants to understand the very fabric of
existence like this is your whole thing
you're you want the toe you want you
want the understanding whereas
you have to understand that most people
don't care about philosophical or
metaphysical topics at all like it
doesn't even interest them to most
people you take a guy off the street you
say hey do you want to know what the
why the universe exists and he'll be
like sure tell me and then you tell him
and he's like okay cool and he just goes
by about his day like he doesn't care he
doesn't it doesn't land on him he
doesn't realize the significance of this
and he's not thinking deeply about
mathematics and physics and trying to
connect everything together into some
larger thing and like no he's just going
about his life you know all he cares
about is like sex and food and simple
things like this
and survival
also he's not as open-minded as you
you're probably the one top
top one percent
of the world in terms of open-mindedness
whereas he may just be a close-minded
person by his you know five personality
type temperament or whatever
um furthermore another important aspect
there's layers to to why psychedelics
are so complex
is that you can't assume that
psychedelics affect everybody the same
at a physiological level right so we
tend to we tend to assume that like well
if i take one tab of lsd and my friend
takes a type of lsd we should have the
same experience
no not at all like i am extremely
sensitive to psychedelics if i take a
psychedelic it's going to be about three
times more potent than it will be for an
average person
i've tested this and figured it out with
you know looking at how other people do
it yeah so like it's a v
it's it's a very so some people are
extremely sensitive conversely other
people have extreme tolerances i know
some people like on my forum that will
say they do 500
micrograms of lsd and to them that's
like
an you know a pleasant trip if i took
500 milligrams of micrograms of lsd i
would be in outer space and probably you
know right because i couldn't even see
the walls of my house
so it's it varies enormously and it
doesn't just vary in terms of dosage you
have to understand furthermore it varies
in terms of just what is going on
because remember what i told you earlier
is that my theory is that we're sort of
living in our own bubble realities
and everyone's bubble reality is a
little bit different and so you're going
to see different things you know like
um
like for example when i do dmt just
regular dmt i people talk about
experiencing entities and a lot of
visuals i don't get any of that i just
go straight to infinity i don't get
aliens i don't get dmt entities i don't
get fractals and a bunch of colors and
stuff it's just like just
i'm in the same space but i just become
infinitely conscious
of the space so it's very it's very
different
have you tried different doses of dmt
oh yeah
well if if i took any higher dose i
would i would be dead right now
okay have you taken the lesser classes
of dna i've taken the highest tier
i've taken so much and by the way it's
not a lot i've take by normal standards
it would be little but since i'm so
sensitive you know i've taken so much
that it's like
literally to the point of suicide
suicidal levels of dose
um so i wouldn't be comfortable taking
more
and then lower doses yeah
of course but all even the lower doses
sent you to infinity none of them gave
you an encounter with a fractal geometry
or
aliens and so on
no demons and aliens i i i get a little
bit of fractals that just comes
naturally with most psychedelics um
especially if i focus in on it i can i
can sort of
almost kind of maneuver my way through
the space a little bit
and it kind of depends on what i want
usually i don't i don't care about the
visuals i i care about the insights and
i care about the ultimate understanding
so i just i just go straight basically
to infinity yeah even on even on like
normally any threshold dose of
psychedelic at this point will just send
me straight into infinity and then if i
take higher doses it'll be just like
almost suicidal levels of infinity
to the point where the i experience such
ecstatic uh bliss
and pleasure from the infinite love that
i experienced when i'm
um you know
going that high
that
it becomes it becomes impossible for
like the body to even contain it you
want to kill yourself because it's too
it's too pleasure
it's too much pleasure basically the
pleasure goes infinite imagine
experiencing infinite pleasure forever
you would think that would be that would
be like a dream come true but actually
what happens is that your body and ego
mind can only tolerate so much pleasure
after a certain while comes
unpleasurable it becomes yeah it
actually becomes like traumatizing
it's it's too pleasant you want it to
stop
so part of your spiritual practices is
actually to raise your ceiling on how
much spiritual bliss you can experience
because that is like your glass ceiling
and it prevents you from experiencing
more love really fundamentally what it
is it's a fear of love
you're fearing experiencing more and
more of your own consciousness because
what happens is at that at those levels
of consciousness you become so loving
imagine falling in love with
torture
rape um
you know hitler and like
these things become so loving like it's
scary it's frightening to love these
things
to such high degrees
and most people would would think
they're losing their mind and it does
feel like insanity at times
and many many people don't have very
stable minds
so they can take a psychedelic and then
they will veer off into some sort of
twisted direction they'll have negative
thoughts and then you know they'll
believe that demons are real and demons
are chasing them it literally turns into
a nightmare
and that's the classic bad trip
what are some tips you have for people
to avoid
a negative trip
and
even
the
suicidal thoughts that come with
these
seemingly at least from one perspective
nihilistic
points of view
when i say nihilism and what i'm
referring to is the lack of morality
let's say a morality or relativeness
right okay um
yeah so the number one simplest thing
you can do is just lower your doses
people get cocky and take higher doses
as though it's a game like you you need
to treat the psychedelic like a loaded
gun basically or like a a bottle of
nitroglycerin i mean this [ __ ] is
is is so
powerful and so potentially dangerous if
you take too much
so i would just
stay in the moderate low to moderate
zone don't go for hideo don't go for
heroic doses there's this sort of stupid
idea within the psychedelic community of
like oh yeah man i took a heroic dose
and then someone else is like oh yeah i
took a double heroic dose
and um just the way that most
psychedelics are done are so
irresponsibly simply because people are
just popping stuff they're not measuring
it
they're eyeballing something and then
they end up taking twice as much as what
they should
and this is mostly what leads to bad
trips is you just you took too much more
than you can handle in the same way that
if you're going to go drinking you know
know your limit when you drink
don't drink an entire bottle of vodka
and then act surprised the next day
that you're in hell it's also oxymoronic
because they're saying look i took a
double heroic dose well truly if you
took a heroic dose you would have a
dissolution of your ego and you wouldn't
be boasting about taking a double heroic
dose
yeah well they may have lost the ego for
a while but the ego comes back after the
trip in most cases true true and it can
even come back stronger it can now feel
like oh yeah
i conquered i took the heroic dose and i
conquered my fear and that now becomes
the new ego
hmm
that's it that's interesting
okay so how does one avoid
the suicidal thoughts that come
along with with nihilism
uh it's it's hard for me to say because
because normally i don't i'm not i'm a
very
psychologically stable person i have
always been that way just
a strength of mine i'm a very grounded
person actually
um
and
i rarely have suicidal thoughts
and so it's hard for me to relate to
people who like live in a constant state
of of negativity and depression and who
have like a miserable life they have a
shitty job they have a shitty family
life they've been abused they've been
traumatized i didn't have a lot of
trauma when i was young i was fortunate
to grow up in a nice
our family was dysfunctional in many
ways but
um you know i received love for my
mother and care for my dad and so forth
so
those of you who had difficult
childhoods lots of trauma
those of you who have lives that you
just don't like you're miserable at your
job and you feel stuck
or you have mental instability or mental
illness even
you have to really be careful with the
doses
and also you have to do a lot of the
basic self-help work you have to realize
before i got into psychedelics i was i
never took a single drug i didn't even
drink i didn't smoke weed
i didn't do anything
um
and i got into psychedelics only like
four or five years ago
and until that i did like
10 to 15 years of work on my life
i worked on my diet on my health on my
fitness on my relationships on my
sexuality i worked on my business i
worked on my career i got all those
things in order i got all my ducks in a
row i did introspection i worked out
various lingering traumas that i did
minor traumas that i had i worked those
out i so i worked out a lot of stuff
plus i did a lot of study of philosophy
and science and
metaphysics and epistemology and i had
those foundations in place so then when
i went into psychedelics
for the most part it was all very
beautiful and very
and very smooth and easy whereas most
people don't do any of that work and
then their friends give them a couple of
tabs of lsd at a party and then yeah
they freak out
how old are you now
36
yeah
i'm losing track of time with all this
covet nonsense
you're extremely wise extremely
extremely wise for someone who is so
young
and something that strikes me about your
character
is that i watch people
like uh like a hawk when i view videos
with them or when i'm interviewing them
and or and i notice that
if there's this is
if there's a skill that i have above all
else it's not math it's not physics it's
not
even
interviewing per se it's
it would be i can read people
i can i pick up on the slightest
hints of insecurity in body language or
dogmatism in so and so area partly
because i have so much of it myself and
i've observed so much and i constantly
observe it in myself so much of it is
being so self-conscious that i'm
conscious of other people because i can
now apply it
and i don't and i sense deception and i
can sense
i can sense the slightest well i can
sense deception in people and i don't
sense
that what you're saying is
for the sake of your own
ego
or
that you
don't believe what you're saying
so there's
there's a congruency about yourself
that i commend
and i i have plenty of uh egoic
tendencies too so
um
there are many times where i want to
exaggerate something
or i want to paint it in a better light
than it really is or where i'm insecure
about sharing something or being
vulnerable about something there's a lot
of stuff that i don't share
um
[Music]
so
by no means
like
honestly i have so much
the the the tricky thing is that it's in
a certain sense it's actually easy to
access
infinity the hard part is how do you
bring it back down to earth and then
embody it and that is something that i
still have a lot of work left to do that
i'm sorting through
so it's it's really bringing the
absolute down into the relative domain
that is the most challenging thing
and in that sense i have a lot of
deficiencies
and uh
and honestly many spiritual teachers and
even masters do
because like it's it's a really
difficult challenge
this is why you see many gurus and so
forth
uh having all sorts of sex scandals
or
character problems or sometimes even
addictions and so forth just because you
have to really distinguish between
accessing the absolute
that's one thing
accessing the truth in a certain sense
that's easy
that does not mean your character is
going to be good it does not mean you're
going to be a moral person it does not
mean that you're going to please
everybody and also everybody who's
looking at you and judging you is
judging you through their ego so they
have their own expectations so it's
almost impossible to meet all of their
expectations because they just conflict
with each other
so
is that because accessing this
information this truth is different than
believing the truth or is that
independent of what you're saying
well truth is not a belief truth is what
is the case
so you can access truth it's not
information it is being
you can become conscious of like you can
look at your hands but the fact that
you're looking at your hands and you're
conscious of them that doesn't
you know if i have a porn addiction that
doesn't cure my porn addiction
if i have uh if i'm
if i'm in a fight with my parents that
doesn't cure you know my problems with
my parents if i'm addicted to greasy
food and bacon that's not going to
remove that because
the mind most of the structure of the
mind still remains and the mind
has attachments and biases and beliefs
still remain
and so you're not done deconstructing
the mind even after you've accessed
infinity
should i want to get rid of attachment
well it depends on what your goals are
there are no absolute shoulds you can
do whatever you want it just depends on
what you want out of your life so if you
have a certain goal i can tell you
whether
like for example if if your goal is to
become more loving
then yeah it helps to get rid of
attachments
because every attachment is a bias that
keeps you from experiencing higher
degrees of love
because love literally is a lack of bias
what about if your goal is to feel
happiness or pleasure should one get rid
of their attachments or get rid of
attachment in general
well every attachment is going to bring
with it suffering
because
one of the core principles
of buddhism which i agree with is
impermanence the idea that no form in
the universe can be permanent you can't
make any form permanent and everything
that you attach to is a form of some
kind
it's either an object a person a feeling
an emote by form i even mean things like
pleasure
that's a form
um
and even ideas are forms they're subtle
forms in your mind
so if you get attached to the idea of
materialism
that's a problem if you get attached
even if you get attached to the of god
that's also a problem because god is not
an idea god is not your idea of god
so that will create an obstacle
and suffering will come from that
because reality is fluid and it's always
changing so anything you attach to
since reality is always fluid and
changing at some point you're going to
lose it and when you lose it that's when
you're going to suffer
right so so any any person you love is
going to die obviously we know that
so any pleasure any pleasure you receive
from loving a person you're you're also
gonna pay for it on the back end it's
almost like you're taking out a loan you
take out a loan and you get love and sex
and and it's great and it's fine i'm not
saying there's anything wrong with that
but you have to understand that there's
going to be a cost that you pay
at the end of that
and
and and look if you accept that cost
that's also fine
you can accept it but you could say yeah
this will cause me suffering and i'm
willing to go through it okay fine
there's nothing wrong with suffering
i like what you're saying which is
slightly different than most spiritual
gurus at least from the more eastern
tradition where they repudiate
attachment wholeheartedly because
attachment will bring about some
suffering
practice practically yeah go ahead
for me well with attachment you
mentioned comes some happiness you get
attached to a dog there's like let's say
five units of happiness per day
okay then you know that there's a
loss function or a cost function there's
a cost at some point it's going to die
because of well there's impermanence
so there's a guaranteed future loss
but then if one is to optimize unless
you die first yeah that's the key
oh great great okay then
right and you also i like that you use
the
analogy of alone on one's house because
the way that most people that i've heard
that are not you express this whole
attachment issue is yes you should
reject it outright because at some point
it will lead to because of the principle
of impermanence let's say it would lead
to huge loss later however they don't
account for the at least momentary
happiness and then you can do an
expectation and say well it's a plus
it's in the same way that a risk
analysis company would say it's still a
plus if i send you a loan you're going
to pay back when i'm going to get more
interest well you can perform the same
analysis and then there's that
tennesseen quote i think it's
it's better to have loved and lost than
to have never loved
yeah i see that missing like there's a
nuance that's missing in so much of the
new age circle
with regard to attachment with regard to
with regard to guilt sorry not with
regard to guilt but with regard to free
will i don't need to express my thoughts
on that so
how about i ask you about thomas
campbell
sure yeah so what are your views on top
where do you disagree with thomas
campbell
large we agree on a lot of stuff
um
maybe 80 of stuff we we might agree on
so for the most part i'm going to be
splitting hairs here on technical stuff
but um that's me that's me in a nutshell
but first let me say where we agree i
mean he basically i think says that
everything is mind or everything is
consciousness
so we're totally in agreement on that
toe to leave yeah
yeah and then um
he's he talks about love and he says
that love is fundamental to the
structure of how the universe works
and i would agree with him on that
um you know love as being opposed to
fear and how you know the universe is
trying to maximize love and so forth
basically we agree on that and that the
purpose of life is to love more to
become more loving to expand your
consciousness we agree on that
um
he talks about a lot of like astral
travel type of stuff
um
and his explorations of that i
personally haven't had much of that
experience myself uh
i don't dispute that what he says is how
he's experienced it and and my model
basically is able to accommodate that so
that's fine uh people can do astral
travel to me it's just like dreaming and
so forth yeah you can do that
and explore different different dreams
different realms okay fine it's just all
imagination anyways
it's all consciousness and then um
where we would disagree is that
is his physical stuff so i would say
he's still not fully god realized uh
because he doesn't he wouldn't tell you
that you're literally god i don't think
um he would say that you're something
less than god he would say you're an
individuated unit of consciousness he
says that i see you
um
great memory man
yeah and and so i would say
um yeah at a certain level
you are an icu an individual union of
consciousness but if you reach the
highest levels of infinity
which i don't think he's reached i think
that's the problem is that he's kind of
stuck in the astral realms
he's he's ver i consider him a very high
consciousness person he has amazing
advice to give you just to most to most
people he can give you amazing advice on
how to improve your life and how to
expand your consciousness
but he has not reached
absolute infinity
and the reason that i can say that is
because his notion of
of physics
is still somewhat almost materialistic i
mean he talks about like it's a virtual
reality
um first of all a lot of people
misunderstand what he means by virtual
so a lot of materialists will latch onto
that and say ah so he's saying we're in
a computer simulation that's not what
he's saying though he's using the the
word virtual rather poetically and sort
of metaphorically not literally in the
sort of computer lingo sense
so reality's not really happening in a
computer and reality is also not a
simulation i think that would be our
biggest disagreement he says it's a
simulation
and he also says it's a finite
simulation he says reality is finite and
it's definitely not finite it's infinite
and um
he also says that time is fundamental
and time is definitely not sorry what
were you saying you're saying that your
disagreement is that he would classify
life or reality as finite
yeah he would say reality is a finite
simulation i would disagree with that
he says that um
[Music]
i don't know if he believes that reality
has like a lower limit and like it's
quantized can you refresh my memory does
he say that it's quantized and that
there's a bottom level like a plank
length or something yeah right so i
would i would disagree with it but yeah
yeah so i would disagree there's no
fundamental unit to reality basically it
goes on forever
up up and down in all dimensions so you
can zoom into reality forever so that's
that's actually a very important thing
to realize because without that you're
not realizing the scope of what reality
is
and um
and then what is what else does he say
hmm
oh he says time is fundamental yeah and
time is time is imaginary and you can
actually
have a reality without time
um
you can you can realize eternity and you
can realize that time is actually
something conscious is constructing you
can deconstruct time
you can also deconstruct space too
but he's still he's still a great
teacher and i i've in fact learned from
him so what have you learned i'm
grateful i'm grateful for his work
um
actually when i started out his his book
you know what is his book called
yeah his book was
it's so funny you talk about materialism
and atheism
when i read that book
i was still like an atheist materialist
and i was into pickup and stuff i
actually learned that book from the
learned about that book from the pickup
community
on a forum somebody just in some random
offshoot forum an unrelated section of
the forum somebody posted that book like
in the philosophy section so i was
interested in philosophy so i
i scooped up that book and the person
there wrote something like you know this
book is very radical and it'll change
your whole understanding of reality i'm
like oh cool
so i pick up this book and i read the
first 10 pages of it and in the very
beginning he starts talking about his
astral travels and i thought it was so
[ __ ] ludicrous what he was talking
about that i put the book down in
frustration and i just
left it on my bookshelf for for like
four or five years
i thought it was [ __ ] stupid waste of
time
um
then later
once i
you know
did more of the spiritual work then i
came back to the book and i read read
most of it
and uh so
from him i learned i learned about like
for example dreaming
he i remember
i listened to one of his talks about
dreaming and he had a profound insight
about how you can use dreaming
as a way to
learn about your sort of trauma and
other psychic baggage for example if you
have a recurrent dream that you keep
having where you're fearful like for
example maybe you have a dream where you
are like what i had is uh
after college
it took i almost had ptsd after college
because
i was studying so hard for all the tests
and exams to be a good student
that um like i would have nightmares
about missing tests or failing classes
and those nightmares would would
continue years after i was out of
college and i wasn't even studying
anything anymore
um
and uh and so basically and i would have
those like consistently like every week
i would have them
for years
and and so what thomas campbell
basically said was something along the
lines of
if you're having a recurrent nightmare
scenario like this or just a bad dream
you got to ask yourself after you come
out of that dream like
what is the lesson here for my
consciousness what do i need to learn
about myself to expand my sense of self
and consciousness so that i can
integrate this so that this dream
doesn't need to keep happening again
because this dream is a sort of an
unconscious message
that there's something i haven't sorted
out yet in my psyche and when i sort it
out the dream will stop
so
that's
one thing i learned from him well that's
psychoanalysis in a nutshell or at least
the beginning of the beginnings of it
like freud and jung so it's not yeah but
what's cool about is you don't need a
therapist you can kind of do it yourself
yeah
what are your views on bernardo castro
like why are you where you agree you
disagree with them yeah we agree on a
lot probably 90 percent of stuff we
would agree on
um
[Music]
he's got very good arguments against
materialism all of which are basically
correct i would say
he does a brilliant job of kind of
dissecting and cutting it apart better
than i do um sometimes i kind of
struggle with with being very technical
about things but he's really good at
that
and um
where we would would disagree
is uh he i think he's still not first of
all
he's not infinitely conscious he hasn't
accessed infinity
um
i don't think he grasps the the
significance of his own ideas he's
intuiting it he understands
that he's kind of
moving in a very profound direction but
he actually he hasn't fully actualized
that
and so he's not actually conscious that
he's god imagining all other beings so
he still thinks that there are
you know you ask them a question about
like solipsism
and you ask them a question about
uh
are you a solipsist that he says very
confidently kind of like no as though
solipsism is like a bad bad thing in his
mind
i get the sense that he's kind of a
verse to solipsism
do you disagree do you disagree or
no yeah for whatever for no from what i
remember he said he's not a solipsist
and he was very kind of flippant about
it
um so his model is basically there's a
dissociative boundary between his
consciousness and other consciousnesses
that's right
um so what i would just say is that of
course that dissociative boundary itself
is imaginary and that if he goes deeper
in his conscious work eventually he'll
realize that he imagines all
uh all dissociative boundaries and all
other agents behind those boundaries
that he assumes are there they're all
imaginary
and they will all collapse
and then he'll realize he's god
dreaming the whole thing up
what would you say to some people who
say if you zoom in enough to an atom you
would get to another universe and if you
zoom out enough from ours where an atom
and someone else is
yeah that that's that's basically how it
works although what exactly you'll zoom
into or out to in terms of form you
could that'll be whatever you imagine it
to be in a certain sense um but yeah you
can you can zoom in forever
uh so
technically just to understand infinity
is that which can divide itself forever
so really what reality is is just
division it's self-division and every
division can divide itself again and
again and again in a fractal way
without any limit
so you can keep dividing consciousness
as much as you want it's just a question
of
how deep do you want to go for example
if consciousness wants to imagine that
consciousness ends at the plank plank
length
that will be its end
because that's what it's imagining the
end is but if conscious wants to go
deeper and probe deeper and real and it
realizes that the plank length is just a
conceptual fabrication it can go beyond
that forever
and yeah you can zoom out
forever as well
and what you'll find there who knows
have you heard of someone named frank
yang
yes
okay i don't know
anything besides how frank yang looks
but what are your thoughts on whether or
where you agree with frank yang and
where you disagree i actually don't know
that much about his whole um world view
and so forth
so
it's a little difficult to comment um he
i know that he has criticisms of me
um
in that he he has this idea of
he's critical of psychedelic basically
his point is that
uh psychedelics don't produce a genuine
awakening or enlightenment
and that
through meditation you can reach a
deeper level of enlightenment the true
enlightenment is this the meditative one
and that he would say that that is all
beyond the psychedelic stuff
and that it transcends all of it and
basically he's sort of talking about the
buddhist notion of cessation
cessation is a
meditative
attainment or achievement you could say
um
for lack of any better word it's
basically it's it's sort of the pinnacle
of what a buddhist meditator would seek
to attain which is you reach
a
mental stillness you you silence your
mind and your consciousness so much
that literally the entire universe
ceases it pops out of existence so to
speak and you're left with just
absolutely nothing it's like a total
blank it's a blank that's blanker than
blank you might say
this
this would be called cessation in
buddhism and then they would say that
that is sort of the ultimate thing that
the buddha taught and the ultimate the
true enlightenment so to speak
and that everything and that everything
else is just a distraction or uh not
the ultimate
that's what i think that that would be
his position
and um i'm curious what the process
looks like of going from this state of
inoperative
nullness
to now where precisely does some of the
perceptions come back if there's
absolutely nothing does it come back in
the center does it come back there does
it come back everywhere
little by little atom by atom i'm
curious about how that looks
uh i
yeah i would assume it would pop back in
rather suddenly
not adam not adam by adam yeah
it it is the way that it's been
described from things that i've read is
that it's it's a it's a rather um abrupt
shift it's almost like imagine you're
sitting here and the entire universe
collapses and then reboots
from scratch
sort of like that like it's it's a very
very very radical mm-hmm like we're
starting a computer the screen goes yeah
yeah you're basically rebooting the
entire universe that's interesting
yeah or maybe you could you could almost
think of it like a glitch
like imagine like a glitch in your
consciousness
where you just like you you you're in
the universe and then you pop out of the
universe and then you pop right back
into it
and since you were since that place that
you popped out into you know the
nothingness zone since there's nothing
there there's no time there
it lasts for an eternity so imagine that
you pop out of your present experience
for an eternity into nothingness and
then you pop right back in and all of
that took just like a fraction of a
second
in real time in our human time but in
you know
in the cessation time it it lasted for
an eternity
so it's a very sort of
very mind-melting idea
yeah because you have a temporal
juxtaposed with temporal and they are
not supposed to have a relationship
between yet they're related in some
manner right right
so what i uh continue
yeah so what i would say about cessation
is that
um
i mean
what i talk about doesn't really
contradict cessation
to me cessation is just one thing that
consciousness can do it can cease it can
sort of be totally formless
and that's fine it can do that but
there's nothing i give no special
privilege to that over any other state
of consciousness so to me all states of
consciousness are basically equal and
there's nothing but states of
consciousness and to me cessation is
just another
thing that consciousness does
no more special than any other thing and
that nothingness it's very important to
understand that it's not that the
universe came from nothing
that's not what i'm saying
there's an even more radical
understanding to be had here it's that
the universe is nothing and always was
nothing and it's nothing right now
this
everything you're seeing all qualia are
actually nothing because you cannot
distinguish something from nothing
and that is the ultimate non-duality
yeah
because if you're still distinguishing
and privileging nothing over something
formlessness over form you actually
haven't fully integrated so usually in
the classic awakening path what usually
happens that first you realize no self
then you realize that the self is
absolutely formless and you sort of get
attached to that formlessness then you
realize that form is also nothing
and then you reintegrate the
formlessness into the form and then you
are in such a state of non-duality
you're so awake that um
you don't need to be in a state of
cessation in order to be conscious of
the absolute the absolute is literally
everything
at all times
no matter what state you're in
all states are the absolute but not all
states are aware
of themselves as being the absolute
have you seen there's the simpsons
episode where
bart
he needed a babysitter and then someone
was called and then she and then there's
a big someone who babysitted her bart
and she's just rocking on its hair she's
like bart put it down put it down bart
she's like traumatized that she's saying
this to console herself but almost like
she can't help it do you remember that
that's a really old one yeah
there's something that i sense in the
non-duelist community
a similar pattern noster where they'll
say
it's all one it's all infinity
everything and nothing are the same it's
all infinity it's all one almost
mindlessly like in an attempt to
it seems like in an
in an attempt to console and convince
themselves of something that they've
felt so sincerely at one point
but no longer do because they're in this
world supposedly rather than this other
world of
of bliss and their current life is so
desperate and so hard and they're
seeking to get back to that place of
comfort
and the only model they had in that
place was that
that of infinite unity
so they keep professing
and trying to get back to this place of
inner peace trying to find
they're trying to get to this
place of inner peace
associated with saying that all is
infinity all is unity all is nothing at
the same time infinity and zero are the
same
rather than trying to get to the truth
wherever the truth leads them even if
the truth leads them to non-unity or
materialism or pluralism do you sense
it's like a dogmatism in the non-dualist
community about non-dualism
i don't get that from
advanced non-dual masters
who i would consider advanced
but certainly those kind of wannabe
folks who are who are maybe students
and are early on the path
um
it's certainly very easy to [ __ ]
yourself with ideas about non-duality
and all those ideas are not nonduality
all ideas about infinity are not
infinity so you can easily
fool yourself with with ideas that you
you might even fool yourself that you've
awoken
when you actually haven't
you can fool yourself to think that
you've awoken to the highest level when
you actually are at a shallow level of
awakening just that's just because
awakening is so is so tricky because you
have a little bit of awakening and then
you kind of even a little bit of
awakening is so awesome and radical that
you say like well [ __ ] this is amazing
surely there can't be anything beyond
this and then then later you'll realize
there's something beyond it
um
[Music]
so i i think that
though of course those traps exist
and you have to be very careful about
not conceptualizing this stuff and
turning it into an ideology
i don't see that in you necessarily but
i see that in many people i won't name
names but i sense a fakeness about some
of them i don't want to use the word
dogmatism about their non-duality
because i don't like to use the word
dogmatism lightly
and i almost feel like people use the
word dogmatism when they're trying to
say that your ideas are false and you're
just too attached to them but i sense a
defensiveness about their spiritual
beliefs and what they perceive to be
these recalcitrant scientists who have
this emphasis on models and language and
they have compassion to virtually
everyone except them
i see this a bit with thomas campbell
too
well i mean i'm a little guilty of that
myself in terms of like lack of
compassion towards uh very dense
scientists
like you know
everyone except
like richard dawkins type of person like
yeah so so you can turn science into
your shadow
like yeah you can turn richard dawkins
or daniel dennett into your shadow and
and i've been guilty of that in the past
to some degree you know i have bad mouth
sam harris at times um when i could have
been more compassionate because
ultimately what you learn is that
everything is happening everything you
don't like about reality is happening
out of ignorance so those people who are
doing something you don't like they're
doing it out of ignorance that means
they don't know any better
so they're like a little child that
doesn't know any better
and so the more conscious you become the
more you realize that so anybody who has
some sort of ideology or a scientist or
a philosopher or an academic or a
religious fanatic
they're only doing it because they're
stuck in their paradigm and they don't
see a way out and so can you really
blame them for that i mean if they knew
better if they were more conscious then
they would
act better
but you can't you can't really blame
richard dawkins for being richard
dawkins he is that way he's never going
to change
and uh and you just gotta accept that
he's stuck there
and and honestly awakening is not for
most people
because it's so extremely radical
uh most people are not willing to handle
god realization and this goes back to
your earlier question about attachment
do i think that it's appropriate to tell
everybody to drop their attachments not
at all
because
the majority of people
are
are not meant to awaken and they will
never awaken no matter how well you
teach them
so you should not try to shove awakening
down their throat
and
and therefore they will always have
attachments so they need to be taught
how to live with their attachments in a
responsible way
not too attached
um but also you shouldn't tell them to
remove all attachments because
it's just not practical
and also even if you're awake you're
gonna have attachments
like literally you can't survive for
more than three days without attachment
to water
you're gonna have to drink water
so survival necessitates certain
attachments
it's just it's more about it's more
about a nuanced sort of view of like
don't worry so much about letting go of
the most
healthy attachments you have like you
don't need to worry about maybe letting
go of your wife or your need for food or
water or a house
but you can certainly let go of a lot of
stupid attachments you have
especially in the i in the realm of
ideas ideologies beliefs you can let go
a lot of those you can let go of
political beliefs you can let go of
religious dogma scientific dogmas
you can let go of other like even your
emotional attachments to needing to
hurt somebody or to get back at them
or to defend yourself against an attack
or to
um
[Music]
to experience a lot of pleasure you can
let go some of those
and your life will
be better probably as a result
what i notice and i don't know what to
call this community i don't even know if
it's a community but the non-dualist
community new age spiritual guru types
are not even gurus forget about that
let's say the followers of the gurus
what i noticed in them
there's quite a bit that i notice in
them that perhaps
my aversion
to
some of
well
what i notice in them is
there is an affectivity about their
happiness
and i don't know if you sense it but
i'm i'm fairly certain you sense it and
others sense it too where they seem
compelled to chuckle and to smile at
everything i think sad guru has a bit of
this quality and maybe to demonstrate
because to not to be mad or to be
to not
find humor in every little bit every
little challenge would be to demonstrate
that they're
incongruous and false
and
i see it as similar to putting on this
persona that the self-development
community has you know the
self-development many people
when they record videos they're like
all right guys let's do and they sm and
they smile no one smiles like that when
they're speaking they're like yeah all
right guys and let's go
and then they change they cut the
standard youtuber does that like they're
adopting someone else and it's
pickup gurus have this feigning of
masculinity and they change their voice
and they have
they display their intemperance with
cars and so on they express command
all right guys this is this is how you
dominate and they've put on this
feigning and i also sense that in that's
like
i sense that in some of the non-dualist
community followers let's say and i'm
i'm just curious if you sense it too
like for example i don't really see that
with saad guru with sagar i see i see
him just being playful and kind of
i mean the dude is so conscious what has
he got to be mad about
i think he's just being playful and
that's just his personality i see him as
being pretty authentic
um
i think most of the highest quality
non-dual teachers from for most part i
find them to be extremely authentic in
fact i find them to be the most
authentic humans and there's a good
reason for that is because the only way
you can be authentic is by discovering
truth
because that's what you authentically
are everything else is a construction
uh you know much of your character is
just a construction
um
but
uh i i think if you're sort of
conflating non-duality with also
a lot of the new age community and also
youtubers
and such and self-help
then then yeah you can in the new age
and stuff you can probably put you can
find people who are like overly
lovey-dovey types everything is like
super positive and optimistic like um
who's that guy um
ralph waters have you seen this guy
infinite waters never heard
yeah he would probably be the best
example of what you're talking about
like this sort of like hey guys it's all
peace and love like he literally starts
his videos like that
and you know i wonder how authentic that
is to him maybe he is that i don't know
maybe he is that way or maybe he's
putting on a bit of an act i mean
honestly
when i do my youtube videos i put on an
act too i almost treat it as though i'm
like a
an actor on a stage so i over dramatize
some stuff and you know to make it a
little exciting because otherwise it
would just be boring as [ __ ] can you
give me that example one example well a
lot of times i'm i'm sort of in this
imaginary debate with like with almost
like an idiot in my audience so it's
like but leo i thought you said this and
then so you know i almost had this
conversation with myself i kind of i do
it tonight and cheek
um
and um it's almost a bit of a problem
because it makes my audience
feel like i'm talking down to them
um
uh and so i could give them more credit
like you you actually do a good job of
sort of assuming that your audience is
very intelligent and
can handle the technical stuff
um
i don't see that sometimes
i think sometimes i assume the opposite
a lot of times i assume my audience is
just like stupid as a doorknob
no but well i i think you're being a bit
harsh on yourself and i see i see when
you do that when you give these debates
do you do these debates aloud between
different personalities at least i
haven't seen you say that this is what
you're likely thinking
or even when you say that maybe i'm not
thinking you're talking about me i'm
thinking you're talking about someone
else because i've listened to so many of
these that is the intention like when i
say hey you know but leo whatever blah
blah blah
i'm sort of intending in my mind it's
not that i'm talking to you
it's that i'm talking to one of the
trolls in the comments section it's
almost like that
yeah
and then and i'm trying to make it kind
of funny like um i will try i will try
to sometimes like actually think of like
a really ridiculous sounding objection
and frame it in a really ridiculous way
just so that it
it's funny um but in a certain sense
it's not the best because it would be it
would be better if i like really steel
man some of my objections um and not not
like ridicule them but i also try to be
humorous
so
speaking of giving the audience a bit
more credit and i was talking to you
earlier about being more precise and
when i'm being persnickety it's not just
because i'm trying to
pick apart it's
it's because i think that the truth can
be found when you
are as precise as you possibly can be
and you take in an hour some people say
you're taking that analogy too far but i
don't think there's such a thing as
taking an
analogy too far i think there's
something like elongating an analogy and
mutilating it because you've
pushed it past this domain of
applicability but in that it's not
taking it too far you're actually
demonstrating the limits of what you're
analogizing and you gain some more
insight
so speaking about that as well as
speaking about treating the audience
well
i think that they're so i think there's
so many your audience and
the audience people who are listening to
this are so much more bright than
traditional media has given them credit
for
like the neil degrasse tyson would say
this is what gravity is you take it's
like a sheet it's like a mattress you
put a bowling ball and then you're
wondering like the average audience
member is thinking first to think oh
okay i understand it then second they're
like well you're using gravity to
explain gravity because the way that the
marble falls is because of gravity
now because i i've always had that
problem with that visualization
let me read to you something leo about
this whole
about being specific because raymond
smalling who's a mathematician one of
a mathematician that
i look up to so much him and douglas
hofstede are the people that i would
interview except raymond smallian is no
no longer with us
but
raymond smalian had this great
conversation between a mortal between a
man
essentially and god and it's about free
will and it's such a brilliant
conversation it's so fun it's so
it's so clever
that
i may well i may just spend an hour at
some point on another video just reading
this conversation from my audience but i
want to read it to you because you say
when you've gotten to some state you
feel an identity with god
and raymond smalian would say would
agree with so much of what you have to
say but would say that look it's not so
you feeling identical to god is not the
same as being god because there are
other possibilities so let me give you
let me read this for you
sure so the mortal says oh come on now
if i'm only talking to myself then how
can i be talking to you god
god says
i'm just in the middle of the story just
so you know he says god says your use of
the word only is quite misleading i can
suggest several logical possibilities
under which
you talking to yourself does not imply
that you're talking to me
okay the mortal says suggest just one
god says well obviously one such
possibility is that you and i are
identical sorry the mortal says that's
such a blasphemous thought luckily i
didn't utter it you uttered it god god
says okay according to some religions
yes that's blasphemous according to
others it's plain it's simple it's
immediate it's the perceived truth
the mortal says
so the only way out of my dilemma is to
believe that you and i are identical god
says not at all that's only one way out
there are several others for example it
may be that you are a part of me in
which case
you may be talking to that part of me
which is you or i may be part of you in
which case you may be talking to the
part of you which is in me or again you
and i might partially overlap in which
case you may be talking to the
intersection and hence talking to both
you and me the only way you're talking
to yourself might seem to imply that you
are not talking to me is if you and i
were totally disjoint and even then you
could conceivably be talking to both of
us anyway it's a clever you can see this
was written by a mathematician just on
the word usage it's such a fun it goes
on for an hour it's a conversation
between a man who in the beginning says
to god please god take away my free will
because it's such an
up it's such a huge burden and god is
like well i can take away your free will
but then once you commit horrible acts
and then the important the man is like
shoot okay yes well
okay but i won't have i won't feel my
free will and so i won't be responsible
for it and then god's like well won't
you be responsible now for what you do
then because you take it's such a fun
dialogue man
yeah it sounds like he's sort of
exploring all the paradoxes of uh of
what god is and there and i mean
when the finite mind tries to wrap
itself around the infinite it's
absolutely impossible for that to happen
so paradoxes
are the result of that
um that's what all paradox basically
boils down to um
what i would say is yeah i mean as great
and as fun as interesting and even
important as it is to consider all those
possibilities and it's always important
to consider how you might be wrong about
something
but
when you reach infinite consciousness
every single distinction that that
mathematician made in his arguments and
in his logic they will all collapse and
finally the distinction will collapse
between self and other and the last
thing you will realize is that you are
absolutely god and that there is no
other but you
and it's really interesting you know
because you might think like oh well
that's just what leo that's just like
how leo wants it to be because you know
he's a narcissist or something
but actually the way that it happens in
in practice when it really happens to
you there's a really interesting
psychological sort of dynamic is that
when it's when
you become conscious of god first of all
you become conscious of it at least this
is how it happened for me you become
conscious of it as other than you
so when i first became conscious of god
the first thing i realized is that holy
[ __ ] god exists
and i was wrong that was my first
realization
at that time i did not identify with god
that just to realize that god exists
this was absolutely mind-blowing it's a
complete like your whole life will never
be the same after that point
not as a belief
but
more real than
uh anything else that you consider real
in your life
so that happens and then it took me a
lot more awakenings to
finally realize that holy [ __ ] it's not
just that
god exists
it's that
what is god see first you you find god
then you start to wonder but what is god
you still don't understand it then you
go you probe deeper and you realize
[ __ ]
of course it's all one if it's all one
that means
i am god
i've been separated i've separated
myself from what i am because i feared
what i am because i was attached to a
finite identity of
a finite idea of myself
and so then you realize that but that's
still not where it ends then it goes
even deeper you realize god even deeper
what you are even deeper because you
still don't really understand what it is
you question deeper you have further
awakenings into what is really gone what
am i really
and then you realize that god is
infinite love and when you realize that
then you don't feel you don't feel
worthy you don't feel worthy to to to
accept yourself as that because it's too
good it's literally so good it's
impossible for it to be so good and your
your ego cannot cannot accept it i mean
i'm a i'm a rather arrogant and prideful
person but even when i realize that it's
too good to just latch on to it with
your ego
it it it humbles you
it humbles you so deeply that you say
uh you actually you almost do enter and
i did sort of enter into a conversation
with god sort of like in that dialogue
where it's like
you see god and you say oh my god you're
you're so beautiful you're infinite love
you're infinite everything
you created me
and
you're penetrating into the heart of
what god is and and and then as that's
happening you're being showered god is
sort of like radiating love upon you
literally like um
it's almost like coming closer to the
sun the sun just radiates you with its
heat
uh
and you don't feel worthy to be in the
presence of the sun
and
you just feel so humbled like i mean
you're in tears you're bawling
in tears you're writhing in ecstasy on
the floor
this is like a profound life-changing
experience as this is happening to you
uh and
and what what brings you to tears is to
realize how selfless god is how
beautiful how good la god is
but
but the final thing that kills you
is
because see there's still a duality
there because you're treating it as
separate from you it's like oh my god
it's amazing i'm not worthy of it and
then
and you're like god how can you be so
good
and then
the final coup de gras that god
bestows upon you is that god says
here
i'm you
i'm giving it all to you
you see so it's not that i'm above you
and that you're some part of me and that
i'm infinitely good and you're just a
little little human down there on the
earth and you you're trying to you know
uh pray to me and all this
it's not like that
the final gift the ultimate thing god
wants for everybody is only one thing
which is to realize that you're god
you're not a part of god you're not
a little figment of god
you're
god
and it's when you get that that it kills
you like literally what you experience
when if if you are
if you are willing to actually surrender
your ego
and here you require complete
self-surrender because the only way you
can accept the gift of infinite
selflessness and love is to completely
annihilate any attachment to any
physical identity you ever thought you
had when you are completely willing to
let go of absolutely everything the
final gift that is given to you is that
you simply become god and at that point
you're just dead
and you just are a pure singularity of
love
and at that point you realize
why everything exists and why it must
exist and why it can't be anything other
than what it is because if you think
about it just think about it if you had
the ability the power to create
absolutely anything
what would you create
and the answer is so simple you would
create nothing but infinite love you
would radiate infinite love forever
showering it upon every possible being
that you could imagine
this is the only worthy thing for an
infinite intellect to do and god is pure
formless infinite intellect
it is an intelligence that figured out
how to create itself and to radiate love
to the maximum number of possible beings
that could ever be
conceived of
and that's what god is it's an infinite
radiation of love forever
with no end and no beginning
and when you get that
you're done you've answered every
possible question that you could have
about yourself and
the universe
and it doesn't matter to you what the
details are science doesn't matter to
you math doesn't matter to you
non-duality doesn't matter to you you're
just love you're just pure love
imagine what what the universe was
before the big bang
right it feels kind of like that it's
like you become that
but not in a neutral way it's it's love
i'm so i'm wondering and i wonder this
i'm sure you've wondered this too
this quest that i have for a toe
i imagine it it's much more of a journey
than it is a goal and the reason is
because i don't want it to be a goal
imagine if i did get the theory of
everything what would i have left to do
would there be fun would there be
excitement
now you're saying you would just
dissolve in the pool of love
yeah well i'm saying that's why i say
radical too selfish i'm too selfish to
accept the toe
well you're yeah it's beyond a toe
because a toe is a theory and it's
beyond a theory but i know what you what
you mean um but yeah so what i'm saying
is so radical that if you
there's many degrees of this so it
depends how far you want to take it if
you take it to its penultima i mean not
penelope but just to the ultimate
if you take it to the ultimate
um
if you accept infinite love you're
actually going to destroy the entire
physical universe it's going to stop to
it's going to cease to exist
right okay let me get let me get
something straight here
for the audience as well as myself when
you say the universe will cease to exist
you are meaning your
from your perspective but somehow your
perspective is also correct
no at that point it's so absolute that
you realize that there are no other
perspectives but your own because you're
imagining all perspectives and so all
you will you will basically
destroy the universe for everything for
everybody
you'll take everything with you
you'll become absolutely nothing forever
and
this has never happened before then
what has never happened
that someone or something has realized
this infinite truth and destroyed well
no
well that's where it gets tricky
it can only happen to you
there's not anybody else to whom it
could happen but to you
yeah okay and then what happens from
other people's perspectives
they don't exist
so no one else's perspective exists
in the ultimate sense yes
help me understand this you understand
where i'm getting it
it's extremely apparent it's extremely
paradoxical because it's not that they
don't exist per se
um it it's much more radical than solid
so some people say that solipsism is
kind of ugly and uh
unpalatable and it's like oh you know i
don't like solipsism
or it's too crazy to be true you know
something like solacism is just too
wacky it shouldn't be true um
it's too radical and actually what i'm
saying is that solipsism is not radical
enough
to be true so
what actually happens is that it's not
just that you're alone in the universe
the reason you're alone is because
you're so together so look what happens
right now we're sitting here and you're
imagining that there's all these
different perspectives and people you me
dogs and cats and so forth
but as you become more conscious
all those divisions
they are merging towards each other look
like this they're coming together coming
closer together and closer together and
it's all a convergence imagine like a
cone like this
right it's an infinite cone it goes
infinitely far down but eventually it
all converges and moves upward and all
the divisions are dissolving
and
all
differences between perspectives are
dissolving until finally you reach the
top of the cone at the top of the cone
there's just you
because you've literally fused yourself
into every other thing so
it might uh you can interpret it as like
oh well that's kind of bleak because i'm
just by myself
but that's not quite the right way to
think about it the other way to
interpret is that the reason i'm by
myself is because i'm so together so
imagine if we took you and your wife and
we merged you together in love
so deeply that you weren't just having
intercourse with each other but you were
physically fusing your bodies and
consciousnesses and minds into each
other so completely that by the end of
that process there was no more
separation at all between
kurt and your wife and you were just
one
in love
forever
and you would never separate again you
would be in love forever eternally
but you and her no longer would exist
you would just be complete
undifferentiated oneness and now imagine
that that happens with every single
human and living being who could ever
exist ever in any possible multiverse
all of it merged absolutely into one you
not only merge with humans and cats and
dogs you you literally make physical
love to couches chairs tables
mathematics numbers science computers
simulations aliens psychedelics uh
rocks trees all of it merged into one
and you have
love
that is what love really means
let's imagine sam harris encountered
god
but he would just say well you're saying
god is ultimate reality something like
that
and he would just say yeah that's well i
encountered ultimate reality i agree i
wouldn't call it god i don't know why
you have to attach a religious
connotation to it so what do you say to
that like why are you using the term god
so uh there's a very specific
state of consciousness that you reach
that i call god realization it's a very
distinctive shift where you actually
realize that you're god
and um it's not just nothingness it's
not just emptiness it's not just a some
sort of like
object like a table or or or a chair
it's it's not a person and it's not like
an alien it's more like um
god is technically speaking is it is
self-creation
so what it means when i say that you are
god it is to realize that you are
literally imagining your own body and
hands into existence you're so conscious
that you know how you're doing it you're
so conscious that you you are literally
conscious of how you're constructing all
of reality
so what would you call a infinitely
conscious agent that is infinitely
intelligent
infinitely good infinitely powerful
infinitely loving
and self-created that means god
is so is so free of limitation and even
logical
uh constraint that it is able to create
itself out of nothing and it's
constantly creating itself and it's
endlessly creative it is creativity
itself what would you call that
you'd call it god
so the word god is the perfect word
that's what it is that's what you are
let's get to some of these audience
questions man
let's do it this has been so fun
good i'm glad
actually one of my notes here before i
get to them i have a note on i have a
note that says one one wouldn't have the
levels of spiral dynamics if one truly
believed in spiral dynamics and the
reason is because at the highest stage
of spiral dynamics is indigo and one
realizes there's no rank there's not one
position that's privileged over the
other and thus you can't say that
there's a development because to say
develop implies a direction even to say
incorporation
implies
that you privilege inclusiveness over
exclusiveness
and so to me the developers of spyro
spiral dynamics to even write it as a
hierarchy means they weren't at the
stage where hierarchies were meaningless
well certainly
certainly the developers of spiral
dynamics they themselves rated
themselves at like stage
blue
claire graves put himself at blue
not indigo there was no first of all
indigo is a is an idea from ken wilbur's
model so it's a little bit more advanced
um but but yeah it's just a model spot
name is just a model it's basically a
scientific model so it has all the
limits that scientific models tend to
have
and so
it it it only works in a sort of
relative pragmatic sense you shouldn't
attribute it as an absolute you
shouldn't think that these levels are
somehow baked into the actual fabric of
existence it's just uh it's just a handy
way of categorizing people in the same
way that like we can categorize
um you know animals according to like
reptiles
birds mammals etc but like i mean these
are not these are not absolute
categories that there are plenty of
animals that kind of have
features that are in between and we
could change how we categorize animals
we don't need the reptile category per
se
it's the principle of impermanence not
susceptible to impermanence
yeah so sometimes it's said that um
the only thing that's permanent is
impermanence yeah so why is that that
kind of paradox
how does that happen
why is that the case
how is it that you can say everything is
impermanent except this guy
it sort of depends on what perspective
you look at it from again it's
relativistic um i would say that that
principle mostly is applied at the sort
of more basic level of human life
um
if you're going to the very highest
absolute levels you might even just say
that everything is permanent
um
like permanent love or something whereas
if you're at the at the lower levels of
consciousness
um
just your experience of of life
it's almost like a scientific statement
i mean we're all scientifically speaking
we're always experiencing consciousness
as fluid and changing
it's never
stuck
as far as we know empirically speaking
right have you ever experienced a
permanent state of consciousness where
it's stuck forever
no right
and so and and really i don't know of
any human who has described such a state
otherwise how could they even talk about
it because they would be stuck in it you
basically have to freeze the whole
universe so it's almost like you could
think of it scientifically like the
whole universe is moving you could
almost say like the whole universe is
expanding just that right there the big
bang alone tells you that you can't have
permanence
what do you make of this argument from
chris langan
which
says that you have free will the reason
you have free will is because you are
god and god is ultimate reality there is
no limitation set on the universe except
from the universe because that's correct
so there is no
so the universe is self-determining
and there's no yeah it is definition of
free will then self-determination
so yeah the universe you inherit free
will
yeah god is
god is
god creates everything using infinite
will
um
and uh and
god could give you a a portion of its
will right so in the same way that you
have as a human you have a portion of
god's
intellect
you're actually using god's intellect
right now to make sense of the words i'm
saying your iq that's god's intellect
filtered down to a very low level
right so god has like an infinite iq you
could say a human has a portion of that
likewise you could say that you have a
portion of god's will but a very small
portion so you can for example
imagine some thought
and then go into the real world and try
to build that like you have an idea for
a
for a house you want to build and you
can go build that house
and that's how humans create stuff and
in fact part of the joy of being human
is creativity
and a lot of people miss out on this joy
like
you as an artist as a filmmaker and so
forth as a rapper and whatever like you
you understand and you probably get joy
out of being creative right
why does that give you joy because
inherently that is god's business
if god has no other business but to
create that that is the highest joy is
to be creative and to be sharing your
creative gifts with with others that's
what creativity is about and then as a
human you do it in a limited finite way
you know you don't have all the creative
capacities of god you can't literally
imagine a house into existence
so you have to first imagine it in your
mind it's a little faint image and then
you have to go and actually buy the
lumber at home depot and build the
[ __ ] thing
um
and so in that sense you have a little
bit of free will and you could
participate a little bit in the activity
of of being like god being a creator
being a little god
so see god is delegating its godhood to
all the little agents out there in the
world
and giving them a little bit of a taste
of what it's like to be god and then if
you like that you can
do more of that
and that's why people become artists and
creatives
and those people are usually more
spiritual too
in the same way that
you say that god is in the business of
creation can one also say by duality god
is in the business of destruction
yeah i'm in creation in an absolute
sense um but yeah yeah destruction is a
part of creation because you can't have
creation without destruction
so in the same way like why is it that
when you talked about
why is it that when you said it you said
the word creation now imagine it's
cultural well one could say it's
cultural we think of creation as a
positive and so if i want to attribute
positive qualities to god i'm going to
prioritize creation but i equally could
have said destruction now is that the
case or no
could you equally have sudden
destruction
again it is very relativistic it depends
on how you define these terms in your
mind the way i define these terms in my
mind is that i have a lowercase c
creation and a lowercase c destruct a
lowercase d destruction and then i have
an uppercase
c absolute creation which encompasses
both of those ah
um i don't do that with the word
destruction
um and the reason is is because um
i don't know it just kind of feels
intuitively wrong to do that i mean i
you probably could do that
nothing is stopping you you can
formulate your worldview or models of
god however you want no one's going to
stop you
um but
it just like
it feels more intuitive to me to think
of god as creator rather than destructor
although of course
you you have destruction is is a part of
creation
but like for example look if you're an
artist let's put it like this let's say
you're an artist do you consider
yourself a creator or a destroyer
for some reason you call yourself a
creator
like you're a youtube creator not a
youtube destroyer
right even though you might destroy some
of your old youtube videos you don't
like but you don't think of yourself
that that's not sort of your purpose
that's not like why you're
the destruction is is serving the
creation you're not making destruction
the point
so in that same way death serves life
but life doesn't serve death death's
point is to serve life
but life's point isn't to serve death is
that a correct statement
yeah you could put it that way i mean
there's no absolute correct statement as
far as things like this go it's like it
depends on how you want to frame it
it's relativistic
you have a video which i didn't take a
look at about good intentions and why
everyone acts with good intentions now i
don't believe that and i haven't watched
your video so i don't know the exact
line of argumentation i imagine it goes
like this everyone has a world view
everyone has a model everyone is aiming
with respect to that model so even if
they're killing someone they believe in
that moment killing is the best thing to
do and because they're aiming at what's
best they have good intentions is that
something
along the lines of you yeah but it's
more it's more it's more radical than
that what i'm saying is that literally
everything every action that happens in
the universe is good it's not just from
good intention but it actually literally
is good so even when a terrorist blows
up civilians
um which like happened today in
afghanistan in the latest news there was
a suicide bombing in the airport in
afghanistan so see first of all what
needs to be understood is that that
person who did that explosion thought he
was doing good
in his own mind
but never mind that you could say well
he was just deluded he you know he he
was indoctrinated in some sort of
terrorist cult and therefore they
brainwashed him okay fine
but that's not what i'm saying what i'm
saying is that he was literally doing
good in the sense that
the only thing that happens in the
universe is good
but the good is always filtered through
some sort of finite form or ego mind
when we're talking about humans for
example
so when a human behaves the human is
always behaving
as what is good from his state of
consciousness so it really depends on
what your state of conscience is the
lower your state of consciousness the
more twisted your idea of good is
the higher state of consciousness the
more pure and less corrupted more
selfless your idea of good is
so for example like hitler
hitler
did the holocaust
and most people would say well that's
bad obviously
um
well that's bad from
one point of view
but from god's point of view it wasn't
bad
because
um
if you actually take a look at what
hitler was doing what he was doing is
from his point of view from his
perspective he was doing what he thought
was the greatest good for his people and
given his identity when you're
identified as being an aryan german
not a jew then from that point of view
you start to see jews as something
sub-human and
something that needs to be purged from
reality
and so it's good from that point of view
to destroy that which you consider
bad
you see so hitler was destroying bad
from his point of view which is good
from his point of view so he was acting
from the intention to destroy evil which
of course because he was corrupted his
mind was corrupted and very finite
turned out to itself actually be a
source of evil
and that's how all evil is created most
of the evil in the world is created by
attempts of limited ego minds to destroy
evil have you noticed this
i would say that that's a naive point of
view but i'm saying that and i'm not as
wise as you so that means that you can
correct me so let me no it means
let me give you my justification yeah
sure
i see
i don't think that everyone is aimed at
what's good i don't think that
people do
only what's aiming at what they think is
love only aiming at what they think is
good i think they do what they do often
to spite love and even though they have
enough strength to do otherwise they
knowingly go against it i see this in
myself at times
and
there's even quotes many quotes from
dostoyevsky about this there's a great
one from moby dick from hell's
heart i stab at the
for hate's sake i spit my last breath at
thee
yeah well hate is just a twisted form of
love the reason you hate something ask
yourself this why do you hate anything
in reality
what's the point
because there's an evil part of you
that's against good
there's something deeper you need to
realize the reason the only reason you
hate anything is because you love
something else instead
yeah so like for example
for example the reason why did this i
mean this is we can actually like
empirically sort of look at this why did
hitler hate the jews
because he loved the german people so
much
his idea and love for germany
the purity of germany
he was so in love with being german and
that whole identity
that therefore he hated
jews
because he saw them as an impurity onto
the goodness he was trying to protect
but his notion of goodness was very
finite
it sounds to me like what you're saying
boils down to you're aimed at something
and that's it
like look what you're saying if you're
saying
he
you don't like you hate something
because you love something else that's
essentially saying you're aimed at
something else
so at least you're aimed at something
well well the hatred is helping you to
get the love
you see the only reason you hate is
because you weren't given enough love if
you were given more love
the people who are the most hateful
people in the world that you can
demonstrate this
just within psychology you know clinical
psychology the people who are the most
hateful
are the people who receive the least
love or some sort of twisted form of
love from their parents
if your mother didn't love you and your
father beated you
then you're going to grow up to be a
hateful person and all of that is just a
coping mechanism to get the love that
you were denied see if you're denied
love you're going to want to deny love
to others because you have nothing else
to live for the only joy you will get in
life is to deny love to others because
it was denied to you
so if i take that back
then at some point god denied himself
love
because why is that
if if i'm saying if i'm evil because my
parents deny me love then why did they
deny me love because they were denied
love and you just keep going back and
back
what was denied love initially
while there was only god initially which
it itself is synonymized with god i mean
sorry with love
right so so we could say originally
there was
infinite love
and then in order to
share itself with others it had to it
had to divide itself
and so that division of infinite love is
you might say the original
form of evil
because when something infinite has to
take on finite form it automatically
becomes less than
everything
and so as soon as god started to
partition itself
that is what led to what we would call
evil
then it is evil though
if if you think of it that way you can i
mean it depends on how you define what
evil is
if you just say that evil is just
partition or division then yeah you
could say that
but that becomes very different from
what we normally mean by evil
because people attach moral judgment to
evil
right so in this case you have to remove
all moral judgment
well i imagine so the reason you're
removing the moral judgment is also
because
there's no free will in this
model it's just cause and effect there
was a bit of yeah that got passed down
yeah
so then in that same way when someone
says hey they're just doing the best
that they could then because there's no
free will you can also say they're doing
the worst that they could
you can only do one thing
so it's like a set just one point
so that one point is its greatest point
so the grid
but it's okay
i understand what you're saying
you could say that but the problem is
that there's no such thing as worst
and there's no such thing as bad and
there's no such thing as evil at all
because the only thing that exists is
absolute perfection so everything is
absolute perfection including all the
divisions so you're still suddenly
judging the divisions as something
that's bad that shouldn't have happened
but the way that infinity or love works
is that infinity must include all
possible finitudes so
the lack of the total unity must include
all possible divisions within itself so
so the way that god resolves the evil
problem is that god just simply absorbs
all of the evil into itself
until nothing until no evil remains let
me explain it a bit differently let's
imagine you have a spectrum and then
plus one is like good and then zero or
sorry minus one is like
evil
so plus one is good minus one is equal
the closer you are to plus one the more
good you are
okay so the closer you are to minus one
the less good you the less good you are
the more evil you are okay right and and
then what happens if we keep compressing
this because there is no free will you
can't choose between these so you get
down to just zero which means that
you're simultaneously doing your best
and you're simultaneously doing your
worst
yeah and that's called absolute love
absolute good that's what absolute
perfection and goodness is and actually
you don't need to compress them you can
take this and turn it into a loop right
it's going to loop around and they're
going to touch and you're gonna have a
perfect loop of infinite love and unity
and oneness and absolute good
so absolute good includes hitler
yeah okay see okay let me let me let me
let me play around it's it's extremely
radical it's it it's also tautological
so there's no way there's nothing you
can say that will break it
but you can try it feel feel free i'm
not gonna break it off have fun with it
right the video is titled something like
why everyone has good intentions i don't
know the exact video but then when i
said you're also passing down evil in
about two or three minutes ago when we
spoke we're speaking about it you said
well i mean evil has some connotations
so i don't know if i would attach that
word to it because this isn't precise
well i could say the same about good and
how you just described good it has
connotations so should you use the word
good intentions if you're not willing to
use the word worst intentions or bad
intentions or evil intentions why are
you willing to use the word good
intentions when good in your model
doesn't bear or bears a little
resemblance to what people ordinarily
think of as good
because when you fully awaken you will
realize that everyone acts from absolute
good
so that's just something that will
happen
within your consciousness
and then you'll understand that of
course everybody acts from good and evil
has never existed it was never possible
so that's just something you'll realize
when you fully awaken
and and you'll just call everything good
so imagine literally walking down the
street and everything you said you see
you're just like good good good good
good and then you ask yourself where's
the bad and then you realize there isn't
any and then you're just happy and
that's it
i i i i i i i mean it this is this is
the nature of talking about absolutes is
that
we want to have a kind of a logic to
explain the absolute but actually you
can't have a logic to get to the
absolute you first need to get to the
absolute and then you can do logic on it
logic comes afterwards
you can't actually reach it through a
logical process
because logic is finite so it can't be
infinite
i have so you know with you i have i got
i gotta i gotta pee first okay okay
we'll go to the washroom and then we'll
wrap up all right cool
in approximately one or two weeks i'll
post a part two with leo gura this time
focused on him rather than his ideas it
will primarily consist of audience
questions so if you have any questions
for leo leave them down below for now
i'm appending a snippet of matthew
phillips the creator of the app
transcend as hearing the story about why
he created it and how it's used is far
more powerful than reading any message
i'm here with matthew phillips matthew
phillips reached out to me a few weeks
ago
telling me that he has this app and when
i say app it's almost an understatement
he has a project that he wants to run by
me and also run by the viewers of this
channel
it's about
well i'll let
matthew speak about it mainly why i
decided to speak to matthew on air and
have you all listened is because i found
the story to be
inspirational so inspirational i had to
stop him he said save this this is great
we're going to speak on camera because
most of the time for ads you'll just
hear someone read an ad and then you
have no connection to
who created it and why they created it
so who are you and why did you create it
well uh well who am i that's a deep
question but thank you kurt i'm excited
to be here and i
please the audience excuse me i am so
nervous
but
you know
my life about five years ago was was
going swimmingly
i was an enterprise technologist leading
a really large scale
organization uh on the emerging
technology side so all things that are
kind of cool in future and emerging but
more on the enterprise side
but in my personal life i've always
struggled with um
something that's always had me down and
that's that along the way i've lost
really everyone that i've ever loved you
know my mentors my family the people
that raised me the people that really
define me
and as a father now
i've constantly thought about what's the
impact of that and how could i kind of
change that in the future
but it was really about three years ago
where an incident happened and this is
what i shared with you
where i was at home one day and i had an
incident where i didn't think i was
going to make it
and that was one of the scariest
incidents of of my life but not so much
because i feared death it was more
because in that moment i had this great
deep realization that i had utterly
failed in my singular life purpose
that upstairs in my home i had two
children you know my son is now six my
daughter's now four
um that if i didn't make it through the
day i felt like i was abandoning them
for the rest of their life that sure i
may be living in a good house and have
college paid for
but that's not really what life is about
and in that realization i
i felt like an utter failure
that i hadn't taken the time to foster
the one thing that i thought meant more
than anything in that moment and that
was my legacy
and it kind of begs the question what
what is legacy
um
lucky luckily ended up pulling through
and everything's good um
but i never lost sight of that
experience and it deeply touched me in a
way to where
you know going to do the standard nine
to five just didn't cut it anymore i
knew that this was a problem that i had
to solve for people if something like
what i'm creating it had existed when i
was growing up maybe i would still have
access to these people that you know
hung the moon for me
so i thought of a way
you know how could i be there for my
children forever is there a way that we
could create to capture kind of all that
we are
all that we wish to share and all the
important things that we wish to pass
along to the people that mean the most
to us
in a way that could transcend time and
space right and that was really the
genesis of the uh
of the company i started
how often do you think about that
experience that near-death experience
whether or not it's technically a
near-death experience you know what i
mean sure yeah it was life-changing i
think about it every day you know uh
listen the happiest moments are when i
wake up and i hug my kids good morning
when i pick them up from school when i
tuck them in at nighttime they define my
purpose if i
you know
i would have told you that i was waiting
my whole life to figure out what my
purpose was but in that moment i figured
it out i knew it and it was the the best
moment of my life you know scariest but
the best because i understood that you
know maybe this life experience
everything that i've learned everything
that i've been through um you know we go
through life and we have things happen
and we experience life or we gain
knowledge it's like you add
time and perspective in that equation
and hopefully it shakes out his wisdom
right
and it's like what do you do with that
wisdom you kind of shape your value
systems how do i go throughout this
world and interact with people and
others you know how do i love how do i
change it for the better
and um
you know i thought it
it
it was so important for me to capture
those things and pass them along to
stand on the shoulders of how far i've
carried the torch right take it even
better i looked at my one sole purpose
as
you know to create two happy um more
conscious
uh better human beings than i am
and
in those moments i thought have i really
achieved that goal
you know in a few years when they grow
up they're not going to remember a thing
about me i don't remember anything about
my father i lost him too young
but man that it took me to the core so i
looked at this as this panic and i
started out with journaling you know let
me just express myself let me dump it
all into a notepad everything that i
deemed important about life and love and
success and failure but the reality is
kurt they're two and four
you know like these are heavy topics
right what do you mean they're two and
four oh i mean they're at the time
they're ages
right so it was like
what are they gonna do with this is this
appropriate when are they even gonna
think that this is relevant for them to
interact with where is this going to
live so then i switched over to email
addresses right i created gmail
addresses which i don't think is
uncommon for the new parent and i gave
my best friend the password and i said
hey listen i'm going to write these
gmail addresses every time there's a
significant choice or a moment or a
discovery or a lesson i've learned or a
hardship i've gone through and i want to
give my kids the meaning behind it or
the context we'll talk about that later
because that's a big part of transcend
and how we tell stories but
i wanted to give those to him so if
anything ever happened to me again he
would be able to give these email
addresses my son and my daughter would
be able to understand who i was where
they came from what i had hoped for the
the advice for them to live the happiest
most fulfilling most conscious uh lives
possible
and that gave me some peace of mind but
it was cumbersome it was a pain in the
ass it's not easy to do and like where
do you start right like i i was
listening to leo's uh thank you so much
for turning me on to
leo's content i think it's uh amazing
but i was watching a video of his that
said
it was life advice for young people and
it was a multiple hour you know i think
broken up into two videos
where he said
you know i imagine that this is the
culmination of my entire you know life
and all the best things that i've
learned my wisdom my experiences and he
said i imagine
as if i had a son in the future and
maybe i'm dying and he's going to sit
down and watch one video
and how can he
you know uh
best absorb that information what's the
most important things that i could tell
them about traps to avoid and how to be
happy and successful
but not everybody's leo gura we all
can't sit down and riff that for four
hours and even doing it over gmail for
me was tough it's like where do you
start and i heard leo say that like this
is so enormous of an undertaking it's so
it's overwhelming
so that was really the the start of the
idea if there has to be a better way if
i was going to try to figure out a way
to take
everything that is uh curt
and make that consumable for people in a
way that wasn't disposable and was
private and you owned it what would that
look like how would i even go about that
methodology of dissecting what is curt
that's a tough question
so we uh you know i worked with a lot of
professionals and uh we've
figured out a software application that
we think is our best effort of how to do
this and we think we've done a good job
and we're so excited to give it to folks
great in that example you said what is
curt now are you creating for other
people or is it for you to create for
yourself no this is for you to create
for yourself yeah so think of it as
tools to document
you know if i had to distill it down
into one sentence i would say
transcend is an easy to use mobile
application that enables you to document
and preserve
your legacy is the word i'll use
for those that you care about
um
that's really
kind of what i think it is right and
when you think about legacy
you know if your users google this it's
gonna say
you know an amount of money or property
gifted to a descendant but i think on a
human being level we all know a legacy
is so much more deep than that right
so we've given people the tools uh
we call them uh starters for example
to start documenting this stuff right so
we've got thousands of prompts of every
vector of who you are to help you kind
of dive in and pull this info out of you
and prompt you and then allow you to
import that information in some really
creative ways and tell the stories
behind these moments and save them but
most importantly it's safe it's private
it's secure and you own the rights to
everything
and that's a big part of this i mean as
a parent and when i was looking at
creating the software i looked at social
media like a few that have come before
me have tried and failed
um
as a data source and i looked at it like
i'm repulsed by that social media to me
is the
the worst place that you could ever look
for an authentic look at who a human
being is so using that as a data source
went right out the window
so i didn't
social media app
um
but
it it's i had to build something from
scratch that was purpose built for this
and really built on a foundation of
privacy we had to go write the terms of
service the privacy policy i mean we
started from scratch and i don't know if
i can say this but we have the same
lawyers as google and i mean as apple
and facebook they represent us too but
we had to start from scratch and fund
these docu because it's almost the
antithesis it's you own everything i
don't want it i want to be the steward
and protector of your data i want to
help you tell your story and i want to
safeguard it but i want nothing to do
with it just like my memories aren't for
sale my kids aren't for sale my thoughts
feelings ideas they're not for sale they
belong to me they belong to my family
and the people i care about and so
transcends really built as a platform
for you to articulate these things save
them organize them and then transcend
helps you intelligently present them to
the right person at the right time ah
are there export options
uh not yet so yes we have them on the
roadmap but we haven't built them in yet
um but yeah the idea is if you want to
take all your data off my servers it
belongs to you do it take it right
i want to hear firstly
can i remove it okay great and then
second
do you have access to it within your
servers i'm sure
there is some way of you accessing it
but i'm not well i'm not 100 sure so how
do you overcome that
sure uh of course in order to service an
account we have to have the ability to
help people out right if kurt if you
created a memory and said hey my memory
is not functioning correctly i need help
we have to be able to go in there and
help you right
but we've structured this company in a
way that um your privacy can never be
compromised right it's it's there's no
data sharing it's a closed it's a closed
loop
and we did that very very intentionally
and we don't want to be in the business
of looking at your data at all right
this is a service and that's why it's a
paid service right this is a
subscription-based app i should say that
upfront because nothing's free you know
people don't understand when they use
facebook and instagram you're not paying
with your money you're paying with your
privacy and your data i mean
uh i had my sister the other day post a
uh uh something that was like hey if you
were a superhero what superhero would
you be and i had to let her know hey do
you know what that really is that's just
mining your data it's a personality
profile you know like everything that
you do is meant to game you and sell who
you are right so we had to architect the
very nature of transcend to be that
antithesis and because no precedent had
existed we had to be the first ones and
that's that's why i'm confident insane
we're the first ones
so some people listening right now
they're sold in the sense that this
sounds huge
how practically does it work can you
take us through a use case yeah
absolutely so
let's say uh you go to create a post
inside of transcend if you uh or you
capture a moment i think something
that's lacking from all social platforms
is the ability to articulate why it's
important to you or why it's meaningful
nobody cares nobody gives a damn
but as human beings this is literally
what you and i are we are meaning making
machines this is what we do yet somehow
it's been overlooked by everybody you
know
so when you post content on transcend
you're taking through an additional step
of annotation or telling the story
behind it so you can create videos you
can create uh text posts you can create
you know written posts you could create
audio um
and then or a combination of all of
those but then you're taken through an
annotation step where you actually tell
the story of why it's meaningful to you
and then you decide who has access to it
when they have access to it how or where
they have access to it
and then that goes into what we call
your legacy or a timeline for example
right
so as of today we're in step one of a
three-step process it's intuitive
next step is immersive
and then the third step is going to be
interactive
so as of right now you're able to
interact with this content if you have
permission you can go in and experience
it you can go through all the media and
hear the stories of why this is
meaningful right that's kind of step one
that's uh intuitive like a facebook
memory or an apple memory
except we have this edge that nobody
else has and i've probably given up our
secret sauce here um and we've met with
apple um yeah what is the other
but
you know if you look at apple's memories
or facebook's memories they're looking
at tons of metadata to figure out why
things are important to you how many
times did you open it did you share it
did you change the color did you post it
did you add an emoji you know all of
these little data points to say this
must mean something occurred because
he's messing with it a lot right with
transcend we actually get to the heart
of exactly why that's meaningful to you
why and who it's meaningful for outside
of you because you're setting up these
permissions and telling us so this gives
us this extreme edge of being able with
really good accuracy almost eerie
accuracy to be able to promote the
things that are for the right person at
the right time so
you know in the next step this is
beta right now but it's not in
production you know my daughter one day
can pick up the phone and say hey dad
i'm having a really bad day at school
can you tell me a funny story
and it's gonna say well piper's asking
dad that's matt phillips story is a tag
you know funny is a tag it's gonna reach
into this deep you know data ocean that
i've privately built for myself and it's
going to pull out the piece of real
authentic content that i have recorded
and tagged
and then it's going to present that to
her in real time right so
i had somebody in a meeting yesterday
say um oh this is like superman's cave
where he talked to his father in the
crystal i've never seen this but it
seems like a good analogy right so right
now it's it's you're browsing you're
browsing the content and we go the extra
step by capturing the story and the
meaning
but the more data that we have in the
system the better we're getting it
intelligently presenting these memories
and moments to the right person at the
right time so you can interact with them
if that makes sense
now
we go a step further because i realized
hey not everybody's had my experience
not everybody's a parent not everybody
cares about legacy
i would argue that this is more about
meaning and and connection
so we put a lot of tools in here to help
people connect with the people and
and loved ones that they have in real
time
so on top of the props for we call them
insight prompts or insight starters that
all feed your legacy with prompts about
moments and memories
we also have starters that are more for
engagement or connection
so if you want to have a meaningful
conversation with your significant other
about you know how could i be a better
husband for you or tell your kids that
you're proud of them or have a tough
conversation with your boss or your
child or your brother or your mother we
have thousands and thousands of prompts
categorized by situation and
relationship to help you actually really
connect and get below the surface
you